e
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have um
several bills this morning or today to
be heard uh in public heing but before
we get to those I'd like you to please
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
all thank you
everyone the first bill to be considered
today is House Bill 392
FN and uh representative U belter is the
prime sponsor he's already in place
welcome representative belra good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
committee I'm happy to be with you here
this
morning for the record representative
Mike Belcher Wakefield Carol County
District
4 I've brought you this bill this
morning seeking to dissolve several
offices and um divisions within the
executives
Department first these programs ought to
be considered both unlawful and
unconstitutional as they represent
affirmative discrimination by government
based on various mostly immutable
characteristics it was these programs
during covid that promulgated policies
that withheld scarce medical resources
color it was these offices that advanced
concepts such as the social determinance
of Health that are designed to
incorporate political activism into
healthc care based on the premise that
the political environment can affect
Health it is these offices that seek to
shutter politically disfavored industry
and energy resources based on the legal
magic of disperate impact and have
thereby endangered the stability of our
electrical grid and driven prices
up broadly these Concepts represent a
purposeful attempt to flip perceived
hierarchies by elevating the marginal
and punishing the privileged
in other words it defies everyone as
supposedly oppressor or oppressed
departing from the American Constitution
they lean on the social analysis of Carl
Marx and John Jax rouso to justify this
evil as such departing from the American
concept of justice as both impartial and
individual they rather imposed penalties
based on not individual actions but on
identity
characteristics the concepts of Dei
equity and social justice is derived
from the new school of marxist analysis
known as the Frankfurt School famously
existing at Columbia
University these Concepts found their
way into American law and jurist
Prudence largely via Harvard University
critical legal studies under Derek Bell
in the 1980s gave way to critical race
Theory under his student Kimberly
krenshaw a couple decades later with her
supposedly ground breaking Marxist
analysis in mapping the margins in
reality it was little more than what was
already being done by the common turn
almost a century
earlier thankfully these Concepts have
now been roundly rejected by the
American people and the citizens of New
Hamshire at The Ballot Box we were put
in this position to definitively end
these discriminatory punitive and
divisive programs when I filed this bill
it was still a bit of a mystery as to
what position we would be in at this
moment I'm happy to now report that the
position I staked out in this bill is
now reflected in federal policy of the
executive now contrary to any
suggestions that we might lose Federal
funding if we were to move forward with
eliminating these offices on the
contrary we're far more liable to lose
Federal funding if we do
not the Federal Executive has issued a
series of executive orders some of which
I have passed out as handouts to remove
root and Branch all aspects of Dei
including environmental justice
practices from the federal
government the federal Justice or the
federal government the Federal Executive
has declared these programs to be
discriminatory and
unlawful now when the Federal Executive
makes a de a declaration like that
they're not merely opining what they're
saying is that a failure to abide by
their declarations may result in
enforcement actions including under the
Civil Rights Act which would open this
lawsuits as far as the necessity of
having enforcement of civil rights which
I don't dispute that exists in our
department of justice where it belongs
not in any other department where it is
being used to smuggle social justice
into policy
and go around this
legislature we must act it is good and
righteous to act now the people demand
it and our Oaths demand it thank you I
would be happy to take questions thank
Bela representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um a lot of us
here on this committee were Health and
Human Services so we may not be familiar
with some of the Departments I know I'm
not for example familiar with the
Department of Environmental Services um
functions for civil rights and
environmental justice that's kind of
outside of the purview of this
department so could you um I was unaware
that even existed could you describe
what that is and what these functions
are in terms of environmental justice
thank you yes thank you for that
question it's a very good question
so environmental justice is quite
similar to any of the other sort of bad
terms Justice that you've heard uh
thrown around in recent years in that it
doesn't mean American impartial
individual Justice what it means is
social justice applied to a certain
field of policy so what they've done is
they've applied social justice to the
field of environmental policy and what
has happened is through a series of um
less than stellar older judicial
precedents such as disperate impact
they've managed to say that any industry
or energy resource or anything of the
sort that can be argued to have a
disproportionate effect on one group
versus another group can result in civil
enforcement actions and be shut down
under the opes of uh environmental
justice so simply put what that means is
if there's a power plant that is
producing some kind of um environmental
pollution even if it's well mitigated
only a small amount if it can be found
that for instance a power plant might be
found in an area that is dis
disproportionately of lower income well
because that disproportionately affects
people of lower income it can be said to
be discriminatory and therefore they can
use it as a cudle to shut that industry
down and it's been used that way um by
the executive branch for the last
several
years oh
questions I'm representative Maser thank
you Mr chair thank you for being here
today and uh taking my question I see
the last uh the last
sentence um in the description of it as
dissolving the governor's Council on
diversity and inclusion am I correct in
thinking that saying that that he did
dissolve that on his way out of his the
end of his term yes thank you for the
question is my understanding that that
uh advisory Council no longer exists um
however the bill does go on to say that
reestablishment of of such uh advisory
council is prohibited under this bill if
it were to pass so it's still relevant
in terms of going forward thank you
questions I'm seeing none thank you no
oh Mark you got to raise your hand r or
something sorry Mr chair um and thank
you for taking my question so um you
talked a little bit about uh the legal
Jeopardy um we do see certain private
businesses you know Walmart Facebook and
even universities moving away from some
of these programs in many cases um the
universities I think actually favor and
would like to go on with these but they
do see some potential uh legal Jeopardy
but are you aware of any specific
incidents where uh This legal Jeopardy
has manifested itself or is it just the
threat at this
point thank you for the question I don't
have the citations off the top of my
head but yes there have been in recent
years a number of judicial precedents
set I don't think any of them have gone
to scotus yet but there have been at
least lower and appeals score president
set finding that the policies of Dei Dei
J have um been found to be violative of
the Civil Rights Act because they are
not based on the idea of individual
impartial Justice they're based on the
idea of purposfully discriminating
against somebody who's perceived to have
more privilege than somebody
else
followup um so if you don't have those
specific references in front of you
would it be possible for you to after
the fact provide those to the committee
Absolutely I'll find some examples to
send you thank you
uh representative Woods thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh help me out I guess I uh
need clarification on uh in uh uh
section one uh the governor hereby
directed to dissolve the council uh and
it's prohibited from reestablish I is it
the purview of the legislature to tell
the governor what he can and can't do
regarding
Council thank you and that is a very
good question and the end of the day
like like most other things the courts
would be have to step in if there was a
dispute to look at that issue however
generally speaking it is the job of this
legislature to direct the executive in
what to do and on the basic principle
that this commission I believe it was
called uh was established to create uh
and promulgate policy based on Equity
Justice and inclusion and that those
policies themselves go against the
Constitution the Civil Rights Act and
our oath of office they ought not be
reestablished and I believe we do have
the authority to dictate that
yes other
questions representative L
montin thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question why do you believe some of
these programs were set up to begin
worth U thank you for the question so I
went a little bit into the history of it
these these programs were largely
established based on the precedent set
by critical legal Theory which is an
idea that came from Derek Bell at
Harvard University not on his own it was
a it was a followup of uh sort of the
work that had been done at the Frankfurt
School to normalize within American
juror Prudence The Concept that we ought
not treat people always as individuals
but sometimes we should treat them as
groups according to their identity this
made their way into American uh jurist
prudence and many lawyers have been
trained along this lines in time since
um so it was it was a long slow process
to move these Concepts from their
ideological foundations in Columbia
University and other places in America
through Harvard through the legal system
through the Education and Training of
lawyers and judges um it's been a very
long process thank you can I have follow
follow
up
um but you don't have any actual
evidence that people that um helped
bring these programs about were actually
Marxist and and these programs weren't
actually based on empirical evidence
showing disparities of health and
environmental
outcomes uh thank you I think I can find
the question there it was so I I can
along with the uh judicial precedence
that I'll find for you later I can find
for you the name of the book because I
don't remember top of my head it was
something along the lines of an
introduction to critical uh legal Theory
it was a textbook that was utilized uh
at Harvard and and has been utilized by
many others since that identified in
fact that Derek Bell Kimberly krenshaw
and the others who promulgated these
ideas and and moved them out from the
academic sphere into the into the uh
governmental sphere and into policy
marxists other questions
over here representative Nagel and then
representative McKay thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um I I've been working with people a
vulnerable populations patients for a
really long time um I think more
pragmatically than theoretically and I
just wanted to read this to you um do
you have a question yes I do okay the
question's coming from what I read okay
okay so um if you look at the DHHS is
website it talks about the office of
Health Equity that I believe would be
eliminated if if this bill passes it
says they assure Equitable access to
effective quality programs and services
across all populations with specialized
focus on breaking down barriers to care
for vulnerable New Hampshire P residents
in my experience that's a really
important function and I'm just curious
if that goes away how do we replace that
thank you for the question I believe the
keyw there was the very first word that
was in that state stat Equitable access
it is not equal access it is not access
that looks determinant at who has the
greatest need Equity by definition looks
at People based on identity
characteristics not upon based upon need
which is the same reason that these uh
these offices promulgated the idea
during covid-19 that withheld scarce
resources on the basis of skin color not
need Al that I know but I'll I'll stop
there representative McKay thank you Mr
chairman the the first part of this
legislation is not is not needed which
you know the second part says we can
never do it again I find that
peculiar uh that telling the legislature
what we can't do most
legislation tells us what we can do
actually do you have a question
represent
do you believe that that is an
appropriate um use of
legislation thank you for that question
and just to be clear I do not believe it
does that at all that's actually a
misreading of that this tells the
executive branch what it can and cannot
do in the future it does not in any way
bind this legislature which we ought to
know according to our own rules and and
President we can't pass anything that
binds future legislators so they could
undo this if they wanted to down the
road that would be up to them in passing
further
legislation thank you other questions
representative Markel thank you for
taking my question um earlier uh earlier
sir you mentioned that this is
unconstitutional did I hear that
correctly that in other words what's
presently going on is unconstitutional
did I hear that correctly yes I believe
the policies themselves have be
unconstitutional what okay but this is
you would agree would you not that this
is basically
Health regulation do I have that correct
health and safety
regulation I I would say it goes a lot
deeper than that it goes to a basic
concept of what Justice is and what
Justice is under the Constitution versus
what Justice is under a paradigm of
social justice okay but not necessarily
social justice but we're here in front
may may follow up thank you thank you so
um my concern is is that I think you
suggested that this is unconstitutional
analysis I wouldn't say it's based on a
strict scrutiny analysis because I'm not
trying to take into account government
extreme need to regulate versus the uh
unique and very narrow tailoring of law
this is a this is a more fundamental
principle actually strict analysis
strict scrutiny isn't actually a
constitutional principle it's a legal
principle based on Jud raal precedent so
no it's not based on strict uh that
analysis it's based on the
concept uh that you can find in the
Constitution for instance that you know
the same idea that requires us to give
somebody a trial by jury is the concept
that they are liable only for their own
actions and the people of of that that
they're a part of the community with are
the ones who will ultimately judge them
in that social justice takes a very
different tact and it suggests that
people will be uh judged not necessarily
by trial by jury but trial by media
trial in the public sphere where they
are presumed guilty instead of being
Presumed Innocent based on their
identity characteristics not their
actions okay follow up may I follow up
thank you okay but you would agree that
this is basically health and safety
regulations on its face I would agree
that it touches on that but it's a much
broader and higher principle than that
okay see I'm thinking that this would
because you mentioned earlier that it
was unconstitutional and I'm thinking
that this is if this is health and
safety regulation it basically gets
rational basis review which means all it
has to do is be legitimately related to
a rational government objective and uh
that's basically the standard of review
which um allowed dos to be able to be
carried the way it was and I'm
suggesting that um it probably is
constitutional you may have different
arguments with
that we can cover that in executive
session representative okay thank you no
further
questions representative TZ thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so you mentioned that um the
existence of the office of Health Equity
and the other two entities is
discriminatory so do you have any
evidence of that discrimination here in
New
Hampshire yes I I can point to the uh
policies that were promulgated during Co
that specifically took a certain amount
of of vaccine when was early available
new roll out was not available for
everyone yet and withheld a certain
amount of that not based on need not
based on the fact that we know elderly
were most vulnerable so perhaps it
should have gone entirely to elderly but
it withheld I believe it was 10% at the
time specifically on the basis of skin
color we also had that same thing happen
with um uh the antibodies that were
available at certain hospitals for a
brief period of time follow follow so um
the office of the udman is who takes
complaints from individuals of
discrimination so do you have any
evidence of any individuals um filing
concerns about discrimination based on
existence of the office of Health Equity
given that the example you cited of um
uh the vaccine distribution was actually
court I'm sorry can you repeat what the
question was there so the example you
provided for discrimination was already
thrown out by two lawsuits that were um
found to not have Merit of being
discrimination based on the vaccine
policy that was rolled out um so I'm
asking do you have any evidence of
discrimination and a need for this
particular Bill thank you I I understand
the question now I would not look to
judicial president to determine whether
something is discriminatory or not I
would look to Common Sense to find that
discriminatory and I would say that we
can adjust judicial precedent in this
body by passing this law thank you one
more followup yeah so are you aware of
the concept of population he and the
institute for healthcare Improvement
basically being the world's leader for
how Health Quality can be Advanced and
they have said that there can be no
quality if we do not address
Equity I'm not aware of that specific
body but I'm aware that these Concepts
these Concepts that were promulgated
based on Marxist social analysis have
been broadly taken in the field yes
other questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so you covered a
lot uh how this programs are
unconstitutional but uh I wonder if you
have any data on the effectiveness uh if
we assume that the goal is uh to help
those who are in in need or certain uh
demographics
so when we look at identity like if we
close energy plant in a poor
neighborhood does it actually help that
poor neighborhood or if we uh Target
some um some uh ethnic or racial
demographic and deliver them uh vacines
that are not stopping transmission does
it actually help them so do this program
programs
help thank you for the question so this
is one of those situations where despite
the fact that there is clearly some need
for regulation in the marketplace to
make sure things don't go Ary in this
circumstance it would be much better if
we just got out of the way because we're
actually requiring through the policies
prolongated from these offices
discrimination we are requiring that
people be treated unequally not on the
basis of need but on other immutable
characteristics such as skin color now
what you've referred to now within the
I'm sure you're probably all aware
within the concept of medicine and
rationing of scarce resour ources there
will be circumstances where it is
correct and good to withhold a scarce
resource primarily for a person of One
race or another but it's not based on
their race it's based on their need that
is correlated to their race that's the
difference if there's a need there's
there's nothing preventing any of that
from happening but when you're doing it
on the basis of race without taking need
into account because you're looking at
it on the oppressor versus oppressed
hierarchy and trying to flip that that's
what this these programs do and that's
what we need to
eliminate representative T is uh please
remember that we're not here to debate
just get it information well I'm just a
little confused because can you share
your definition of Health Equity because
every definition I know is about
providing what people need based on
their individual circumstances such as
people with disabilities who who um uh
may need a wheelchair or people who are
blind who may need Braille the rest of
us don't get it but it's because we
don't need it so it is about providing
what people need so please show your
definition thank you I would what I
would say about that is it leaves out
the fact that it interprets that need on
the basis of group not individual need
if you so it would look at a person of a
certain skin color and say because of
historical circumstances or whatever
else is going on this group may have a
greater need because they're UN
underperforming in this area or whatever
than this other group and it will
thereby treat everybody within that
group under that Paradigm instead of
looking at them as individuals who have
an individual need which may or may not
Paradigm okay we do need to move on any
final
representative uh Ju Just for the uh
everyone's uh information uh the
practice of this committee is to give
the prime sponsor additional time the
the purposes of explaining the
background of the bill why it was
introduced and so forth but uh it is
also the practice of this committee to
ask that all those testify and keep
their testimony to three minutes that
allows not only for others behind you
the a chance to testify gives everybody
an equal opportunity and we do have
quite a few people who do want to
testify but it also allows the committee
members to have time for ample questions
of of you and and much of what you might
not cover in your testimony if you run
out of town time could be covered in
that manner so please be respectful of
the time constraints and we will be
timing uh testimony this morning uh next
up to speak is uh the um represent
excuse me attorney John Williams and
Associate commissioner Anne Landry from
Services again there's there's two of
you so it's three minutes up up to three
minutes a piece but
um you've asked for three to five so
obviously the quicker you can make it
the better okay thank you good morning
chairman McDonald and members of the
House Health and Human Services and
elderly Affairs committee my name is an
not and Landry and I am associate
commissioner at the Department of Health
and Human Services and I'm here today
with my colleague and for the record my
name is John Williams I'm the
legislative director for the Department
of Health and Human Services and we do
appreciate the opportunity to come
before this committee to provide
information yes thank you um in addition
to being the associate commissioner I've
overseen the office of Health Equity for
the last 5 years and I appreciate the
time this morning to share with you some
very um serious concerns regarding HB
392 as introduced specifically sections
24 and five and the negative health and
financial implications to New
Hampshire's residents healthc care
providers local municipalities and the
states um and the state itself should
the office of Health it be
dissolved the vision of DHHS is Optimal
Health and well-being for everyone and
the mission is to join communities and
families in providing opportunities to
achieve health and Independence again
this is for all New Hampshire residents
and
citizens the office of Health Equity
serves three primary functions in
support of all of the Department's
program areas and divisions in
eliminating barriers to access for
direct and contracted Health Services to
achieve this vision and Mission the
three primary functions of O are
ensuring compliance with communication
access and disability federal and state
laws engaging with the Department
leadership and staff as well as the
community and providers in to facilitate
access to care for all residents and
overseeing the ferally funded and
mandated state Refugee resettlement
program so I'll address each of those
three buckets quickly in our time frame
um and please jump in if you have
anything but o oversees the Department's
communication access Services Program
for staff and any individual receiving
services from the Department this
ensures the state's deaf and heart of
hearing visually comp um visually
impaired and those with limited English
proficiency have full access to all of
our services and related information
these are services that they're legally
eligible for and
deserve the office insures the
department is compliant with the Civil
Rights Act of
1965 title six American with
Disabilities Act of 1990 Section 504 of
The rehabilit Rehabilitation Act of
1973 and RSA 521 A-5 among others the
office also advises contract compliance
for all of our provider Partners on
these federal and state laws ensuring
that their services are also um
accessible with all the communication
act access standards that they're
required to abide by the elimination of
O would greatly jeopardize the
Department's ability to ensure access to
all individuals requiring and receiving
Services Not only would we have
individuals with disabilities not
getting the care they need but also the
department would be in violation of
several federal and state laws which
would put the state at risk for
countless lawsuits and financial
penalties additionally when residents
are unable to access the care they need
in a timely manner It ultimately puts a
strain on the hospitals and Health Care
Systems leading to potential increases
in emergency room weight times and in
uncompensated care this is for critical
hospitals this this is for academic
hospitals this is for your large
tertiary Care Centers and all Community
providers the second point is that ogag
serves as a key Community Ambassador and
facilitator across the state in
understanding all barriers to access for
Health and Human Services for all New
Hampshire residents and helps to
strategize with Community Partners on
how to best address these
barriers the leadership and staff of O
receive Outreach daily from constituents
with complex health needs both the
clients and their providers from across
the state who are struggling on how to
navigate our health care System the team
helps with the immediate need of that
individual or the provider advocating on
behalf of that individual but then also
addresses the larger barrier to Care by
commun uh convening with the different
Community stakeholders and
providers the barriers to care addressed
by o on a daily basis include
Transportation communication access
again for the DEA hardened hearing and
Visually Impaired hous housing and
connection to primary and substance use
care for individuals who are re-entering
our community after incarceration just
one more minute often a requirement for
release and and important to reduce
reism we Minimate the office minimizes
cost of healthcare system by helping key
individuals um keeping them out of
assisted living and in their homes by
ensuring the Right Care at the right
time in the right place at the right
cost very critical to saving money in
the state New Hampshire you could start
wrapping up please okay the last part is
um so eliminating this would would
disrupt the coordination of care across
the state and then the last piece is
that we oversee the 100% federally
funded Refugee resettlement program
which moved into the the Department of
Health and Human Services from the
office of the government in
2012 um this is 100% federally funded
all these individuals are here legally
but the ability to integrate this
program into the office of Health Equity
and DHHS allows us to have the fiary
oversight of these federal funds which
allows for more effective and efficient
use of these funds and allows us to help
the refugees achieve indeep um economic
independence and self-sufficiency
earlier if the office were to be
dissolved we will lose this program
would exist outside the state government
we would lose all control over these
funds and there would be a burden placed
on the municipalities in which these
refugees reside which are the major
primarily the major cities in in New
Hampshire so just to wrap up again
looking at communication access in
compliance with federal and state laws
our ability to knock down all barriers
of care for every single resident in the
state of New Hampshire and to continuing
to help refugees um achieve in economic
independence as soon as possible thank
you I'm happy to answer any questions
representative Paz off thank you Mr
chair and thank you for um taking my
question uh could you go back into
history when your office was created and
like what what parts of U DHS or other
uh departments were um taking were
helping with this functions before it
was
created um the office was created in the
late 90s and over the last 26 years or
so different different components of um
of the office had been integrated into
that office for better coordination and
functionality representative Maser thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question and thank you for being here
today um you mentioned the refugee
resettlement services that you offer and
that if this were to go away in your
department um what would happen are
there not other organizations such as
the international National Institute of
New Hampshire asentria ET Etc
that do somewhat of the same thing thank
you for your question the in
international institution of New England
and the in asent are are are two
resettlement agencies in the state of
New Hampshire that are part of a na um
the federally approved Refugee
resettlement services so we contract
with them to deliver the services
required by the federal government if
the office um of refugee resettlement
was removed from DHHS or the state
government there would be a different
organization outside state government
that would administer those funds for
the federal government whether it's one
of those two resettlement agencies I'm
not sure or if it would be a different
entity that would be set up in the state
of New Hampshire that that would then
contract with those two resolvement
agencies representative Nagel thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question I think the hot word in all
this is that word equity um and I'm just
curious um so in the State Health
assessment and implementation plan we
thought that word was so important that
we spent two days discussing what it
actually meant and we came up with a
working definition and I'm curious if
you have a working definition that
defines what you mean when you use the
term for the office of Health Equity and
for this you know the Department of
Health and Human Services we really look
at the word Equity equity as addressing
the health needs of every individual in
the in the state of New Hampshire
ensuring that every New Hampshire
resident has access to care whatever
that means for that
kofel thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so um following
up on representative maser's
question um you indicated that if um
refu Refugee resettlement program were
eliminated within
DHHS then those Services would likely be
contracted with an outside agency you
also said that if that office were
eliminated from
DHHS then we would have a a problem in
which cities and towns would be taking
on the expenses and the burdens
associated with Refugee resettlement so
I'm trying to square those two
statements because it seems to me that
if the federal government were going to
be contracting with an outside agency
then it would not put burdens on cities
and to pick up the the slack can you
explain yes thank you um for the
question and I I did rush through my
last my last part in in that section um
so yes if if the office of the refugee
resettlement program existed outside
state government there would still be
federal funds for that program however
its existence within DHHS allows for
better integration with the the programs
in which these refugees are already are
legally required to receive whether it's
some of the SNAP tanif benefits are
specific to refugees um some of our
Medicaid programs specific to refugees
and so positioned in DHHS it allows for
better integration it also allows us for
to use our contract compliance um and
fiary skills that and expertise that we
have um and allows us to better
integrate the services and program and
allows us oversight over these programs
to ensure that the funds are used
efficiently and effectively to help the
refugees achieve economic and health
Independence other
questions representative lontine thank
you thank you Mr chair thanks for taking
my question do you know of any rules or
policies at
DHHS that would deny anyone care based
on the color of their skin as the prime
sponsor has
suggested not to my knowledge no
other questions representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and um thank you
for taking my question so um the the
three bullets that you've kind of lined
out here I I don't think uh anybody
would dispute that they have enormous
value um at least I wouldn't dispute it
um so but again following up on uh
representative L montine question the
the focus is not saying the distribution
of covid vaccines is or is not important
those things are all important so I
guess my question would be with respect
to the approach that you take
um how is there are there incidences
where you are going to look at and say
this community needs Service as a
community more and so we're going to
focus delivery on a community- based
approach as opposed to an
individual-based approach and I think
that was because nobody's disputing that
these three bullets are important the
the question is related to the approach
that thank you for the question so if if
I understand correctly it's whether your
question is around whether we're focused
on one Community or another or the
individuals within the
community is that correct yes in other
words the the the concern of the Prime
sponsor was that in seeking to advance
the good of the community it is
sometimes necessary to subordinate the
good of the individual and that was his
concern and so what I'm just trying to
get at is your practice and how you how
you conduct that and how you ensure that
that does not happen of course so our
office the the part of um the office of
Health Equity that would help in that
part is really listening to all
communities and and and that's all
provider ERS all community members and
looking at the barriers within sometimes
there are barriers that are specific to
a certain region right we have a very
rural State we have a lot of homebound
seniors we have transportation is a huge
issue sometimes access to Primary Care
in the rural region access to recovery
so they might look at a community like a
geographically and say what are the
barriers to care in that region and help
knock down those barriers with the
community members and the providers but
not weighing one community over another
Community or one individual over uh a
different individual really convening
and facilitating and understanding is
there a Gap in primary care of doctors
is there a Gap in substance use recovery
is there a Gap in um case managers for
inhome care for those Aging in in home
so really looking at some of those
broader themes um at a strategic
level other questions representative
TZ thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question question
um sort of hidden in the middle of the
language of the bill it says um DHHS is
hereby director to dissolve the office
of Health Equity and is prohibited from
reestablishing this office or using any
allocated monies for any project labeled
as Health Equity can you tell us what it
would mean for the Department of Health
and Human Services to be prohibited from
doing Health Equity across all of the
Department of Health and Human Services
um at this time we don't have projects
or programs labeled Health Equity we
have Federal funding and general and
general funds for different programs
that are specific to whatever you know a
grant comes in and it's addressing one
need or another and there's specific um
regulations and use U appropriate uses
of those funds but as a whole we don't
have programs or projects labeled Health
Equity
but I but I could follow up with that in
addition to social commissioner Landry's
uh certainly it serves a very important
function to make sure that the other
program areas um are aligned in terms of
any requirements under federal law for
administration of their their programs
thank
you one followup please so just um if
you could expand on that we the fiscal
note focuses on the cost within the
office that might be saved um but you
did mention that not complying with
Federal civil rights law puts a lot of
um money at risk because we are supposed
to all the department and Health and
Human Services programs should align
with compliance so can you can you
repeat or tell us like potentially
What's the magnitude of that
scale so I'm thank you for your question
Dr T is I'm not prepared to give a
financial number of what we we are we
have not done that financial analysis of
what the potential penalties are because
we don't know
how what that would even mean at this
point I mean as far as the the number of
violations that we would incur if we did
not offer communication access and we
didn't comply with federal and state
laws but we
have numerous residents across the state
that are deaf and heart of hearing that
are visually impaired where English is
the second language they have a right to
access all of the information and all
the services and if they can't get the
information they can't access access the
service services and therefore we are at
Li we are liable um for for that lack of
care if you will for that individual so
I can't quantify it today
um and if I could add to uh associate
commissioner Landry's um um answer
response back that the question is it's
posed is looking at the bill under the
for hunters of the document and an
elimination an elimination of the
program you know I think our goal here
today was to provide educational
opportunity for you to make an informed
decision about what actually the program
does and Associate uh commissioner
Landry did a a very concise fine job of
doing it the question and flipping it on
the other end of it well what value is
it to the program as it currently exist
in terms of cost savings so for example
we know in long-term care it's better
for people to age in place so that costs
annually around 24,000 a year versus if
somebody has delayed services and
requires higher cuity care you're going
to be entering into a nursing facility
uh and the average cost of that is
$74,000 so there is many cost savings
that are currently occurring as a result
of the current configuration of that
particular uh entity within our
department thank you one one more
question representative Maser yes thank
you thank you Mr chair um can you just
tell me how many employees If This Were
to pass how many employees would be so
if these were dissolved how many would
be impacted what what's the number of
employ emplo es we're looking at we
currently have 11 positions within the
office of Health
Equity it's follow follow up what about
the Department of Environmental Services
that commission will be testifying I
Commissioner okay thank you thank you
much and speaking of Environmental
Services we have Adam quo the assistant
Commissioner of Environmental Services
up
next and the commissioner uh again if
you could keep it as close to three
minutes as
possible thank you oh there a two of you
okay so you've asked for five this to we
you so okay we we'll keep it brief um
thank you good morning my name is Adam
crepo thank you for the committee uh for
having us here today I'm the assistant
commissioner at the Department of
Environmental Services and I have here
with me my colleague than joyle um she's
our the head of our legal unit at the
department um like I said I'll keep it
brief you know we we this this bill
proposes to prohibit the department from
using any allocated funds uh for project
for projects labeled civil rights and
environmental justice the department
doesn't take a position on this bill
however we do want to make the committee
aware of some of the concerns that we
have um de is required to ensure
activities funded with Federal monies
are in compliance with the Civil Rights
Act of
1964 specifically we are required to
adhere to title 6 which is intended to
prohibit discrimination on the basis of
race color and national origin and
programs and activities receiving
federal financial
assistance if a recipient of federal
assistance is found to have
discriminated and Vol voluntary
compliance is not achieved the federal
agency providing the assistance is
required to initiate fund uh termination
or refer the matter to the Federal
Department of
Justice um so in in addition to that we
are required to comply with the ad uh
Americans for Disabilities Act as well
that's the Ada and so the having the
bill say we can't work on projects
labeled civil rights and environmental
justice would put s significant federal
funds in Jeopardy um we did give a a
range in the fiscal note of 80 to $90
million of federal funds and those are
for various infrastructure projects that
the federal government Prov provides
funding for um and many other programs
and and and other things that we do with
the
Department um regarding the term e uh
environmental justice uh that's
a it's a long-standing term I think if
you asked anyone on the committee uh or
or anyone at the department what that
term specifically meant I think you'd
get many different answers um but at at
its core you know over the last few
years the federal government has had a
an emphasis on ensuring that the
department um adheres to uh some of the
executive orders that they have at one
point one of the executive orders uh
required for any discretionary grants
that 40% go to um environmental justice
community so uh and basically how we
label that as any disadvantage
communities low
communities um that executive order has
been repealed um so we are really what
that means for us now is just good
customer service and historically what
we've done is if someone asks for a you
know translation services for documents
or a translator at a public meeting we
we offer those Services uh as a courtesy
we we think that's good customer service
but that's at this point that's the
extent of what we do under the I I guess
what I would say the opes of
environmental justice um you know so
that's that's that's really where we're
at we we think
that it is a good thing to offer those
to anyone who who needs them uh good
example I know there there was a project
in naswa that had uh that was being
proposed in uh Community with uh a lot
of individuals who uh were not
proficient in
in English and so we did offer
translation services down there at a
request of uh one of the groups that
that represents that Community to ensure
that they understood what the uh what
the project was doing and and what what
what was being proposed there and so
that's that's a good example of how um
we offer these types of services we it's
really meaningful engagement in making
sure that folks can interact with the
Department um so with that I I you know
I'm happy to take any questions I don't
know if you want to add anything but um
I happy to take questions from the
committee thank you representative mea
did you want to follow up the question
from before yes thank you Mr chair um
how many employees in the department of
environmental services so we have in the
department we have more than uh around
500 employees but in any program where
there is an individual who who works on
a project or a program that has Federal
funding attached to it we are required
to adhere to the Civil Rights Act and so
that is so it's not any one person
specifically that's working on uh the
Civil Rights piece it's it's a it's a
group of folks that uh throughout the
department it's not anyone's one duty
it's part it's kind of baked into the
duties at the department um in in those
roles on the environmental justice side
uh we don't have anyone working
specifically on environmental justice
what we do have is someone who does
provide and and coordinates language
access and as I mentioned those services
like uh providing translation for
documents um or information relative to
uh any any of the services we provide if
if someone needs it with a disability or
some other um some other
issue that they that that they're facing
so follow up yes thank you so I'm
looking at the fiscal note where it's it
it says
$100,000 with 500 employees it it seems
like it would be a lot more than that is
that correct in assuming
that so for the for the fiscal I'd have
to take a look at the fiscal note we we
provided an estimate for that one
person's position for that individual
who provides language access that was
specifically what was asked for um for
that as that's kind of labeled
environmental justice and that's and
that's what what that would cost on the
Civil Rights side it would be a much
larger um fiscal impact as I mentioned
in the order of $90 million potentially
that's the range of what the EPA could
look at and say you're not you're not
making sure folks have a pathway for um
you know if they discriminated against
you know one of our subrecipients for
example if they discriminated against
somebody uh you need a pathway to be
able to make that complaint and and we
do offer
that representative McKay and then
representative
McLean thank you Mr
chairman I'm not sure if my hearing was
correct did did you say that this
legislation would jeopardize up to 80 to
well what I what I said was they that is
the amount of federal funding that is
subject to title six of the Civil Rights
Act and we have to make sure that we
provide a pathway for someone
to um if they're discriminated against
under any of our federal programs to
make a complaint under that um we need
to make sure that all of our all of our
programs that receive federal funding
but also our subrecipients are adhering
to title six of the Civil Rights Act and
so that is the universe of funding that
if EPA were to ever or any other Federal
agency that were receive funds from were
to do an audit or some sort of other
check on whether or not we're we're
we're adhering to that that uh part of
the ACT then that those funds could be
in Jeopardy I that's just the universe
it's I I'm not suggesting that that is
uh likely to happen I but what I am
suggesting is that is the universe
that EPA could look at and say okay
you're not adhering to the Civil Rights
Act and that that's what could be at
Jeopardy depending on what what what
they find so thank you representative
mlan thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so just to clarify
when uh dhss testified that they talked
about the the kind of three-legged stool
that they have um within the um uh the
office of Health Equity and
that if this bill were to become law
basically that stool gets broken and
everything has to get scattered and so
they lose a little bit of that cohesion
um however with your department if this
bill were to become law um you would
still be providing translation services
you would still be if someone had a
complaint processing that complaint so
um really if this law was to
pass would there be any real change in
the way that you
operate on the environmental justice
side likely not on the Civil Rights
because we we are not branding an
environmental justice at this point
because that Federal executive order has
been rescinded we it is a it is
merely just good customer service that
we're providing on the Civil Rights side
if someone were to make a complaint we
would not be able to process that
complaint because the text of the bill
says we cannot work on anything labeled
civil
rights follow up I think I got it thank
you okay other
you also signed up to speak is
representative Jess Edwards from
markingham County District
31 and again representative if you could
minutes uh thank you Mr chair I'm
representative Jess Edwards uh
representing Rockingham District 31 um I
uh have served as the uh chair of
division three for the last um two
budgets now going on three uh I'm also
been a member of HHS oversight
and in in these five years uh I've had
uh an opportunity to speak with the
Department because the word uh health or
the phrase Health Equity has jumped out
at me as well and um I think uh we've
got a situation where whoever came up
with the name of that department really
regrets it uh because you they couldn't
forecast how the the name would U
basically
um become synonymous with uh actual
discrimination uh and not real equity
and and so I've been asking repeatedly
and been told uh each time probably five
six times in public hearings some in
private what do you do to run these
programs and what they're looking to do
it it was said break down barriers to
access they're trying to make sure that
those Among Us that are less um aware
culturally because they're new they're
refugees or they're less abled than we
are um uh they're they have less
proximity to Medical resources than than
most do uh th those demographic
populations that are not predicated
strictly on race
um uh they can be cultural they can be
Geographic it's whatever forms that
demographic that what they're looking to
do is to ensure um that uh access to
care is
equal they are not trying to make sure
they're not trying to have any
individual demographic get Superior Care
it's just a search to remove barriers to
make sure that we all have an equal
access to care and uh of all the
programs they've mentioned I've been
pretty okay with them doing that I'm a
little concerned about the housing
program I wish I had a chance to do a
deep dive into that one um but um I I
unless they've been lying to me in
testimony for the last five years I I
would say that this is a program that by
and large um most of us can agree to
we're trying to make sure that our our
citizens our our fellow citizens get uh
access to the kind of care that our
society expects we're not trying to put
the thumb on the scale to give somebody
Superior access it's all about equality
and that's why they've done things like
mobile Vans to go out into the community
to make things available um and so so uh
that that that's really what I wanted to
say is I I've I've spent more time with
this group than most legislators have
and and I've gone into it cynical
because I'm cynical and each time I've
gone into it with my cynicism fully
activated I've been comfortable that the
DHHS Health office of Health Equity is
is probably doing good work I'd like to
cut it a little bit because because we
need the money but but that's a
different issue thank you any questions
for representative
you hopefully I pronounced this
correctly uh also signed up to speak is
than joyle I believe it is from the
am I not pronouncing
that second get a second opinion here
Bane joy joy joyle Environmental
Services wasn't she the oh maybe she was
with the commissioner commissioner sorry
about
that okay also signed up to speak and
this is another tricky one um I believe
it's from the Department of Public
Health
and again you've asked for five minutes
if you could keep it closer to three I'd
appreciate
it and please please put your microphone
on the button at the base thank you
there you go you can tell it's my first
time thank you and thanks for having me
here my name is IA
Munos and I am a concerned Nashua
resident and the the health and Health
Equity officer for the national division
of Public Health and Community Services
one of those positions that um is
controversial right now with the name um
I am a Hispanic Latina woman I'm the
wife of a non-english speaker and the
mother of two Hispanic Latino boys one
of them is bilingual and the other one
is a native English
speaker not for by choice he has a
disability a speech
disability um I am here to testify in
support of the office of Health Equity
their role is to ensure Equitable access
to high quality the HHS programs and
services for all populations in our
state with a focus on breaking down
barriers which is what we have been
speaking to care for New Hampshire's
most vulnerable residents I'm going to
repeat vulnerable
residents the office of Health Equity
has provided strategic guidance training
and coaching to our department fostering
an ongoing process of organizational
improvements and cultural
Effectiveness their work supports our
programs in the nashal region ensuring
compliance with the Ada and class
standards and providing critical
assistance to new Americans as they
navigate life in our
state as someone who has personally
taken English language classes and
courses I totally understand firsthand
the challenges and opportunities that
comes with learning a new language and a
new culture in both my personal and
professional life I have seen how access
to language learning resources can open
doors the office of Health Equity plays
a crucial role in making these resources
available by securing funding and
offering strategic
support through their coaching and
guidance I have gained valuable insights
on improving Public Health
Communications ensuring that Vital
Information reaches our community
Through radio TV and newsletters as a
bilingual professional I prioritize
sharing Public Health Resources in both
Spanish and English so that all
residents regardless of their language
can access essential services that is
what Health Equity is all
about the office of of Health Equity
also supports immigrant integration
through the state Refugee program
assisting refugees in becoming
self-sufficient and adapting to life in
the United States their collaboration
with local Regional and National
stakeholder strengths the New Hampshire
communities I'm almost there I'm sorry
um New Hampshire communities by building
our Community Asset um sharing knowledge
and developing resources um that promote
opportunity and well-being additionally
they provide critical training to Our
Community Partners on language
accessibility and ensure that tools of
the death and heart of hearing Community
are widely promoted and utilized if you
could start wrapping up please yes the
leadership of the office of Health
Equity is essential to fostering a
healthy safe and thriving Community when
everyone has the opportunity to achieve
good health we all benefit I think we
all agreed on that uh investing in the
office of Health Equity is an in
investment in our well-being as a
community I strongly urge you to oppose
House Bill 392 and show your support for
a Gran Staters in achieving Optimal
Health and Equity wellbeing thank you so
questions I just have one question can
you spell your last name for me sure
Munos m u n o
z thank
you other questions yes
you also signed up to speak is former
representative Joe Shapiro former member
of this committee welcome back
representative
Shapiro representative Shapiro knows it
real he even put down three minutes as
as the amount of time he wanted
so thank you chairman McDonald and
committee members and it's a um pleasure
and and a privilege to be back here um
to testify in opposition to House Bill
392 um how did I not know that
everything I came prepared to talk about
would already be talked about by the
time I got here um got to the microphone
so I I will try to limit my comments to
um some of the
practicalities
um and to try to put a human face on
some of the issues that we've already
talked about
one of the themes that
um one of the themes that was often
Central to our debates in this committee
during my six years on this committee
was the theme of building
self-reliance how many discussions did
we have in this committee about
providing specific benefits and services
for lowincome individuals or disabled
individuals or individuals with mental
health and substance use issues isues um
or people who just had a untimely
medical crisis in their life how many
times did we talk
about um whether the
said benefits that we were talking about
giving people um would they create
create more resilience more well-being
more health and more um Independence in
the future
or would those same benefits
create more dependence and lock people
into a cycle of poverty and
dysfunction that was frequently what the
discussion came came
to I'm going to talk specifically about
the refugee program within the office of
Health Equity the refugee program does
the former fully funded by federal
dollars it works to Foster integration
and help refugees achieve
self-sufficiency as quickly as possible
working through the two resettlement
nonprofits it promotes English language
proficiency cultural integration and
employment
skills while immigration can be a
divisive
issue this is what the vast majority of
Americans say they want that newcomers
follow the rules that they learn to
speak English that they become good me
members and good standing in their
communities and that they work to
support themselves and their families
while filling very important
um empty jobs in our in our
state this is exactly what the refugee
program promotes this kind of
resilience um this kind of
um
self-sufficiency and if I could have
just another minute I'd like to just put
a human face on this program so in my
neighborhood um couple of blocks away
for me a family was resettled by A
Century Of Care Alliance um they are a
family of two adults a married couple
and a 13-year-old son so when they when
people were evacuated from Afghanistan
in
2022 um they were brought um first to
Italy then to this country then to
conquered and finally to Keen to be
resettled by the American Military and
by the American government um both
adults had been shot by the Taliban and
have um you know wounds that have um
that have not completely healed um the
father of the family worked in security
for the American
Military um since arriving in this
country country they have um the father
has worked at the Cheshire Medical
Center um he works the night shift
because he can make a pay differential
so he can send home money to his family
in Afghanistan he takes every bit of
um overtime pay that he can overtime
hours that he can take so he can send
more money back to Afghanistan for the
first two years before he got his
driver's license and before he was able
to buy a car he rode his bike um at 10
o'clock at night to the hospital two
miles away and back start wrapping up
and back at 6:00 in the morning these
are the kind of families that get when
they first come get help through the
refugee program at the office of Health
Equity and I hope that you will take the
actual people that this affects into
consideration when you take your vote on
this on on this bill I urge you to vote
it L on 392 thank you any questions
representative n thank you Mr chairman
thanks for it's nice to see you again um
I'm sorry you're in the seat when I'm
thinking asking this question but I know
you well enough that I think you can
answer it one of the statements that
I've heard over and over again um has
been that you know you know historically
we used um private sector nonprofit um
ecumenical Serv whatever to provide the
services that DHHS is providing riding
now and some people are saying well
maybe we should be going back to doing
that again to save the taxpayer money do
we have um do you think the um the
structure in place that we can do that
in an in outside of the government to
provide those services in a cost
manner thank you so that this has
already been brought up before um and I
um
I did hear people say that the money
would not necessarily go away although
the money seems to have gone away any
case um but it would not necessarily go
away because of this bill but um funds
would be administered by private
nonprofits um what I would say to that
is that I think the Department of Health
and Human Services is better able to
provide oversight and effective ad
administration of those funds and I
believe that this is something that
our my government my state government
should be involved in because I think
it's really important and I think we
have a stake in
um bringing refugees to this country and
making sure that they become
self-sufficient making sure that they're
able to fill jobs that we desperately
need filled um and I think that state
government government is the best um
funds did I say a hand up over here
earlier apparently not anyone else any
other
you also signed up to speak is Brianna
testimony you want to you have it to
distribute or just yeah to distribute
yeah just just drop it off with
representative McGrath and she'll pass
it around she'll pass it
down is it the spelling of your last
hello my name is Brianna hle I'm the
legal policy fellow at new Futures new
Futures is a non um nonprofit
nonpartisan Health Organization that
solves New Hampshire problems through
policy change um new Futures opposes HB
392 and my testimony will focus on the
office of Health Equity and DHHS a lot
of what I planned on saying has already
been said so I'll talk about a specific
program that um DHS helps run and um
create accessibility so one example is
the 988 Suicide Hotline it has
capabilities for video calls for people
who are death or hard of hearing the
office of Health Equity is key to
providing policy strategic guidance
training coaching and technical
assistance across the entire department
so the critical Emergency Services like
the 988 Suicide Hotline remain
accessible for all grand
saders um new Futures requests the
committee to oppose HB
392 um and I can answer any questions if
needed a lot of what has been said is
already in the written testimony as well
okay great thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Richard
Hampshire thank you Mr chairman my name
is Richard Menard I'm the executive
director
a building community in New Hampshire I
live in bo uh bcnh is one of those
private nonprofit Refugee resettlement
organizations uh our mission is to help
refugees and other new Americans
navigate their way to safe healthy
productive prosperous and connected
lives uh I'll Focus just on a very
narrow point because so much has already
been said that the office Health Equity
performs many valuable functions
among them it houses the state Refugee
Health
coordinator part of whose job is to make
sure that all new Americans have
received the necessary
vaccinations uh that the federal
government requires and that also that
help keep all of us safe having the
refugee Health coordinator in
DHHS in close proximity to the refugee
coordinator uh makes good sense
uh we' got the health side we have the
refugee resettlement side which is
primarily a an Employment Program uh
together they work effectively together
uh and and um I think for for that
reason alone it would be worth uh iing
this bill uh in addition to to all the
other values that that the the current
structure brings to the state of New
Hampshire um I would just add
um as one of the really four or five
major nonprofits that work with Refugee
resettlement having excuse me having
state government playing an essential
coordinating role makes a great deal of
sense uh it had never occurred to me
frankly that we might be Unleashed from
state government I don't think that
would be productive for us as an
organization or for the people we're
trying to serve I'd be happy to answer
any questions questions thank you any
representative plaz off thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question uh if you could uh help me uh
with the demographic that you
serve like there are some opposition to
refugees coming at all but also there's
a some uh conversation around who is
here legally who is here illegally and
in my view it could be like a spectrum
Refugee s who come on cbp1 S who jumped
through the border so if you could like
uh uh speak about who do you
serve all of excuse me because we use
these federal dollars we are only we are
only focusing on people who are here
with Federal blessing who have come as
refugees who've been approved by the
state department or some other
categories of of new Americans people
who come as humanitarian Parolees for
example from Haiti or uh as as the
people who are evacuated from
Afghanistan uh ukrainians who are here
through uniting for Ukraine uh my staff
uh we we're a small organization we have
seven full-time people they include case
managers who are originally from
Afghanistan from Democratic Republic of
Congo from Ukraine and from Haiti uh
it's an amazing group they together they
speak 17 languages this is what Health
Access and Equity is all about is having
communication skills on hand uh and uh
and and so we we're working with
approximately 400 people today all of
them are here as as they say legally uh
though I don't find it particularly
helpful to use that term but they're
these are they're they're working they
have social security numbers they have
employment authorization documents uh
and they're contributing greatly to the
state of New Hampshire financially
culturally and because they are
young New Hampshire needs more young
questions seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Le Lisa
bordwin from the New Hampshire Council
of
churches good morning for the record my
name is Lisa Bodwin I am the executive
director of the New Hampshire Council of
churches I am here to express on behalf
of the Council of churches our strong
strong opposition to HB
392 the council represents seven
denominations in over 300 churches and
communities across the state this bill
raises critical concerns to people of
Faith who are called to uphold the
Dignity of all individuals particularly
marginalized and we advocate for
policies that promote access belonging
and the common good much of my written
test Tony has already been shared here
today so I would also like to point
out that each of the structures under
attack in HB 392 has the secondary if
not primary effect of improving access
to stable employment for the populations
of granite sters including people with
disabilities immigrants and communities
of color by ensuring Equitable Health
Care protecting communities from
Environmental harm and fostering
inclusive
workplaces these offices help
individuals secure and maintain
meaningful employment allowing more
Granite Staters to become productive
taxpaying members of
society this bill would
dismantle that and leave unnecessary
obstacles in place for these particular
groups of workers and also undermine the
state's economic stability by reducing
Workforce participation and tax
revenue I will also add as a personal
story that my son Forest is a person
with Down
syndrome and I can assure you that the
group of people with Down Syndrome
within the group of people known as
people with
disabilities do in fact face barriers
based on their appearance and
presumptions that they have no
competence to work or be engaged
citizens the offices under attack in HB
392 would leave
unaddressed the social barriers that
prevent people like my son forest from
being seen as valuable
employees to Granite State
employers from being seen as valuable
friends as valuable
volunteers I strongly urge
you to vote itl on SB
392 thank you thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Heidi
trarco from the conservation law
good morning my name is Heidi trarco I'm
an attorney with the conservation law
foundation and with me here today is my
colleague Marina Voss who is our EJ
community advocate for the NASA
Community clf is a nonprofit
environmental Organization advocating
for clean air and water and healthy
communities and we oppose this bill and
urge the committee to vote and expedi it
to
legislate the committee's already heard
today about the critical work that these
offices do and so I won't repeat that
testimony and we are submitting written
testimony um but I think it's critical
that we just emphasize that what this
bill would do is remove services for our
most vulnerable residents in New
Hampshire and it's not just in our
cities it's not just nashv and
Manchester but it have impacts across
the state including in the North country
and in rural communities where access to
health services are often um very hard
to access there's a lot of distance to
travel and some of this work provides
state the committee heard from the
Department of Environmental Services
about what the EJ office does or does
not do um but I wanted to clarify
something that a clarify statement from
the sponsor
the sponsor's description of what
environmental justice laws are in the
state of New Hampshire really wildly
departs from what is actually happening
in the state of New Hampshire um in
contrast to uh what he was warning about
the state has no environmental justice
law or cumulative impact laws and when
the Department of Environmental Services
permits a facility they have said and
then their regulations prohibit them
from looking at cumulative impacts so
while there is a need to assess
cumulative impacts and environmental
justice the department is not engaged in
that at this point and the description
that uh if a facility is shown to have a
impact on a certain Community it'll
immediately get killed that is not
what's happening in in our state and
there's no there's no state or federal
environmental justice law at
play what this bill would really do is
take a wrecking ball to the Department
of Environmental Services and the
committee heard from um Dees that they
estimate that it would result in uh them
giving back roughly 80 to 90 million
doar of federal funding for the
Department a
year is the Department of Environmental
Services in such strong shape that we
can give back 80 to 90 million certainly
not we know this not to be true the
department regularly testifies that
they're doing the best they can on very
limited resources and that there's a lot
of work to be done um they're stretching
their dollars so I believe $80 to $90
809 to 90 million a year is roughly a
quarter of de's operating budget this
would have great effects in de's work
well beyond the office of environmental
justice or the EJ work that they are
doing um it would impact our clean air
and our clean water it would impact our
permitting in the oversight it would
have far-reaching effects throughout the
way we regulate and protect our
environment and our natural resources in
New Hampshire so we urge the committee
to oppose this bill and vote in exped to
questions saying no questions thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Sam
thank you chairman members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
today for the record my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm the public policy assistant
at Nami New Hampshire the National
Alliance of mental illness Nami New
Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire I'm here today to
speak in opposition to House Bill
392 we have a strong history here in the
granite state of working to improve the
lives of individuals and families
affected by mental illness through the
work of community organizations state
agencies and the work that happens here
in the legislature through this work
we've made great strides in improving
access to care for all people living
with a mental health condition however
we have grave concerns that dissolving
the office of Health Equity could
jeopardize access to care for granite
Staters or will jeopardize access to
care for granite stors you've heard
specifics of the programs and services
offered by the office so I will not go
into those but I do want to emphasize
again that through the oversight and
assistance they provide to the
department and their contracted
providers which includes crucial Mental
Health Services they promote and protect
access to care really for every single
Granite
stator simply put for people living with
a mental illness recovery is possible
but only with access to the care they
need every day people go to work across
state to protect and promote that access
to care and that work has to continue
for that reason Nami New Hampshire urges
the committee to vote itl on house B 392
and I thank you for your time thank you
any
you also signed up to speak is is Ador
Rodriguez Rodriguez Leandra New
Hampshire Council on developmental
disabilities
good morning thank you chairman and
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony um I do have written testimony
so I won't repeat a lot of what has
already been said um the new I my name
is Isadora Rodriguez and I'm the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Council on development mental
disabilities uh the council is in
opposition of this bill because of the
uh dissolving of the office of Health
Equity and we believe that the office's
work is vitally important to the
disability Community due to its focus um
on groups that have health disparities
so some of the points that I wanted to
reiterate are that this office ensures
Federal compliance under Federal stat
statutes including Ada which protects
people with disabilities um and allows
for equal access of information and
resources um the office has been around
since 1999 under different names um and
and I just want to you know voice my
concern uh that we need to have careful
consideration um to not blanketly
eliminate anything just because it has
the word Equity or Justice in it um
because um there there is a need that
needs to be met um and because of Health
disparities that exist for people with
disabilities those needs can only be met
through Equitable access um to resources
and
information um and then my last real
point is that you know cour ordination
of care um and uh accessibility of care
is less expensive than siloed care right
and to meet in the needs of
individuals um we need to recognize that
um offices like the office of Health
Equity is looking to ensure that every
Granite stator has access to resources
and um Medical Care
that's it thank you any
Dary Mr chairman members of the
committee uh I want to give you a little
context quickly and I'm not going to
take questions in the time time fortime
expediency uh I am a doctor who
practiced in New Hampshire for 18 years
I've now retired I'm the mother of a
special ed child and I'm an immigrant so
I cover a lot of the topics that are
affected by what we're discussing but
today I want to present you with a just
a big picture thought about medicine in
general in this state the model of Dei
and the model of meritocracy are being
presented as polarized approaches to
healthcare the debate in our country and
in our state it is about choosing one
path only one is superior to the other I
agree that both are necessary for our
population to stay healthy and
productive Healthcare is a foundation of
a thriving and competitive Society New
Hampshire's population is tough
independent and self-reliant by Design
despite that every single one of us is
impacted by the quality of the care we
receive in our weakest and most
vulnerable moments
this is when we often have no choices
our lives and deaths will be in the
balance diversity in medicine improves
care and Innovation medicine is changing
very quickly a doctor friend of mine
says that trying to keep up with
medicine is like trying to take a sip
from a fire
hose I feel there is a danger that will
we will become calcified if our state
approach to medicine if we only pay
attention to who merits a medal medical
Ed education and who merits receiving
the highest quality of Health Care few
agendas have as big an impact on the
health happiness and prosperity of New
Hampshire's population I urge you to
vote to remain free and to live free and
die on our own terms New Hampshire may
never behave have equal access to
medicine but if this bill passes we take
one step closer to falling
backwards as academic and woke as Dei
issue it is a humanitarian issue that
has never been solved by Merit
alone New Hampshire live lives will be
visited by unnecessary suffering and
even lost due to a lack of protection of
our vulnerable citizens and by our by
our state government I believe New
Hampshire lives free and dies not just
on our own terms but on the independent
Excellence of our elected
representatives and what you Foster in
our
government thank
you
much also signed up to speak is Wendy
roer
and you've asked for four minutes again
closer to three would be would be
preferable
sure good
morning my name is Wendy rooper I'm a
Guilford resident and I'm retired I have
truncated what I have to say uh quite a
bit in the essence of time but I do have
copies that I can make
available we are operating in an
environment of polarized views and
highly charged language words matter
when we don't understand or agree on the
meaning of specific words those wordss
can conf those words can confuse and
divide
us when we are responsible for governing
and impacting the lives of
1il 1.4
million people we first must seek to
understand the meaning intent and
practical outcomes behind using certain
words only then can we make fully
informed governance decisions I believe
we are here today in part because of two
recent presidential executive orders
titled ending radical and wasteful
government Dei programs and preference
and ending illegal discrimination and
opportunity both orders indicate support
for
longstanding federal civil rights laws
and there are
many which protect individuals from
discrimination based on a host of
protected categories in New Hampshire we
have RSA 354a which established the
Human Rights Commission
president Trump has made it clear in his
EOS that he is concerned about and has
ordered illegal programs and activities
that violate our civil rights laws to
end I support stopping illegal
practices I do not understand nor
support the wholesale dissolution of
three New Hampshire government entities
proposed in this
bill just in the last week websites have
been scrubbed wording parsed or
documents taken down entirely in an
effort to be
compliant when I discovered that the
previous Governor's executive order of
2017 establishing The Advisory Council
had been removed from the State website
I asked Governor aot via email if the
values espoused in that EO and its
commit to equal justice for all are no
longer
applicable and more importantly that the
concerted thoughtful stewardship of the
council in the area of
discrimination supported by state and
federal law is no longer needed I have
suggested that the council be
re-imagined to support
anti-discrimination efforts
Statewide dissolving the office of
Health Equity and prohibiting its
reestablishment is baffling to me I
trust that the committee or sponsor has
had conversations with the relevant
Administration and program staff to gain
a deep understanding of the programs and
services administered and whether or not
they support Bedrock anti-discrimination
law have please startop wrapping up have
illegal activ acties been
identified I would make the same comment
about the dees Services have the
relevant staff been spoken to and have
illegal activities been identified those
folks have already talked about the
impact on federal funds let me remind
you that President Trump's EOS are
focused on
illegal
activities consequential actions such as
those proposed in this bill should not
be taken based on Words and an
assumption of what they mean but only on
fact-based knowledge of illegal policies
law I agree having been a 30 plus year
ma'am please wrap up New Hampshire state
employee myself that there's always
improvements to be made money to be
saved programs to be streamlined I think
we can do better I suggest this bill be
withdrawn or voted down until such time
it can be determinate determined that
any of the entities cited have broken
any anti-discrimination laws thank you
for this opportunity thank you any
also signed up to speak is Kristen Evans
Hampshire thank you chair and members of
the committee um for the record my name
is Kristen Evans and I serve as the
Director of policy for AEL New Hampshire
which is a disability Justice
organization dedicated to protecting the
civil and human rights of people with
disabilities across New Hampshire I here
today to speak in strong opposition to
HB 392 because this bill is not just
policy it is personal it threatens the
well-being Independence and dignity of
people who already face enormous
barriers every single day people with
disabilities work hard to build lives
contribute to their communities and
navigate systems that were not designed
with them in mind
many already struggle to access health
care find stable housing and secure
employment this bill would strip away
the few remaining safeguards that help
level the playing field it would make
daily life harder for people who already
fight who are already fighting to be
seen heard and valued HB 392 is not just
about eliminating offices or positions
it is about the message it sends it says
that equity and inclusion are optional
it tells people with disabilities that
they struggles do not matter that their
access is not a priority and that their
rights are negotiable this is
unacceptable New Hampshire can do can
and must do better a truly strong and
just state is one that ensures every
person regardless of ability has the
same opportunity to thrive I urge you to
reject HB 329 and affirm New Hampshire's
commitment to equity dignity and
inclusion for all thank
you thank you any questions
you also signed up to speak is Kathy
Society and again you asked for five
minutes please keep it closer to three
absolutely um thank
you um honorable chair and the committee
my name uh for the record is Kathy
Stratton I'm the CEO of the New
Hampshire Medical Society um and I'm
here to speak on behalf of the society
and uh New Hampshire's Physicians um in
392 um New Hampshire Medical Society is
a nonprofit Association of Physicians
and other healthc care clinicians the
organization's mission is to advocate
for the well-being of our patients for
the profession
and for the betterment of Public Health
in New Hampshire the society envisions a
state in which personal and public
health are high priorities and all
people who live and work here have
access to Quality Health
Care what does Quality Health Care mean
to the Physicians um Health Equity means
Act is addressing the barriers that
negatively impact patient care for
example are patients able to access
appointments um do they have trans
Transportation do they need Vision or
hearing accommodations can they follow
up with
medications physical and behavioral
health therapies and
prescriptions several of our physicians
have submitted online testimonies um and
I want to take a second to highlight um
one in
particular um and this is uh Dr Travis
Harker who who stated that the office
provided training to his staff to me and
to better understand the needs of a deaf
and hard hearing veterans and elderly
and the people from different cultural
and language backgrounds the office has
supported his patience and they navigate
and as they navigate State resources the
office has identified Health disparities
in our communities and collaborated with
Community leaders and medical and public
health experts to develop strategies to
improve health for all New Hampshire
residents um I'm going to keep it short
because a lot of what I've written has
already been said and I will submit this
in writing um the medical society is
here to advocate for the rights of
patients uh Equity programs that
identify and serve New Hampshire's
veterans elderly disabled and
underserved populations core public
health programs that ensure quality
health care for all and a core value of
the society and its members elimination
of the health office of Health Equity
would impact each physician and
physician practice and patient
differently I can say say however that
New Hampshire Physicians unilaterally
believe that the office of Health Equity
serves an important and valuable role in
the health of New Hampshire's citizens
and the patients that we all care for
for these reasons the New Hampshire
Medical Society strongly opposes Health
Bill 392 and we urge the house
um Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs committee to recommend not pass
thank you for your consideration of this
testimony thank you any questions
you did you say had a written copy or is
that what was passed around I'll submit
it I'll submit it um online okay okay
thank
you also signed up to speak is Jennifer
Earl
please put the microphone
on uh I'll just you can use either
one
um thank you thank you chairman Wayne
McDonald in house Health Human Services
and elderly Affairs committee my name is
Jennifer Belmont Earl I live in
barington New Hampshire with my husband
and our two School AG sons and I'm going
off script um when I was listening to
the people from um both
DHHS and um the Department of
Environmental Services they talked about
uh providing sign language
interpretation my children are autistic
my youngest son is nonspeaking he's
non-verbal he's he communicates
differently than everyone else and one
of the
things that allows him to participate in
School in society um and eventually when
he grows up
to participate in our community in our
state is sign language
uh more than
anything
and hearing them talk about how um they
have
interpreters there to make sure um
people can meaningfully participate
on is a huge huge thing um to
voice
um sorry um just as as a
mother I would urge you
to um not pass HB 392 to recommend it
doesn't pass
um because these programs these things
um in the um in these different agencies
they break down barriers of access they
allow more people to
participate
[Music]
and become you know contributing members
of our society so thank you very
much thank you are you taking questions
sure oh sure if anybody there are any I
you also signed up to speak is Andrew
lther believe that Dr Andrew
Lo I'm not sure I'm pronouncing your
last name correctly so I apologize if if
I'm
not thank you Mr chairman for the
introduction uh my name is Andrew Lair
uh I a lime resident I'm a surgical
oncologist I'm the vice president of
graph county Grafton County Medical
Society also the public policy leaon for
the Dartmouth Cancer Center uh the
capacity I'm here today I'm speaking
largely on behalf of my
patients um and our research community
that has done so much in this space over
the last few decades New Hampshire's
home to some of the best doctors in the
United States but yet we're know we also
know that our clinical care is limited
by the often times by the communities
from which our patients come 60 to 80%
of Health outcomes are due to factors
well outside of the role of in the
hospital or in the
clinics these D these social uh and
environmental drivers of Health are why
thousands of granite Staters 50% of
granet Staters uh who can't afford
Healthcare 50% of granite Staters who
live in rural communities disabled
residents small business owners service
workers um have adverse and worse Health
outcomes than others Health Equity
impacted my 7 4y- old patient from the
North Country uh who waited until a
softball-sized mass was bleeding through
all of his clothes to show up to see me
because he didn't have a local provider
or any
transportation Health Equity is my
47-year-old patient who works six to
seven uh days a week for her entire life
and only came to me when she could no
longer walk because of the 30 lb tumor
um that was obstructing her Venus
outflow her only question to me prior to
our surgery um was when can I go back to
work Health outcomes also have an
immediate impact on the communities in
which we all live I I vividly remember
walking into a patient who just
underwent a life-saving surgery he and
his wife were crying because they just
had to sell the farm that had been their
family for four
generations another patient of mine um
uh had to sell his business that had
been that he had had for 40 years
because of cost complications and
inability to uh uh to pay for his
workers strikes me every time I talk to
my patients oftentimes the first thing
they talk about is the burden of their
Care on their patients on their
Community their family their businesses
their
employees so Health Equity is not some
straw man that affects everybody else
Health Equity impacts all of us it's
ensuring that um all in our community
have access um to high quality Care um
in fact Health equity research has shown
that policy that this that this uh state
has implemented
has eliminated disparities in rural
patients presenting with Advanced stage
cancer that's being published in the
coming months it also is the work that's
being done on the ground to address the
20 to 40% of granite Staters who have
food insecurity and can't heal from the
surgeries that folks like myself try to
provide in life-saving
Fashions um Health Equity is also things
like the Medicaid expansion that we know
stabilize the rural health health uh
Hospital Marketplace decreasing closures
of rural Health ensuring access to
everybody um and data out of other
states has shown that Medicaid expansion
improve the overall economy of States
finally I want to talk a little bit
because Health Equity and diversity are
very often conflated if you could start
wrapping up though yeah I will to clear
to be clear both of them are critically
important I have to tell all of my
patients regardless of background that
we have delays in seeing scheduling
their operation that's because our
Workforce is so incredibly short up at
darkmouth and elsewhere around the state
up to 100% of population growth in this
state is net in migration we need to
know how to work with folks from outside
of this this state uh and elsewhere in
order to increase the workforce so uh in
closing I would just uh strongly urge
you to oppose HB 392 uh I will be
submitting my testimony as well as any
other supporting documentation
statements research that you all have uh
requests of me thank you any questions
representative
Lucas thank you Mr chair and thanks for
taking that
question um I would like to know if you
are aware of any incidences in your
practice among your patients or your
colleagues in which any of the uh
practices by the uh
uh Dees or I'm sorry the
DHS um have uh resulted in
discrimination in healthc care in your
opinion uh no sir no ma'am thank you
thank you thank you other
you also signed up to speak is gindel
and Tyrie from the greater nashor Mental
Health
so who understood that oh okay I am the
only hearing person on my team and today
it was supposed to be a deaf person that
would be speaking with you however I'm
assuming you guys know that especially
uh meeting like this a hearing takes a
lot longer than an hour that is
typically expected an inter was only
scheduled for an hour the servic is used
for cart the captions that are now being
provided to my co-workers and to um we
have somebody else uh who is here from
Northeast de and heart of hearing who is
also deaf um are not high quality there
are full sentences being missed and so
there is not equal access today at this
hearing where you are determining if
deaf people should be able to access
their healthare now imagine and this is
common this happened before
surgery I have known people who have
gotten surgery on the wrong side of
their body because they could not
communicate with their doctors and tell
them that it was wrong because they
didn't know what the doctor was trying
to communicate with them either that is
gross malpractice and that is not equal
access to um our
healthare I urge you to think about this
as well 90% of deaf children are born to
hearing parents 90 90% of those parents
will never learn any sign language at
all I grew up in the deaf community and
I had a friend who I asked one day how
do you communicate with your mom he said
I don't the only things I know is when
she walks in my room and goes like this
it means cleans my clean your room if
she does this it means come here besides
that she'll text me his English language
was not strong so he could not truly
understand what his mother or father was
trying to communicate with him I'm going
to do my best to keep this under four
minutes and respect your time and I
appreciate you all so much for listening
to me and hearing what I have to say I
have spent $200,000 on an education to
be a counselor a clinical mental health
counselor the only one who was a
clinical mental health counselor in the
state for de people my co-workers make
up the only service for mental health
counseling that is provided in sign
language in the state I drive two and
half hours to see one of my clients up
in gorm because there's no other service
for
them they already have a huge barrier to
finding the services that they need why
would we add another
one we are making a decision for people
who are unable to be here today and for
people with disabilities who are unable
to stand up for themselves how much was
this advertised this meeting for those
people to come and speak for themselves
and how much was it advertised in not
just English because English as a second
language is hard how many people he read
things and you have to like reread it in
English because you didn't understand
language it does not help anybody in the
community to pass this bill it hinders
them our Pledge of Allegiance ends with
in Liberty and justce for all where is
the Justice in this bill what are we
doing to help the people that we have
promis to help and support in our
country this is supposed to be a place
of Freedom this is supposed to be a
place of
democracy and I do not see that being
represented in this
bill if you have any questions about DEA
culture which I am not the person who
should answer even though that is my
undergrad degree it is the deaf people
that are currently here that should be
speaking right now it is the deaf people
here that should be answering any
questions that you have about how
drastically this bill will affect the
community I was a special education
teacher for a year in the state of
Maryland I moved here for this job from
Kentucky I displaced my husband
unwillingly on his part to be here I
will wrap up um I was also 6 years ago
started interpreting so I have seen from
The Interpreter side side and I'm a case
manager as well so I schedule
appointments for Deaf clients and a lot
of times they ask me to schedule the
doctor's appointments because they have
too hard of a time trying to get an
interpreter a lot of times offices will
hang up when they hear that a sign
language interpreter is being used over
the phone because they think it's a scam
or whatever it is I do not know why this
happens it
is that I could talk about all this for
a very long time um but I was calling to
make an eye doctor appointment and I
promis I am wrapping up for an
11-year-old client because mom who is
hearing has had such a difficult time to
get an office to accept using an
interpreter and paying for one which is
a legal responsibility of the office to
pay for that interpreter I had to call
three offices one of them flat out
refused another one said that they don't
have the resources set up and I tried to
educate them finally the third
one was willing to work with me and I
had to have a phone conversation with
their office in order to teach them how
to find an interpreter and that they are
indeed legally required to provide that
to
somebody thank you so much for your time
if you have any questions reach out to
me I can help you direct you to somebody
who is deaf and can better answer them
and share their life experience but
today that was
unavailable thank you representative
navel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my call you obviously have an
important role to play in this state
thank you for being here of course um
what happens to your job if this bill
passes um well my job I would actually
get more clients because it would cause
so much stress I have the one of the
only professions that if I do my job
right I will be out of a job I would
love to be out of a job but this would
cause so much stress the current
political climate the current way that
everything is happening is already
putting so much undue stress on on
people we have had clients cancel um
services with us because they're scared
of what's going on with the political
climate and that their services would be
continue other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you very much I hope you all have
day no one else has signed up to testify
on HB 392 FN before I close the public
hearing does anyone else wish to testify
seeing no one I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 392 FN and open the
public hearing on HB 751 FN and
recognize the prime sponsor who is
actually a member of this committee
I
I filled out the pink card is coming
down oh yeah that was going to be my
next question it's it's weaving its
way up to your
desk just that appears here good morning
everyone thank you Mr chair and
honorable members of the health human
services and elderly Affairs committee
for the record my name is Mark mlan
representing Hillsboro district 14 which
is Manchester Ward 8
uh I'm here to introduce HB 751 which
would create a lure process for
outpatient substance abuse treatment
programs by the Department of Health and
Human Services um so just a little story
uh early last year the newly elected
mayor of my city of Manchester met with
several legislators uh from Manchester
including myself and when we asked him
what he needed from us and conquered he
said he needed three things really help
with housing a clean up of the bail
reform law and pertinent to the
legislation we're talking about today
some kind of regulatory structure for
substance abuse treatment and this bill
is a step towards addressing that final
concern so why is it needed well um both
uh the mayor and myself neither one of
us are big fans of excessive regulation
but the city the situation in the city
and in the state as a whole in relation
to substance abuse treatment has become
unmanageable so the mayor of Manchester
as many of you may know is a recovered
addict himself so he knows the recovery
landscape and he as much as anyone else
wants to see people get treatment but
his comment to me when we were talking
about this is he says look when we
release somebody from Valley Street jail
and they are clean we have a rare
opportunity to keep them that way
instead they go into some black pole of
treatment um where the person who's
providing the treatment isn't even
through their own recovery Journey
completely and so what happens is they
fall back into addiction and this very
precious opportunity is lost okay and
that's really what's at the heart of the
problem and those comments don't even
touch upon the predatory behavior
highlighted in 2023 is the 13th Step
podcast the state doesn't even know of
the existence of more than half the
facilities that are out there they're
operating completely in the dark and so
we're really in a situation where I
think we need some guard rails the bill
originally came to before our committee
last year but at that time the committee
rightly said there were too many holes
in it to allow it to go forward the
major concern expressed at the time was
that lure might be so onerous that it
might discourage folks from actually
coming in and offering Services Services
availability may go down rather than up
but you know because I was aware of uh
the need that the bill addressed I asked
instead of us killing it outright if we
could hold it over for interim study so
in the subcommittee we looked at it we
eliminated the residential components of
last year's bill um to focus on the
outpatient only we Exempted non-clinical
services individual practitioners and 12
step programs from the need for lure
okay also we retained the utsman
position subject to available funding uh
contained in the original bill um you
know we talked in uh our uh our
orientation session early about the
value of an ombudsman so you know
whether it's you know for the elderly we
have a right to know utsman and even the
housing appeals board which was newly
created ser as kind of an edsman uh
effect and so basically um I think that
those have been very effective and
persons who are using the services of
these facilities are often at the most
vulnerable point in their lives and so
having easy access to Someone Like An
edsman who can help them access and
resolve their complaints um I think
would be of enormous
value uh since filing uh the bill in the
fall you know based on the work of the
subcommittee we modified the bill
somewhat and since then the HHS
department has come back and said that
they think that they can execute the
lure requirement more effectively by
Rolling it into the existing Health Care
Facility framework than the separate
certification that we've been talking
about in the bill last year and that is
what you have in the amendment before
you which I handed out before the public
hearing every body should have Amendment
uh
22h okay and so that is what I I would
like to you consider going forward with
I basically what that does is that
substitutes the bill wholeheartedly with
the amendment and what does the
amendment do the amendment basically
well as I said it keeps the edsman
position subject to the ability of
funding it establishes the licensing
requirements with the specific
exemptions that I mentioned the
individual practitioners and 12-step
programs but instead of creating the
separate certification it rolls The Lure
into the existing framework laid out in
RSA 151 colon 2 and appropriates the
money for a compliance officer who will
provide oversight and the thinking was
you know since we already have this
existing infrastructure set up it's it's
going to be much easier to do it's going
to be easier to comply with and it's
going to be easier for the Department to
run and so they and they have come
around to say yeah we think this is is
is a better way to go so I'll just end
by saying I know you know I know a lot
of you folks I know that many of you
folks are skeptical about new
regulation uh so am I but the
population that is struggling with
substance abuse I think they're often so
low that they're not not this is not
like going and looking at Yelp for a
good roofer and uh letting the market
kind of drive it these people basically
they're solo they're going to go where
they're appointed and they're they're
just not going to be doing all that
heavy research so I think we can help
with this I think this bill is needed
and I hope you will support it um there
are others who are lined up to speak as
well I'll do my best to answer any
questions that you may have but bear in
mind that we I do have some folks behind
me thank you Mr chair thank you any
questions for representative mlan yes
representative
McCay thank you Mr chairman as a former
director of alcoholism for the State of
New Hampshire and a licensed clinical
social worker would you believe that I
legislation representative mlay I would
believe you support it I would also
believe that you were invaluable to the
you other questions representative
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my
question like in previous session I
still
don't understand why why we need it
because uh you spoke about predatory
behavior uh in some of treatment centers
and that was the reason
this bill came to us uh uh in in a
previous session but for me the logic
doesn't match because predatory behavior
outlined in that podcast happened
exactly in
certified treatment program so now we
are uh pushing uncertified programs into
certified programs where this predatory
behavior was happening
and with State facing all the L hes from
sunun Center that was certified I just
don't see how more certification will
help with predatory
behavior well I I don't think that the
the the intention at this point is is to
insulate the state you know against
lawsuits from predatory behavior the the
intention is to minimize uh the
predatory behavior so number one um the
the majority of the facilities we heard
testimony from the department and the
subcommittee um the majority of the
facilities we don't even know that they
exist and and so um while
individual uh providers within those
facilities may be licensed by the oplc
there is no um is no oversight of of the
facility itself and I think also um this
was where the the edsman position
becomes very important you know when we
when we look at for example um the the
right to know Ombudsman uh people would
would look to get transparency they
would run up against uh barriers in
their towns and it it was very hard to
push through and and I think you know
having some some one that I can go to
and I know what their role is even if
their role is they don't have any legal
weight um they they can certainly shine
light on things and they can influence
what ultimate decisions come so if you
have someone who is a clearly defined
position that that people can go to that
understands uh the framework um
hopefully the the the intention would be
that that would be helping to guide
better outcomes um so um I look at it
from that perspective I hope I answered
your
question other questions representative
McGrath can you help me understand how
it works now somebody's getting out of
jail do they go right into one of these
treatment centers and who pays for
that um if if they get out I don't I
I'll I'll defer it to somebody after me
I I do believe that um if if it's
mandated
by the court that it would be covered by
the state I I but but don't quote me
because I'm not an expert I do believe
it is and maybe you can ask somebody
after me from the Department that might
know better than that I don't know if we
have somebody here from the drug court
or not but um but I'm not
certain other
questions I I do representative merer
thank you thank you for taking my
question the office of the ombudsman so
that's something that does not exist
presently
correct that is correct okay follow up
follow up so I I've had experience with
the right to know on budsman and so that
was not a great
process so I'm wondering if there's
something that you can send us that
really lays out what that Ombudsman this
new creation would be responsible for
and his
responsibilities how he communicates
with people because we were we were we
couldn't email phone nothing so so if
there's something that we could
see that would make this a process that
would make things efficient I mean I I I
don't have the the particulars on that
the position hasn't been created um
there was discussion during our
orientation hearing that they have an
utsman who works with you know people
who are in Elder Care
uh my assumption and it's just an
assumption would be that it's based upon
something along that model um but you
know I could certainly um when the folks
from DHHS come up we could ask the
question but I'm assuming that it would
be built upon that same
structure other
questions representative Nagel thanks Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
really appreciate all the work you did
on this you really deserve a p in the
back um you really gutted this bill a
lot and I was wondering about the whole
section two where it talks about how the
commissioner is going to establish rules
eliminated the reason is is because
you're going to be instead of creating a
brand new certification you're moving it
right into the existing uh statute for
Health Care Facility lure so um I do
think there would still be some Ru
making that would have to be done um I
don't think it just is a cookie cutter
insert creating a new subsection G um
but the the amount of rule making that
would be required would be substantially
less okay thanks other
questions representative
kofol uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question so um you you
have sponsored legislation that would um
open Health Care to uh free market
forces in New Hampshire by allowing
licensed Health Care Facilities to
accept cash only payments right now
licensed healthc care facilities are
required to accept all forms of payment
essentially would this if if it's moved
under licensed Healthcare facilities
would it then be the case that
um we we would
have um treatment that that would have
to cover would have to accept all forms
of payment including Medicare Medicaid
uh private insurance Etc or or would
that be would cash payment or would
would would cash only payment or free
market options be
available yeah thank you for the
question obviously I'm a huge fan of
free markets and I do want to uh
liberalize the HealthCare Marketplace
and so when this Amendment did come back
to me since they are rolling it into 151
colon 2 that was a huge concern of mine
um looking at 151 uh colon 2
the all payer requirement reply applies
to uh A and D and it explicitly says A
and D where this is creating a new
section g um that would not be the case
so for example if you uh wanted to open
up a facility and you wanted it to be
cash only um because this new section g
is not covered by that it would not be
covered by the all-payer requirement so
that would be I hear what you're saying
and I I and I I've already asked some
folks about that very thing thank you
other
you uh we are behind a schedule uh we've
had some important bills today and we
are behind schedule so we aren't going
to break formally for lunch but members
are encouraged to go at their Leisure uh
I'm going to continue the hearings right
right through uh until we get done so
you want to go now you want to go later
we call it a ring lunch and we will
continue to have the hearings and
hopefully we'll get caught up at some
point so so I'll leave that up to
members discretion as to if you want to
go uh also signed up to speak on this
bill is Jen o Higgins and Dorian sharley
Services it is still morning good
morning chairman McDonald committee
members my name is Dorene shley I am the
manager of the Bureau of Licensing and
certification at the Department of
Health and Human
Services good morning I'm Jenny O
Higgins I'm the legislative lays on for
Behavioral Health at DHHS so the
department would like to provide some
information relative to House Bill 751
we continue to expand uh substance use
treatment options and also to monitor
the effectiveness of care for all New
Hampshire residents um in existing State
Licensing or regulations are for
substance use exist under the office
office of professional lure they exist
under U the bureaus of Licensing and
certification as well as the Bureau of
drug and alcohol services and our
Medicaid provider enrollment so those
are some of the existing quality and
oversight um protections to make sure
that people who seek treatment uh that
treatment is effective and of high
quality um this oversight bill here is
as already described by the prime
sponsor uh the underlying Bill had
focused on certification and in working
with stakeholders and sponsors the
department was able to identify existing
programming under our licensing
department so you will see in the fiscal
note of this worksheet that you may have
with you today is on the underlying Bill
and you'll see that because the creation
of a certification program for these
substance use outpatient facilities
would be new the department was
requesting four positions an IT
infrastructure build in order to do the
certification uh and some training
within our existing ombudsman's office
and in working together on the new
Amendment uh that Amendment would allow
us to reduce that fiscal impact
significantly where the department would
need one position within our existing
bureaus of Licensing and certification
unit so that is a big change and some of
the reasons that we moved from
certification to lure to be more
effective in that existing oversight
that's overseas today already substance
use sort of residential treatment and
this would expand to outpatient as also
previous previously noted the department
doesn't have a great sense of where uh
treatment is happening in the outpatient
space because we don't have this
oversight so today we know that there
are 53 outpatient practices registered
with Medicaid at over 90 locations but
that's would be just those that accept
Medicaid and so the landscape of
substance use treatment is much larger
than that so the intent of the bill is
both to help us understand the landscape
of treatment and have uh families be
able to know where they can access care
and then also to monitor the
effectiveness and quality of that and to
receive complaints and be able to take
action and as Jenny has already stated
substance use disorder residential
treatment facilities are already
licensed in the state of New Hampshire
and the Bureau of Licensing and
certification oversees those facilities
the and Jenny's already mentioned the
fiscal note um again the department is
committed to continue working closely
with with the sponsors and with
Advocates and stakeholders um to ensure
that it will be an effective way to
understand the landscape of treatment in
New Hampshire and ensure the quality of
services and the ability to respond to
concerns we're happy to answer any
questions no questions thank you thank
Peters good
morning uh please put your microphone on
and you ask for five minutes please keep
it closer to three you bet um my name is
Kate and I'm a family doctor in
Manchester I work at Amis Health which
is our safety net Health Center in
Manchester and um I also Moonlight at a
couple of our County jails so I'm very
familiar with substance use treatment
and I do a lot of it and I'm passionate
about getting high quality treatment um
in place for folks and I've seen the
damages that can happen with poor
quality treatment because a lot of folks
end up unfortunately in situations that
are not ideal for their treatment
setting um I guess the piece that I'd
like to add to what's already been said
is that in my estimation 100% of the
people who seek treatment for substance
use have suffered significant trauma and
people who have suffered significant
trauma are particularly vulnerable
unfortunately to abuse and to be taken
advantage of um I hope you all have
listened to the 13th Step podcast I
think it's really pertinent to this
conversation um and you know it's my job
as a healthcare provider it's your job
as lawmakers it's all of our job as
responsible citizens I think to advocate
for the most vulnerable Among Us right
this is why we put in laws to keep kids
safe and keep elderly people safe and I
think people who have suffered
significant trauma like those people who
are seeking substance use treatment
deserve that added protection too um so
over the years the legislature has given
lots of money for um substance use
treatment programs and I want to say
it's working I see a lot of people turn
their lives around and become wonderful
contributing members of society uh who
take good care of their families and
contribute to the economy um and we now
need to continue to make this investment
uh effective by putting in guard rails
you know so to speak for the pl
treatment places that are available when
we provide good quality evidence-based
treatment for folks with substance use
they get better um and that's good for
all of us um so I hope that you vote
ought to pass on this and help me in
stemming the tide of the opiate
epidemic right thank you any
questions saying no questions thank
you oh representative
Nel sorry I was just dealing with my
son's trauma um I just for clarifi
clarification can you specify what you
mean when you use the word trauma sure
well um trauma can be lots of different
things right it can be certainly
physical trauma like having suffered and
overdose and getting you know uh medical
treatment in ER or it can be emotional
trauma I think that um there's really
good data that most um people who end up
struggling with substance abuse either
have had trauma in their history that
has led them down that road or uh in
getting involved with substance abuse
then they have suffered trauma um
emotionally and physically as a result
of that
other
questions I think it's safe this time
thank
you also signed up to speak is Annette
good uh please put your microphone on
and again you've asked for five minutes
please keep it closer to
three there you go it's on now okay us
to be on you okay um my name is Annette
Escalante and I am the director for sud
services for the Alia health system and
I am here today um because this was one
of the things that I'm very passionate
about just to clarify um I a person
living long-term recovery 30 3 years
from heroin and I got to be very honest
with you that when I came I'm from
Massachusetts uh yeah um but when I came
here 29 years ago I was a little shocked
about the current sud system and I can
honestly say that we've come with a very
long way but we still have a long way to
go um about four years ago I was a
director of The Bureau for dug and
Alcohol Services and really got to
experience the state piece and what we
do with the treatment and now as a
provider out in the community and
serving for many years before that I
really am able to see what we're
actually currently working with and the
reason that I am so passionate about
making sure that this does happen is
because of my experiences at the state
knowing that I really couldn't do
anything I would get complaints and we
had no
oversight so what I decided to do was
really push this and I left the state
because I was receiving phone calls from
family members asking where they should
send a loved one and I got to be honest
with you if you were looking right now
today to try and find a place for your
child or your sister or brother you're
going to want to have someone having
oversight from where you're sending that
person and this is really what what this
is about um is making sure that we're
providing the best care for any person
coming into treatment here um we've
received several complaints there have
been several complaints in the people
who know the best are the clients who
are actually the folks who are receiving
these Services we've had programs that
kind of put 30 people in a group there's
no oversight for this if
there if someone has a complaint they
don't have anywhere really to go unless
they are the program itself is receiving
services from the state of New Hampshire
so we really need to be able to have a
place for anyone who has a complaint to
be able to to look into it and really
process it so that we're taking care of
the most vulnerable population in our
state and that's really why I'm here
today okay thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Jamie
powers from I believe it's Gate House
treatment
you just shut it off there you go um my
name is Jamie Powers I'm the CEO of uh
Gate House New Hampshire wfit and mat
care clinics all located in Nash but
serving all areas of the state I was
also the director of the Bureau of drug
and alcohol services immediately after
Annette was so it's nice that we're
following each other again uh I am here
to testify in support of this
legislation it's a crucial step towards
ensuring the safety and effectiveness of
our Treatment Services here in New
Hampshire as others have mentioned we're
dealing with very very vulnerable
populations who don't necessarily have
the means or even willingness to do a
lot of research into care they just want
care they're scared they're sick they're
done they want help they're not going to
Yelp it's not like choosing where you're
going to go to dinner and right now with
no certification or lure for outpatient
facilities like we have for individual
providers through oplc or Residential
Treatment Centers through uh Health
Facilities there really is no measure uh
nor is there a comprehensive list of
what services are
available we have made huge huge
investments in our system of care over
the last 10 years um since the
implementation of the Affordable Care
Act as well as parody and that system
has grown incredibly but we don't have
the means to monitor it to make sure
that we are giving people the services
that they need I know I've heard
concerns about this bill and stifling
creativity and Innovation I want to be
very clear that what this bill does is
it provides a framework of safety that
individual programs can then build on in
their own ways and just as we have with
Medicaid and payer regulations now we
have very different programs that have
the but those same standards of
safety um I think most of everything
else I was going to touch on was already
discussed I will Echo anette's
frustrations with uh families members
calling concerned about the treatment
that their son daughter is receiving and
really not being able to do anything to
help them that's that's a really
horrible
feeling so I will leave my written
testimony and I thank you all for your
time and
consideration thank you any
you are those for to be
distributed Miss Powers are those to be
okay representative McGrath could you
please also signed up to speak is Jake
Futures Mr chairman honorable members of
the committee thanks so much for having
us here today my name is Jake Barry I'm
the vice president of policy at new
Futures as many of you know new Futures
is a nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy
and advocacy organization we've been
working for more than 25 years to help
address issues around substance misuse
and addiction in our state I don't want
to repeat too much of what's been said
here this morning but I do want to
stress our strong support for this bill
uh simply put we believe this bill
represents a natural and logical next
step in the growth and maturation of our
treat treatment system and it will
provide qual important quality
assurances and P patient protections for
individuals in need as others have
alluded to our our substance use
treatment system has grown significantly
in the past decade thanks to the work of
many including many of you and and your
fellow legislators there are now uh
dozens and dozens and of treatment
providers in our state uh providing
meeting the needs of of individuals and
families certainly we want to believe
that each of them prioritizes patient
care and patient needs and provides high
quality evidence-based Services uh and
and most of them and we believe most of
them do but the truth is we don't know
that that's the case for all of them as
you've heard under our current system
there's no the state has no oversight or
record of many of the provider
organizations operating within our
borders you heard the numbers there are
53 outpatient provider organizations
currently registered with Medicaid of
those 53 the department currently
contracts with only eight of them for
the rest the remaining 45 the state has
no oversight Authority or mechanism to
step in of cases of wrongdoing or
misconduct or substandard Services arise
and this doesn't even touch on the
dozens and dozens of providers that are
not registered with Medicaid these
organizations are not registered with
state in any way we don't know who they
are where they operate or what quality
of treatment they provide at best this
leaves individuals seeking treatment to
navigate an un uneven system that varies
significantly in the quality of services
offered uh this weakend our treat this
weakend our treatment Network as a whole
and contributes to a rol involving door
of patients who trans transition in and
out of treatment while they fight to
address their addiction at worst it
leaves patients at risk of abuse and
misconduct that threatens to to to force
them to relive the trauma they have
experienced and make it that much harder
for them to to get into to M obtain
long-term
recovery uh the amendment as
representative mlan mentioned would
address this by by requiring Outpatient
Treatment providers to be licensed by
the state for further it would add the
behavioral health specialist position to
the embud men's office which as you
heard is just a critical component to
ensure that there that individuals who
are experiencing uh again misconduct or
wrong wrongdoing in within treatment
have a place to go to report their
concerns and it's just another Avenue to
for them uh for the state to investigate
and make sure that there that there are
Corrections um where they need to be uh
in closing I would say that the state
over the years has in you we have
invested millions and millions of State
in federal dollars to establish a
treatment system that that's capable of
meeting the needs of our state uh it is
you know weaknesses or or holes in the
map folks who are not registered that
makes it harder uh you know for us to be
good ta good stewards of those tax pair
dollars to make sure the money is being
uh being reasonably used um because it
it means people are receiving
substandard treatment which makes it
harder for our highquality treatment
providers to ultimately help get them on
the right path and get them the support
that they need so we think that this
bill is just critical in uh ensuring
high quality services across the across
the state for everybody who needs it and
I'm happy to take questions thank you
any
[Music]
you also signed up to speak is Amanda
Vashon from Riverbend Community Mental
Health
good morning uh chairman and committee
members uh my name is Amanda Vashon I am
the coordinator for the Marat County
Recovery Court it was formerly known as
the drug court which is rebranded so
those terms are
interchangeable um I have testified on
uh all the versions of this bill since
it's an Inception um
and that felt like a responsibility to
me I've worked in this field um of
mental health and substance use disorder
treatment um for over 15 years um the
majority of that I worked as a
corrections officer working with um
people uh from Community Corrections so
people who are out in the community on
bail or who were serving a sentence it
also included folks who were uh part of
the specialty Court treatment so um
program so mental health court and and
um drug
court uh the reason this is so important
to me and to uh the specialty Court
programs in the state is that we um end
up working with the highest risk highest
need folks in our communities what that
means is that without intervention they
would likely recommit you know commit a
new crime um and their substance use
disorder would likely get worse they
also are the highest need because they
have a severe substance use disorder um
previous testimony has included
information about trauma and how
impactful that is to developing a
substance use disorder um it is
pervasive substance disorder does not
discriminate it's across all genders
across all socioeconomic status uh
across all
Races and so it's important to the
society as a whole that we do something
to safeguard the treatment that we're
expecting people to participate in now
this bill applies to all treatment and
not just the particip that I work with
currently as the coordinator of the
program but uh by the time they get to
us it's more than likely because their
substit dis disorder has gone untreated
or has gone um had they've seek services
for from providers who did not provide
adequate
treatment the goal ultimately is to not
need specialty courts because hopefully
we would provide a network of treatment
that would get people well before they
commit crimes to the point where they
would be facing a prison sentence or um
participating in my program but we're
not there yet and so we have an
obligation to provide oversight to
ensure that we have a Continuum of Care
that would reduce the likelihood that
someone's going to wind up on my you
know in front of me um for those of you
who may not know what specialty Court
programs are they are a combination of
uh mental health and substance disorder
treatment that's aimed at um providing
accountability for those who have
committed crimes and who also have one
of those diagnoses in New Hampshire we
should be very proud all but one of the
counties in the state has an adult drug
court program we also have um mental
health courts across the state um and
the recent data has shown um that we are
reducing overdose deaths by about 40% in
2024 we also will see the 1,000
participant graduate from our court
system in the state
the reason I'm here is is really just
because the 13-step podcast illuminated
something to me that I didn't know about
which was the likelihood that the people
I had sent to treatment over the course
of my career um were statistically it
was possible that they were victimized
when they went to treatment and to me
that was unacceptable I lost sleep over
that and I feel like I have to be here
to be a voice for those people who we
are mandating in some cases to go to
these treatment centers okay thank Youk
you any
questions representative Lon thank you
Mr chair and thank you uh for taking my
question and I apologize if you said
this and I didn't quite understand it
but how when you re does the court
contract with particular treatment
centers now or how do you make the
referral where do you currently get your
information about what programs to refer
people to you mean before they come to
our program or after they've already
accepted a
sentence um I guess anywhere in the
process I don't really okay I'll try to
quickly summ so um someone who commits a
crime um most often they're uh drug
related or drug related adjacent um they
would be uh referred oftentimes by their
defense attorney to apply for the
program so these programs are voluntary
up until the point that they're
sentenced then they become mandated so
they have to do what the court is asking
them to after that point but the process
to get into these programs is twofold
they have to be assessed by a licensed
clinician to determine they have a sub
disorder and they also have to be
assessed by a trained um professional to
determine their risk level and they have
to be high risk to participate once they
come into the program the clinical
assessment that they obtained when they
were deemed appropriate is then used to
determine the level of care that they
would need to be in sometimes that means
they come out of this the jail system to
uh right into an inpatient bed sometimes
it means they come right out to
outpatient services through for example
Riverbend which is where I work um as
part of a program but over the course of
time level of care can change because uh
addiction is a relapsing Condition it's
chronic and so over time they may
struggle we reassess their level of care
they go to a different treatment center
and come back to us so the Continuum of
Care is very important to the SU ESS of
our participants over
time other
questions seeing done thank
enough also signed up to speak is Cheryl
is I pronounce that correctly you know
job yeah my name is Cheryl pelli and I
am also a person in long-term recovery
for 35 plus years and I am speaking in
support of this bill I concur with
everything everybody said already but
now I want to tell you a story about
what is currently happening right now
today as we sit here with zero oversight
for these programs on Monday as a person
in long-term recovery for a for a long
time I get calls from all kinds of
people family members where can I send
my son daughter to treatment and I also
get calls about this happened where I
work who can I tell what's the process
to make a complaint and this woman who
called me is in her early 20s she works
at a Outpatient Treatment Center
and her boss who was the
director
um solicited um inappropriate sex from
her and she doesn't know who to tell
that to there's no oversight for this
she went to her boss the person
ultimately got fired and when that
happened she took over all of his
clients five other women have said the
exact same thing happened to them again
no one to tell no oversight nobody to
make sure where he's going to work next
which he is already working somewhere in
conquered it's not going to happen to
another woman so again I would urge you
to support this bill for those reasons
and it has been mentioned before if you
have not listen listen to The 13th Step
podcast I would download it to your
phone on the way home this is real women
in treatment are being abused over and
over and over and we are not doing
anything about it I have been
trying to work on getting this done for
11 years this is the closest like I have
come and it is in your hands now to help
to move this legislation forward and I
have written like professional testimony
sure but um I just wanted you to know
like this is actively happening today
and I am trying to help this woman know
what to do so and I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you representative
palazov thank you Mr uh chair and thank
you for sharing with us and taking my
question so I'm trying to understand uh
obviously uh very concerning situation
but I'm trying to understand if this
bill will help or makes it worse
because uh uh you are speaking about
individual who who was abusive and now
he is in different uh facility
but uh I think Bill if I'm not mistaken
speaks
about uh about facility itself and
facility is now in is in good hands so
going after facility maybe not the right
approach in in the situation that you
described so in my way of thinking and I
could be way off off but if in fact I
was a woman in that treatment center and
this was happening to me that I would
call the office of the Ombudsman and
report it and then what they do with it
I would hope they would investigate look
into it and find out what's going on
make sure the director of that facility
knows like we had five women say that
this person is um you know taking
advantage of us and right now there's no
place for that to
questions see seeing none okay thank you
thank
you oh and one other thing I was never
the director of the Bureau of drug and
alcohol
[Music]
Services also signed up to speak is
Marie
key hi my name's Mar Kylie and I live in
Portsmouth New Hampshire thank you for
allowing me the time to testify I'm I'm
here today in support of House Bill
751 and I'm supporting this bill because
my son my only child Ben and this is his
picture died suddenly and
unexpectedly from alcohol on October
24th 2023 which is 15 months ago and um
he was only 44 years old and um I never
saw him drink and neither did my whole
family he he worked full-time and he had
lots of friends and he was very close to
his family and um his friends knew he
had a problem with alcohol and um they
just didn't know how to help him and I I
appreciated hearing um that this bill
people talk about this bill is going to
allow people to be able to more easily
navigate the system and find treatment
because um and someone mentioned I think
the sponsor mentioned that and others
that the people people and their
families are a really vulnerable when
this is going on and it's not an easy
process to find quality
treatment so um my son um I didn't know
that he had relapsed he this picture was
taken on Mother's Day 2023 and that was
5 months before he died and um we were
out hiking he loved nature he loved to
go hiking and he he was sober then I
didn't know he would he had relapsed so
it was a shock in October when I
received the call from the hospital that
he'd had a cardiac arrest and uh it was
3: in the morning and he never regained
consciousness and he died a few hours
later and um my sister-in-law was there
with me at the hospital and um she said
this is just shocking she's like he's
the picture of health and and I I kept
looking at him and saying to the doctors
look at him he doesn't have a line on
his face he his beard is so trimmed his
fingernails he's so healthy how could
this happen and a doctor told me that um
you know I'm like but he's so young and
he's so healthy and he just said you
know for your son alcohol was poison
and um he said I don't we don't know why
some people are in their 70s and they're
in and out of detox and they're back
here and but he said not for your son so
Ben had voluntarily attended substance
use treatment centers four times in the
six years before his death that's when
we found out that he had alcohol use
disorder like I said we never saw him
drink but you know six years ago six
years before his death he was diagnosed
with alcohol use disorder and he was
very open about it with us and he badly
wanted wanted to stop drinking and
unfortunately the treatment senses that
he attended did not provide
evidence-based treatment something that
I didn't realize at the time and he
didn't realize and he did tell them you
know after the first treatment center
and when they sent him he was he was
referred we and we we talked to the
hospitals and they referred him to these
facilities I don't think they knew that
they weren't evidence-based and he had
told them after the first one I need
more Medical Care sorry I'll keep this
short um but he didn't receive it so he
did not receive evidence-based treatment
and I I think that this bill will help
to ensure that that happens that the
facilities need to meet standards have
qualified staff and um provide
evidence-based treatment and um also um
the other thing is that we and the other
families that were um had their family
members there received outdated and
harmful advice from the center staff who
lack the qualifications to advise Ames
we attended the family meetings and the
advice that we got on what how to help
our families was very outdated and very
harmful and um so I I think that this
bill will help to ensure that there are
a qualified staff there that are meeting
standards and Ben was very intelligent
kind caring he always worked full-time
he had so many interests he loved
history and literature he loved to read
and write screenplays he was funny and
creative he was just a wonderful son he
was was a gift I used to tell him he was
the joy of my life and I miss him every
single day and I'm just so sad that he
lost his beautiful life needlessly and I
I've since learned that alcohol use
disorder is highly treatable and I
believe Ben would be alive today if he
had received the evidence-based
treatment that he wanted and
needed um and he was so full of life
that I saw him losing hope that he could
recover so I ask you to support this
bill for the many people like Ben who
are struggling to recover from addiction
and for their families and friends who
were also desperate to help them so
thank you for your time thank you ma'am
and we're sorry for your loss thank you
thank you very much any uh
you I have a second card for Jamie
Powers but I know Jamie Powers just
testified so is this a duplication
or okay all right great do I need to
retain this uh no no we've already got
okay I have no one else signed up to
testify on 751 FN um does anyone else
wish to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
public hearing on hp71 751 FN and open
the public hearing on HB 645 FN and I
believe Senate um representative y there
he is representative Edwards is the
prime
sponsor he's coming in now two minutes
going to have a just a very brief recess
of a couple of minutes but uh give
representative Edwards a chance to get
situated and um a couple of other
members to take care of some couple of
things and do you want me to hold off
yeah if you could hold off for just a
couple minutes appreciate your patience
no
problem had some interesting bills today
yes
e
okay I'd like to reconvene and uh again
open the public hearing and proceed with
the public heing on HB 645 FN and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Jess Edwards from
markingham County District 31
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chairman I'm representative Jess Edwards
representing Rockingham District 31
that's Auburn Candia Chester and
Deerfield um I'm here today to introduce
House Bill uh 645 FN
um the one of my
co-sponsors uh shares with me the uh the
honor of serving on the prescription
drug affordability board that's Senator
Rosenwald and we also today have um the
uh chairman of the prescription drug
affordability board with us the
honorable Gary Merchant um um
representative Merchant um
would helped me draft this bill with
Senator um Rosenwald so what what you're
looking at is the evolution in
understanding how the prescription drug
affordability board ought to operate it
first got put into legislation about
four years ago maybe five years ago um
it had some Concepts at the time that it
was going to be pretty autonomous in
terms of the its data collection and
data storage and its ability to um uh do
data calls to ask industry to provide
direct answers to them that they would
provide privacy and security around um
there so so so what has happened is uh
uh having had an opportunity to operate
the board a while and figure out what
the real ways of working should be it's
been determined that that we think um
the the board
uh ought to rely on the data that's
already being accumulated by other
departments and to rely on them to to do
all the data warehousing and managing
and that the pdab will become
essentially uh an entity a customer to
request uh access to particular data to
run a particular report and only run the
reports that have been developed in
concert with um the entities of the
state that purchase our prescription
drugs so we're supposed to be in touch
with those uh entities that buy drugs on
our taxpayers behalf figure out what
kind of information they need in order
for them to make better informed
decisions to use the transparency of
information for them to drive better
drug prices that's the general principle
of the board um and what this bill does
is in several places it puts us in the
statute like in the on the first page uh
section 21 on down it talks about um
uh identifying the report before they
start to seek the data then on line 28
it starts to talk about um collaboration
between departments using M us it talks
about uh cost sharing with those
departments so that if extra work is
required money is made available it
talks about uh in uh on page two line
five uh the the methodology for making a
data call uh line 11 is due process so
that if a data request is made that's
onerous um that uh the uh that industry
has an opportunity to contest the
request um before providing the data um
and uh on page three I'm going through
it a little quickly um we uh there's a
section in here um that talks about how
the board is supposed to provide value
and what kinds of information it can
look to we added to that uh line 25 and
26 basically saying that the board ought
to have um situational awareness of what
other pabs around the country are doing
what the feds are doing so we can just
leverage other good ideas instead of
thinking we have to make them up
ourselves next page um it again we're on
situational awareness then we get to uh
how we can f um Levy fees if uh if um
companies do not comply with a a valid
data request um we limit our own access
to the data to only those who are
qualified and with a need to know within
the
board um sometimes we may ask for
business sensitive data and that's what
the lines 34 on that page do is to just
say that we should be aware of business
sensitive data next page five is a
quality uh statement so that if we
collect data we're collecting good
quality data and that way any data that
we do uh uh collect can then be useful
to others and not just to our own
purposes so uh so that's that's what the
bill does there's a fiscal note on it
um and um uh I I think this is uh this
this bill is an effort to do some good
government the
board operation ought to mature uh and
this legislation uh directs a good way
in which it can be done in a sort of a
nonpartisan or bipartisan way and with
questions I have one to start off with
is there an amend Amendment pending on
this I had a rumor or um I I do not I I
understand um the Edna committee uh
after they heard the other half of this
bill um that their committee is talking
about another amendment but I don't have
anything official on that okay thank you
any questions representative
Kofa yes so so can you um offer any
insights into how much uh what what is
the budget I was I was looking at um
some slides online and it looks like the
budget request for the next two years is
around 1.2 million for the for the board
is that accurate or am I well uh I I am
aware of the agency budget request for
and and I remember it in the first year
$257,000 um and um and that that's
that's in the budget and then this
fiscal note thinks that uh there would
be some potential for Revenue a little
bit and um some additional expenses
related to the data calls so if um so
another appropriation would probably
need to be made to support the data call
part of this and so it could go from a
quar million to about
$350,000 a
year does that answer your question uh
it does followup followup um so and are
you aware of I mean so in addition to
the sort of the hard dollars are there
soft costs associated with the board I
mean are there for example um agency
Personnel or Personnel from other
agencies that are contributing
significant amounts of time that that
ought to be considered as a factor in
the the overall cost here the amount of
time that I'm aware of is um in the
Department of Health and Human Services
because this is attached
uh to
DHHS and and I and I and I think it's
accurate to say that in the last year or
um about 120 manh hours 100 to 120 man
hours it's a rough estimate it's not
been documented but uh it it feels like
an additional 120 manh hours have been
donated to the board by other
departments and that other departments
could include uh the Departments that
come in to to provide some uh an
advisory Council and the department of
administrative Services as they and doit
is we talk about data warehousing so so
there are additional indirect costs that
are not associated with the hard
dollars thank you other representative
Woods uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question did medicine
we think in medicine sorry in medicine
we like to I think we proceed on and
call it evidence-based medicine I think
this looks pretty good in the sense of
evidence-based buying yeah um with that
said um I'm I a little bit confused that
maybe I'm just not reading this
carefully enough uh but there's some
authority to get the data that you want
to make sure that money is being spent
properly and and the muscle behind it um
and we've seen this in other committees
about money state money being hidden
behind
proprietary uh
discretion and not being
accessible what would prevent like say a
PBM um is uh would be one that you would
interact with I would presume uh they
wouldn't want to give up their data uh
what Authority do you
have the the the the initial legislation
from four or five years ago had very
strict uh Authority and and we scaled
that out until we could build the PAB
and figure out what we really need so we
could uh make the authority uh
commensurate with the the requirement
for the data instead of just sort of a
plenary uh Authority and and we've
scaled it back um representative Woods
I'm looking for the particular paragraph
but it I think it's uh
about $500 or so for um a data call that
is refused so if we if we've Justified
the need for data by having a report
format that would serve the needs of a
buying entity if we do the U the the the
data analysis on it to find out that the
data just doesn't exist anywhere in our
government system already and that it's
a new request for data
um and then we form the data request and
send it
out the entity receiving the data call
has an opportunity to uh protest say I'm
not giving you that it's too business
sensitive you don't really need it you
could get it from other ways there's a a
due process Loop that's in this bill
that hasn't existed yet uh and at the
conclusion of that if the pdab
determines that we still need the data
um then we can issue the data call and
there's a legal obligation of the per of
the entity receiving the data call to
respond and if they don't then they
begin to be fined so it's it's very
narrow whereas the initial setup it was
very
broad well I thank you I just I want to
clarify that in fact there is an Avenue
to get that data and there's no no way
for an entity to just plain Stonewall
say no that's proprietary information
thank you very
much they they have an opportunity as
they should to protest if we've asked
for too much data and we give them a due
process
opportunity and but but still at the end
of the day the PAB is in a judgment
position to determine whether or not
their protest was adequate or
not other questions representative kof
fall
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so the um so so
reading through the the annual report
there's quite a lot in there about
rebates and one of the one of the powers
in statute is to collect information
about rebates so I have really two
questions about that number one is
um does the purview of the prescription
drug availability board extend to
vaccines and does the information
collected about rebates
um apply um
to uh rebates or incentive payments that
are made to providers for certain
meeting certain thresholds for far
either Pharmaceuticals Andor
vaccines okay I'm I'm going to try to
answer your question it may not be uh
directly correlated but in in in general
uh the Department of Insurance already
collects a tremendous amount of data
they get data on actual orders and
utilization uh I think some of that
information comes through the uh the um
um prescription drug boards no what
what's the term I'm looking for pvms
comes through the pbms but the rebate
information so far has been extremely
difficult to get and to apply to the
drug data and therefore uh entities all
all over the place trying to figure this
stuff out it Das the federal government
other states everyone I think is
struggling with the idea that these
rebate mechanisms are so obscure and
Byzantine that it's very difficult to
take that that that information if you
even if you can get it and then apply it
to the actual drugs so you can know what
the true cost of the drugs are so that
that's a problem and and I think that's
one that the pdab is working with with
the doit for the coming annual
report and and like I said The Honorable
Gary Merchant is here he's the chair
he's been working this problem for four
years he he could
elaborate follow um so if that is the
case because rebates play a significant
role in pricing or in obscuring
transparency in pricing um and if PB if
the uh PD um prescription drug
availability board doesn't have access
to that
information um it is it obscuring the
ability of the board to to do its work
and you know can the can the board be
effective under those
circumstances I won't get to the
effectiveness uh question uh I think
right away but I I'll I'll I'll say that
the entire predicate of the board is the
belief that if we have price
transparency we can provide recom
recommendations to the purchasers of of
our drugs where they can use that in
their contract
negotiations and so to the extent that
we have really well-qualified drug
transparency you would assume that that
would lead to better negotiating
positions which is maybe why it's so
hard to get the data I I don't know
that's where this kind of gets gray and
then the question on whether or not the
pdab is effective without being able to
do that I I I I think the ultimate
um indicator of Effectiveness is the
extent to which the uh pdab is able to
provide value added recommendations to
our purchasers that they can Implement
and start saving real money so so far
there haven't been any recommendations
money other
questions seeing done all right thank
you also signed up to speak is former
state representative Gary Merchant and
former member of this committee welcome
representative
Merchant representative Merchant I have
to admonish you we try to stick to three
minutes here you ask for
five I'll try to wrap it up as quick as
I can Mr chair thank you um it's a
pleasure to be back before this
committee it was a pleasure to serve
with this committee for a few years uh I
learned a lot and uh hope you guys will
bear with me as well so what I would say
is what we're trying to do on the
prescription affordability board is
bringer greater transparency into the
state of New Hampshire to make people
more aware of what the market Works um
I'm a strong believer in a free market
but I also believe a free market only
works when transparency is available and
data is Flowing freely um if the buyer
is not aware of the market and what's
going on it really in a lot of ways puts
them out a
disincentive so when you look at the
State of New Hampshire to give you some
idea about the magnitude of what we
spend in
2022 we spent $1.7 billion that's with a
B the state of New Hampshire by itself
spends multiple millions of dollars on
um prescription
drugs if we don't find a way to begin to
bend the cost curve and try to
understand what's going on in the
marketplace we cannot as a state nor as
a citizen try to bend that cost gr so
what this is I worked with
representative Edwards also with Senator
rosenell is trying to find a way to
collect the data that the Board needs in
order to begin to bring greater
transparency to the marketplace and try
to educate ourselves as well as other
folks that rely upon the
market so that's the whole intent here
is to say we don't need to be in the
collecting of the data process the board
should not have to build its own
infrastructure to collect the data there
are other entities in the state that
collect data the Department of Health
Human Services the department of iot the
um insurance department we don't need to
recreate that infrastructure what we
need to do is have the ability to
identify what data we need for the
reports let that entity collect the data
on our behalf and then have that entity
once they collect the data share with
the board that's an efficient way for a
government to work I was up to upstairs
with Edna talking about a data warehouse
we have various silos in our state that
collect data but they don't talk to each
other so it's a separate bill but this
is back to the same thing is we're
trying to find a way to use State
resources efficiently and economically
to ultim allowed the board to accomplish
its mission that was stated in the
statute thank you any
questions not seeing oh oh there he is
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
very much for taking my question just
just for I'm still trying to piece this
together um could you give me just an
example of who would be the consumers of
the reports that would be generated and
what kind of information would you be
talking about going into the reports I'm
just trying to understand H how does
this work who's using the report what
data are they
using that's a really good
question represent McLean I think the
intent of the report is to provide
information to the buyers in our state
and when I say about the buyers it's the
people who buy the prescription drug B
benefit is helping them understand
what's a reasonable contract what's a
reasonable price so when they're
negotiating they have some Benchmark to
M Mark against today they don't have
anything there's no recommendation
saying this is a fair price this is not
a fair price it doesn't I want to be
clear about this it does not in any way
disallow someone from charging whatever
they want what we're talking about for
recommendations which is back to the
same thing the free market is saying
this is a reasonable price this is not
if you go out if you think about the
Kelly Blue Book it tells you what a
reasonable price is to buy a car does it
not it doesn't mean that the dealer can
charge whatever they want they can
charge $100,000 for the car but the
Kelly Blue Book says it's only worth
30,000 it's still your choice to pay the
100,000 but at least you have something
to go back to to look at the market and
saying what's reasonable we don't have
anything like that this Market is so
opeg it's like walking into the dealer
and saying
hm I like that car what do you think
it's worth are you relying upon them
telling you what it's worth versus going
to a third party like the Kelly book and
saying based upon the Kelly book I think
this is reasonable what you chargeing me
and what you want to charge me is
unreasonable but there's no reference if
you will repres clean there's no third
party database to
help follow up so in going after this
information you mentioned the we have a
whole bunch of
DHHS um are are they going to be the
primary information reserves that you're
going to or you're going to be going to
the manufacturers themselves and the the
the compliance mechanisms that you have
in here is it just for the Departments
or is it for
everybody can you if you would when you
say compliance compliance with the
datally say so yeah so I I I have a data
call and you uh don't give me the data
so after 14 days you know I said this is
fair this is a reasonable request you're
not meeting this request so you you owe
me 500 bucks or whatever it is 500 bucks
a day up until I hit 25,000 and then it
caps off is that being paid by the the
non-complying department or the
manufacturer can you go to the
manufacturers themselves who are you
seeing as the people that are going to
be paying that fine
The Entity that's required to submit the
data is the one that's going to be on
the hook for the $500 not the department
that receives it so be clear if you're
asking from the manufacturer they're the
ones on the hook to comply if it's
coming from the PBM it's coming from the
pvm whatever the entity is that's being
asked for the data they're the ones that
are on hook to pay you the fine if they
data so I noticed that the fine caps out
at
$25,000 so um given we we're talking
about hundreds of millions and billions
of dollars and information is very
valuable um how is that amount arrived
at and do you think that that's an
effective stick or
not it could just Stonewall
you they could call it a cost of doing
business I don't disagree with you um I
I think it's a place to start if we find
that with people stonewalling us at that
point in time and $25,000 on a
7.1.7 billion worth a book of business
is just the cost of doing business then
I think we need to come back to the
legislative body and saying it's not
working they're stonewalling we need to
have a way to break through it whether
it's with fiscal penalties or some other
way to get there I don't know but I
thought it was reasonable at $25,000 the
capit to begin the process and not get
into something so honorous that it would
be so difficult to even get it to the
legislative body thank you other um
representative woods and then and did I
see someone else yeah okay then yes I
know go ahead representative Woods um
thank you Mr chair thank you uh
representative for taking my question uh
good to see you um I'm I'm I'm concerned
about this nebulous reasonable price
uh reasonable uh in the eyes of uh
myself as an enduser will be vastly
different than the reasonable price if
I'm a PBM uh and it's vastly different
that if I'm a pharmaceutical
manufacturer putting out a drug that's
uh May save millions of dollars uh and
uh thousands of lives um how do you
arrive at uh at the ground level of this
is a and what factors do you include
when you say it's a reasonable
price well that's a very good question
representative Whits it's one I wrestle
with but there are third-party entities
that spent a lot of time and a lot of
resources trying to come up with
something that's reasonable um you have
iser which is available um it's out
there in the marketplace when new drugs
come to the market they do actually
develop what they think is a reasonable
price for based upon the market based
upon the resources used to create it it
does not preclude somebody for paying
more than that because the board is
basically making a
recommendation so you have the issue of
what's reasonable and how you define it
I think it's also a critical question
for the advisory Council which is
comprised of many stakeholders and
asking for their input as well so it's
not like the board's making this
decision in a vacuum it's really looking
for broad stakeholder opinion before
they try to come up with some
recommendation followup thank you um in
that consideration I guess I'm trying to
say if you consider the social value of
drugs as well uh we think about the
immediate value of you know solving
someone's problem either uh getting rid
of Representative uh um are just as U
cold uh versus um someone curing cancer
uh and those have
value um and some have other social
values as as well is is that taken into
account uh uh in discussion with one of
the U this is a true story um uh one of
the drug reps uh uh that has the hepc
and as you know dosage of hepc is
horrific and my query was uh why well uh
we're saving Society millions of dollars
return that I totally agree with I think
when it comes to trying to understand
what the fairness of a price comes into
multiple factors including offsetting
medical cost I can remember
when um H2 or peptid if you will get the
market and it was supposed to be very
expensive but it was saving surgery uh
there was ways to prevented so you have
to look at to your point the whole cost
Spectrum so it's not like you're looking
at strictly one piece of it but you got
to look at the whole overall impact of
healthcare so we're not trying to
isolate the drug cost by itself but
looking at the overall
impact representative McGrath and then
representative
kofel thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question can you explain
how being a
pharmacist a um
[Music]
prescription um PBM negotiates with the
Insurance on behalf of tens of thousands
of patients for the best price and yet
that price is hundreds of dollars more
of every generic discount card that's
negotiated with a
pharmacy no I cannot and that's part of
the reason I'm trying to with the
prescription Dr affordability board be
good to understand it I just came across
something the other day not to D just
divert myself but a lot of the
prescription discount cards we have do
data yeah we in our
Constitution have data protection
seriously that we put in the
Constitution here we are taking these
opportunities and letting people sell
our data there are which came to our
attention at the board ways to use a
card like that from other states that
created something that prohibits them
from sharing that data that's an example
but back to your question which you
asked there's no way right now I mean if
you look at Mark Cuban this Market is so
opaque it's like The Wizard of Oz behind
the black curtain trying to figure out
what's going on until you pull it back
you don't really understand
it representative kofo thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question so
um I have a couple of questions actually
but the first one is a followup to to uh
representative Wood's question regarding
reasonable what's reasonable so would uh
potentially
substitutable um Pharmaceuticals be an
example like would that be a basis for
determining what is reasonable if
there's a generic or other substitute
that could be um offered in replacement
representative Cal I think we're talking
about another bill that's being brought
forth and that's in the biologics and
when you look at the biologic market
right now it's unreasonable because you
have a situation where the pharmacist
cannot allow an interchange with a
patient to save them money so the
reasonableness it comes back to is what
is reasonable based upon what's
available so if you have competing
entities on the product or on something
comparable to it and you can save money
for the patient should we not allow the
marketplace to do exactly what it's
supposed to do and allow people in the
in the play if you will to be able to
take advantage of that on behalf of the
patient or
payer so reasonableness is really not
defined in one particular way it's
defined upon many different ways to
Define it so I'm with you
100% follow up can can you offer
specific examples of pricing that
category um the last time I was last
year talking about drug you have a
herera and you have Huma $80,000 a year
less price and you have something else
at strug B which is probably 4 0,000
sounds like a great savings and you have
another one drug C which is
20,000 but if you don't have a situation
for the pharmacist to allow them the
market if you will to work with the
patient saying you should have a choice
between Hamera B or C 80 40 or
20 that's a question bringing that Tye
of transparency that kind of information
to the buyer to allow them to understand
what's available to them and right now
that is not really readily available
it's like goes back to my blue my blue
Kelly book it's having something that
somebody can look at and saying this is
where the market prices are these are
comparable products and this is
something you can work with if you're
thinking you'd go back to your physician
go back to your physician but you need
to educate the buyer about what's there
including Physicians for the most part
they're trained nothing against Dr Woods
here or Dr pler but or Dr um
telsey they're focus on your care and
trying to get you the best thing for
your care they possibly can but there
should be a way for all the parties to
have access to data about what the
prescription drugs cost and help them
understand what the choices are
questions one final one final one sorry
so would this would this
bill provide the board with the
information that it needs to to increase
the transparency around rebates
specifically I can say that it will
provide the board with more information
that it needs to begin the process of
transparency I cannot guarantee that
having the data is going to do that but
I can say what we're doing today without
working anyone
you also signed up to speak is Dr Jason
pdab and could you identify the person
with
you good afternoon thank you for your
time to Har us I have with me here
Morgan Harris she's our director of
healthcare analytics at the insurance
department my name is Jason AIS director
of Health economics at New Hampshire
insurance department um Miss Harris
works with the prescription drug rebate
data submitted to the department by
pbms we wrote um a redundancy
elimination report at the direction of
the New Hampshire legislature publ
published it late last summer um to my
recollection is posted to the pabs
website the New Hampshire pabs website
and um I we did see some uh reference to
redundancies streamlining the
efficiencies for data share data
collection sharing and Reporting
um so the department has a neutral
position on this bill but we're here to
answer any questions that might arise
questions W okay I guess I I'll question
out at the moment okay thank you for
you also signed up to speak is Linda
hodon from the who's a volunteer with
Hampshire I've changed my good morning
to good afternoon thanks for hanging in
there good morning or good afternoon
honorable members of the H uh house
Health and Human Services committee my
name is Linda hodgon and I live in abum
I'm here to testify on behalf of AARP
New Hampshire to express our strong
support for House Bill
645 in my prior 30 years working for the
state I was Medicaid Finance director at
one point and in my last position I was
Commissioner of administrative Services
we were in charge of administering the
active and retirees health program for
over 40,000
lives in both jobs escalating drug costs
were a challenge to understand and to
try and manage data made all the
difference and data saved the state
money I am concerned about the rising
cost of prescription drugs and its
impact on older adults in our community
an article I read over the weekend
stated the two largest age groups in New
Hampshire are 55 to 59 and 60 to
64 in the same article the New
Hampshire's office of Planning and
Development projections for the
population in the 65 plus Community is
an expected growth of
66% from 2020 to
2040 as many of you know the 55 plus
Community is the group that AARP
represents I fully support the New
Hampshire prescription drug
affordability board and its goal to make
prescription drugs more affordable for
Granite State families it's a valuable
resource for New Hampshire and we need
to support it I support house bill 645
because the pdap needs access to data to
do their job fortunately much of the
data they need is already being
collected by other state agencies House
Bill 645 will create an efficient way
for the pdap to access this data helping
them to fulfill their mission on behalf
of New Hampshire citizens with access to
the data the pdap can better address
High prescription drug cost benefiting
consumers facing expensive drug prices
in conclusion I urge the committee to
support House Bill 645 to ensure the
pdap can work effectively for New
Hampshire residents the pdap is a great
resource and we need to use it to
support its mission to improve access
and affordability of prescription drugs
for all of the grand estate families
thank you for your time consideration
and attention thank you any
questions I'm seeing none okay thank you
and I have written testimony it'll be
submitted through the portal okay thank
you thank
you that was the last person who had
sign she was the last person who had
signed up to testify on uh 7 645 FN does
anyone else wish to
testify if not I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 645 FN and open the
public hearing on HB 724 FN and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative hecken Phillips uh before
we get too deeply uh we needed your PIN
card by the oh we've got it okay I'm
going to turn the gavl over to the vice
chairman representative Maser I'm going
to step out for a short time I'll turn
the hearing over to her and
um then with that U representative
hackin phip you may proceed thank you Mr
chair just a matter of um process I'm
wondering if the committee's already
been provided copies of amendment
0222 in regards to hb7
24 if you've not received it I'm happy
to bring that
out um Miss Grant uh I thought um Karen
Davis was going to give that to us but I
don't think I've seen it
yet we have oh there it comes it com
you thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee good afternoon U I'm
representative Mary hacken Phillips of
graft and 12 serving Handover and lime
and I'm very pleased to be with you
today to introduce HB 724 relative to
lead paint poisoning prevention and
Remediation at this time I'd like to
2025-the only difference from the bill
and the amendment offered is that
section two of the original bill which
lowers the threshold for blood liad
level investigations has been removed
given it has a significant fiscal impact
the original intent for the bill was to
offer a no cost high impact solution to
prevent or remediate lead poisonings and
so I'll be focusing my testimony today
on that Amendment um during today's
hearing but of course there will be
folks here um and I'm happy to speak
about that section at a later time if if
the committee so
chooses so to begin with uh the
prevailing belief is that lead poisoning
in kids is a problem that New Hampshire
solved decades ago when Congress banned
lead paint essentially in
1978 we understand the cause and we know
what the solution is uh scientific
experts inform us that lad exposure
through paint dust consumer products and
water causes elevated blood levels in
children who are more susceptible to
poisoning than
adults children with elevated blood
levels and turn experience reduced
learning capability ability to pay
attention an academic achievement but
high levels of blood Le poisoning can
cause irreversible Health damage and
this is a permanent trauma to the child
and their family the solution once a
child is poisoned is very expensive
medical interventions and treatments for
the child remediation of lead in the
property or a complete disposal of the
product an ongoing financial support for
Education emotional and behavioral
development at school and in our
communities so you see the effects
Ripple wide and they're just
devastating so the sponsors argue that
we have a duty and a moral imperative to
act so that we're not waiting for New
Hampshire's babies to be poison before
we do something about it thankfully
Congress has passed many laws in the
past aimed at preventing lead poisoning
for instance Congress in 1992 passed an
act that requires lead paint disclosures
for most real estate built before
1978 which has really increased the
Public's awareness of what lead paint is
doing in aging housing and in particular
in 2020 I'm sorry 2008 the EPA
established the renovation repair and
painting regulatory program which
requires contractors and landlords to be
trained and certified and led safe
practices to lawfully work on projects
that dist um disturb lead based paints
and homes child care facilities and
schools built before
1978 here in New Hampshire the
legislature has most recently passed RSA
130-a colon 5-d which requires Property
Owners to have a lead safe certificate
prior to occupancy and newly constructed
rental properties and newly licensed
Child Care Facilities located in
buildings that were constructed before
1978 so these laws together and others
make up part of the solution to reducing
lead
poisoning but the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
December report based on its own testing
data indicates that these Solutions are
not enough members have received copies
of this recent DHHS report in their
legislative mailboxes and I really
encourage everyone to check this
out uh perhaps you've learned or heard
about this um in the news reports that
have been across our state in the past
week um DH hs's report says the number
of children here in New Hampshire
identified with elevated blood levels
has increased since 2021 and it's at its
highest level since child blood Le level
testing was enacted in
2018 that's right and a miss an
estimated 1,142 children here in New
Hampshire have elevated blood L levels
high enough to impair their ability to
think learn and concentrate in
2023 so concentrations of child's lead
poisoning is most pressing in Manchester
and nashwa but no community no region
and no County in our state has been
unscathed moreover poisoning numbers are
probably worse than reported given that
every child in New Hampshire is tested
so here's the takeaway the lead poison
problem in New Hampshire has gotten
worse and we have to do something about
it to keep our kids
safe so this legislature can
affirmatively act by advancing HB 724 as
amended and to take another step towards
the prevention and Remediation of lead
poisoning today the amended bill has
three no cost solutions for your
consideration and I'll just briefly
explain those now so if you're looking
at Amendment
0222 it changes our RSA 130 a the lead
paint poisoning and prevention control
and control chapter law with the
following additional paragraphs so
section one of your amendment requires
that building permit applications
include the EPA RRP license number for
any person engaged in renovation repair
or painting of buildings erected prior
to January 1st
1978 under the existing epa's renovation
repair and painting rule homeowners are
already required to use a licensed
service provider for these projects so
the change to an application form helps
remind contractors and homeowners of
their legal
responsibility the New
Hampshire Municipal association's town
and cities magazine noted that
municipalities have a role to play in
preventing childhood lead exposure and
many municipalities here in New
Hampshire are already doing this um it's
a simple no cost um change to an
application and um you may know that
towns such as Sugar Hill are already
doing this their permit application has
been printed and it'll be here for you
to take a look at what this looks like
in Practical um implementation a little
later
today section two of this amendment
Bill restores the Department of Health
and Human Services Authority to inspect
subsidiary units if another unit in the
same multi-unit building is found to
have a lead paint Hazard and in the past
DHHS had had this Authority but at some
point it was removed from Statute in
approximately
2018 um in consultation with the
Department stakeholders and sponsors of
this bill have learned that the
department would welcome the restoration
of that authority to protect all the
people in the same building that is
known to have a potential lead Hazard so
the department here today can verify or
the department is here today and can
verify um that it believes this
subsidiary unit inspection work can be
absorbed without a fiscal impact to the
state finally section three of the
amended Bill establishes a rebuttable
presumption of lead in pre-1978 housing
unless lead inspector has determined the
dwelling or unit does not contain lead
based
substances this change will create a law
sorry a low barrier evidentiary tool in
court that any pre-1978 housing is
likely to contain Lea based hazards so
this is another no cost strategy for
preventing lead blood Le level
poisonings that have been effective in
other states in our region including
Vermont so I'm just calling on my
colleagues on both sides of the
political aisle as well as in both
Chambers to join the sponsors in
preventing childhood Le poisonings by
supporting HB 724 as
amended we hope you will agree it's a no
cost multifaceted approach proven to
reduce Le exposure in New Hampshire
worthy of your support this will be
another step in reducing the lead risk
to children in our state and please know
the sponsors will continue to push for
no cost low cost and ideas with return
on investments to reduce the lead risk
to Children Here in New
Hampshire so I know there are many
Advocates here planning to speak today
in more detail and if the chair should
agree and the committee does not object
object I'm hoping the next speaker could
be attorney haidu tarco of the
conservation law
Foundation um who has several handouts
that will be helpful for the committee
to um INF framing the discussion um
today so I'd personally like to thank
the co-sponsors and the conservation law
foundation for their partnership and
working on this bill and thank you for
your time and if there are any questions
I'm happy to answer them this
time thank you representative does the
committee have any
questions representative m
graph thank you Miss chair and thank you
for taking my
question so this graph is really
interesting uh we've had mandatory
testing and it was going down do we know
why and now it's going up do we know why
uh yeah so the amount of testing went
down during the covid pandemic because
not as many families were coming in for
their children's annual inspections when
this blood test requirement usually
takes
place um but I'm sure the experts here
can speak to the you know nuances as
questions thank you can you please
repeat who you said you'd like to speak
next yes it's attorney Heidi trarco from
the conser conservation law Foundation
you
try thank you um nice to see you again
my name is Heidi trarco I'm an attorney
with the conservation law foundation and
uh 3 minutes is quick so I will run
through my material I've submitted
written material in support of of the
bill um and you're getting a c copy of
that now and that has some documents
attached to it so that might be helpful
when you um are looking it has the DHS
2023 data brief it has a uh building
permit from the town of Sugar Hill so
you can see what this looks like on a
building permit and it has one of the
economic studies um cited in my
testimony I'd also like to note um some
testimony that the committee should have
received electronically from people who
were wanted to test to find support of
the bill but can't be here today um the
first is Dr Christine Arseno from the
New Hampshire Pediatric Society or the
New Hampshire AAP the chapter of the
Pediatric Society the Pediatric Society
strongly supports the bill and urges the
committee ought to pass and you should
have her testimony also testimony from
Charlene lit the former mayor of the
City of Claremont who also supports the
bill and brings a real Municipal
perspective um and discusses how
Claremont has done similar things that
this bill provides to remediate LED
problems in Claremont and how that
worked in Claremont and urges the
bill as you've heard and as I hope
you've seen in the data brief and in the
news the recent DHHS report shows the
highest blad poisoning levels in
children since we began recording those
numbers in
2019 and the jump up to
1,142 Children which is a 42% increase
from the 2022 cannot be attributed to an
increase in testing Alone um for example
the testing in 2023 the numbers of
children tested is very similar to The
Numbers tested in 2019 before the
pandemic so we're testing about the same
number of children and having elevated
lead and as the sponsor told you not all
the kids are being tested so about 70%
of our children are being tested so we
know there are a lot more children out
there who are likely poisoned by lead
and we can also understand that a lot of
these children who aren't getting tested
are probably our most vulnerable
children and more likely to be exposed
to lead hazards and the data Bears this
out it is our poorest children in New
Hampshire who are the most susceptible
to lead poisoning they are twice as
likely to be poisoned by lead and for
New Hampshire children on Medicaid one
in 10 is poisoned by lead it's really
tragic there are some experts here today
who will talk about what happens when a
child is poisoned by lead why this is so
terrible and the lifelong impacts that
child will carry um I have references in
my testimony as well to support that and
I know the committee has a lot of
medical experience and you can all draw
on your personal knowledge of what the
dangers of lead poisoning um but I'd
like to point out to the committee
really quickly and you'll see this in my
testimony that the state has also
studied that investing in lead poisoning
prevention saves the state a lot of
money DHHS in 2014 estimated that
medical treatment and special education
costs for lead poison kids cost the kids
about cost the state roughly $300,000 a
year which in today's dollars is about
half a million dollars a year um and
taking into all the other um expenses
that occur in families and communities
and the state the cost of lead poisoning
is in the millions of of dollars and
there's references to dhs's report I
didn't bring it because it's like 25
pages but the link is in my testimony so
you can go read that data for yourself
thank you if you could start wrapping up
okay
um I'd be happy to answer questions
about these three Provisions which are
geared at preventing poisoning in the
first place so requiring towns to have
the RP number on their building permit
you'll see in the Sugar Hill building
permit this is a oneline addition to a
building permit it just says contractor
name license number so they're already
required to be licensed this is just a
simple prompt on a building permit and
you'll see in mayor lit's testimony that
this simple prompt encouraged more
contractors in the City of Claremont to
become RRP certified and to engage in
lead safe practices it also lets
homeowners know that there's lead
hazards in their home I think that
people are often under the assumption
that this is a problem we have solved
this is a simple way of letting people
know this problem is still there than
you I really do need you to wrap up
thank you does the committee have any
questions representative Woods um thank
you uh for thank for taking my question
um this this license um especially in
some of the more rural areas does that
impact the the ability uh because or
does everybody all the contractors have
this as a matter of fact or is this
going to impact uh people being able to
do repairs on their
home thank you for the question so the
contractors are already required to be
RRP certified this bill does not put any
new requirements onto them so that's a
federal law it also applies in certain
situations under epa's RP law and so
this just prompts when they're doing um
Renovations on a home when submitting a
building permit to provide that number
um and I I think um mayor claremont's
testimony I mean I'm sorry mayor lett's
testimony about the Claremont experience
does speak to how a community um
benefited from this
provision follow yes follow I'm not sure
I asked the right question um if you're
in a rural area um and the someone wants
a renovation done they go to get a
permit well the F contractor do doesn't
have a license now is that is that a a
significant
imposition uh in any way to to get
remediation thank you for the question
I'm not aware of how many unlicensed
contractors were out there working I
mean that would be in violation of
existing law so I can't speak to that
but I can say that the communities that
have put this into the place are kind of
varied across the street so we have um
Sugar Hill Waterville Valley Easton
marac um Madbury Claremont these are a
variety of communities who are um
recognizing it's important to get this
on their form and I I don't think it's
been an impediment um I'll also add the
municipal Association um has um told me
and authorized me to say on their behalf
that they don't think this provision
will add any cost to
municipalities thank you representative
delus thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question so when you when
you say contractor are you talking
construction contractor or painting
contractor thank you for the question so
it is anybody engaged in work under
epa's RRP law and so that's renovation
repair and painting of pre-1978 housing
so there's a very specific set of work
that triggers this provision okay and it
is anybody engaged in that work so if
you have a home that was built in 2019
uh this wouldn't never apply to that or
a new build house this wouldn't apply
it's it's a specific rule for people who
are engaged in work in that has to deal
with lead hazards under this Federal
rule any yes representative Lucas thank
you madam chair and thanks for taking my
question um wondering about the
situation at least in my community comes
up quite often and people do their own
renovation they don't hire a
contractor how is this going to address
the situation if at all thank you so
often the RRP rule does not apply to
home renovations in people's own homes
um and it is really tragic and I I don't
have the data but I've talked to a lot
of lead experts about why is this where
is this increase in Poison kids coming
from and some people do speculate that
there is a bump in DIY home projects
particularly since the pandemic we were
all home we were all doing work in our
homes um perhaps and again I don't have
data to back this up perhaps that's one
of the reasons why kids are we we're
seeing these increased numbers so this
provision wouldn't impact you know the
DIY I'm going to go um paint my hallway
um but as a whole you know I'm trying to
get the word out about this I think the
report I think the provision on a
building P firm uh permit prompts a
conversation in communities um and and
people go to fill up their form they see
it there you look at these building
forms now it say what are the Wetland
impacts what are this that that what are
lead paint is not on there it should be
people should be thinking of this where
do I live where do my neighbors live so
it's to raise awareness and the same
with the rebuttable presumption is to
raise awareness to this problem and I I
I'm telling everybody I can you know we
we have not solved this problem of lead
poisoning it is here we know what the
solutions are we know what the problem
is so it's it's part of that effort um
but I don't have a a perfect solution
for inhome projects thank you anyone
else any further questions thank you
fry good afternoon my name is Kate fry
the vice president of advocacy at new
Futures I'll be very brief I do have
written testimony
um new Futures we appreciate the
testimony speak in support of House Bill
724 we're nonpartisan nonprofit
organization networks uh through
problems through policy change in this
rule we work extensively with policy
makers and Healthcare Providers um
regarding increase to access quality
affordable health care so um regarding
this bill in particular we stand in
strong support of HB 724 I really
appreciate the sponsor sir uh saying
ahead of time that this is um a no CA
solution to the lead poisoning
prevention epidemic that's really been
happening in our states for years and
years and years for context I worked at
the Department of Health and Human
Services 10 years ago and we were
working on this very issue and I feel
like it's um Deja Vu uh what I really
just wanted to focus on in this
legislation in
particular is um while we made a lot of
changes through S SP uh 248 in 2018
that uh were really great steps um
regarding um childhood Le pre prevention
policies there was a huge step back with
that
legislation um so prior to 2018 the
department um had the authority to when
it had um a lead hazard in one housing
unit the agency would be able to inspect
other units within that building to
check for lead this was just common
sense primary prevention you don't want
a kid to be the canary and the coal mine
if you know that there was a kid in
another unit who was poisoned you should
be able to check the other units um that
was change in s SP 248 and I think that
was a big step back in terms of primary
prevention this bill fixes that and my
understanding is the department is um on
board with that so it does uh also
identify other um solutions to which um
Heidi spoke about of which we are in
favor um but I would just really ask
this committee to um consider this bill
um closely as further steps we can take
to prevent our kids and keep them safe
and I ask you to vote a to pass thank
you does the committee have any
much next we have
Nick Nick Norman Norman oh okay sorry
don't know your name
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak my name is Nick Norman I a
advocate for housing
providers my Association is a network
of property owners throughout the state
and in various different associations
that work together on
legislation we look at all legislation
that affects real estate in particularly
landlord tenant law we have a membership
of about 3500 we get out give out our
legislative update to the members each
week during this legislative
season I'm a landlord for over 30 years
probably about 35 years I've got a
number of properties myself that are
older I've been very involved in the
lead world so to speak I've served on
two year-long Le commissions I've served
on a committee that rewrote the rules
for Led in the state of New Hampshire I
teach the RRP course that people been
talking about and I have a very large
knowledge and background on the subject
of lead so I would like to invite
everyone to be asking me questions to
get in perspective from a property
owner's position there are tremendous
amount of problems with this bill and
the cost that it will in uh create it is
absolutely not a no cost solution I'm
sorry to hear that that's been
represented to you I've got a lot of
things to say I have talking points that
I will pass out a copy I have emailed
you last night and I probably won't have
enough time to go through it but I
invite you to ask
questions so I just get started and I
guess you have to pull the hook at some
point um landlords did not create the
the lead hazards this the use of lead
based paint was dramatically um popular
it was the best functional paint ever
invented unfortunately it was extremely
poisonous at the same time it was very
commonly used very much recommended to
be used and it's just a plague on our
society it's a societal problem it
should not be placed to one set of
stakeholders namely housing providers to
brunt the full cost of this and every
time there's a piece of legislation it's
always aimed
at um forcing housing providers to to
pay for this solution which is not
something they created it was it was
part of our society the cost of
abatement uh ranges all over the place
if you have a little bit of work to do
it's going to be a little bit of a cost
if you got a lot of work to do because
nothing's been done over the years it's
going to be a large cost but there is an
average in the last set of grants that
were in Sullivan County the average cost
was 30,000 per unit in nashwa it was
28,000 per unit and in Statewide it was
26,000 per unit so if you have an 8un
building and you find out that there was
one child that had an elevation and the
present law says any other units with
children will be inspected and you end
up with three units in the building that
come under order now that's three *
$30,000 that's $90,000
average it's not you know precisely that
number but if we switch back to
inspecting all
units then that will become eight units
under a batement order that'll be 8 time
30 that'll be
$240,000 how can you say moving from
90,000 to
$240,000 is no cost solution sir if you
could please start wrapping up there's
probably three hours more to talk about
um sorry if you have written testimony
we'd be glad to see that so testing data
let's talk about that in 2010 you are
going to need to start wrapping up
certain this will be a wrap up then okay
the 10 2010 177% of the children tested
measured between 5 and N micrograms per
deciliter people are talking about so
much more uh elevations in
49% we've done an amazing job in
reducing the amount of lead poisoning in
children and it's because the property
owners have been buring the face of this
and paying for re Renovations and
eliminating lead hazards thank you go
ahead in courtesy to other speakers I
will
have we would be glad to have you email
that us so we can really look at what
you have I emailed this last night
there's one update to it that I have
another link to have referred to okay
there's a lot to say about the RRP
that's been misrepresented thank you
I'll open up uh to committee questions
representative
delus thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question thank you is
there if this let's say you've you've
got that scenario you've got your eight
units they come in they check need needs
to be
remediated is there any recourse with
insurance or anything like that no no
there is um
HUD offers grant
money and the state of New Hampshire has
some grants from HUD to do L
abatements the the crazy thing about it
is that you could use RRP to handle the
renovation to get the property back to
an Abad safe State at half the the cost
abatement thank you any other questions
yes representative
lontine um thank you and I was going to
ask the same question about grants and
have you used grants yourself to help
pay for the abatements I have and the
process is is fraught with several
problems the Grant so the grant money
can be a godsend if you've been given an
abatement order you have no choice it's
like you're going to have to either pay
all of this money or you turn in the
keys and you lose the property because
you can't afford it and that's happened
many many many times to Property Owners
you got someone that eats some
applesauce that was tainted with lead in
2023 and now they have an elevation and
now the property is put under order so
yes I've used the grant money
voluntarily and I've learned a lot about
it and some of the issues with it is
that the grants are approved not based
on the property owner the grant is
approved based on the income of the
tenants so if the tenants income is
above what HUD allows you don't get the
Grant and you're still under order and
the Grant and the the baitman is the
most expensive way to handle the
solution it can be handled at almost no
cost thank you representative Sebert did
you have a question um that kind of
covered it okay any other
questions seeing none thank you
sir next we have Rick is it okay former
representative and I'm sorry I did not
know that you should have put that on
your pink card former uh representative
Rich oh dear P patima I'll help you with
that Deena Deena thank you you have
three minutes thank you ma'am thank you
good afternoon Representatives I'm a
former member of one second before your
time starts can you spell your last name
sure uh d i capital P is in Peter e n t
m a penmanship was not my best subject
in school thank you for your patience
thank you representative um glad to be
here I'm a former member of the house
and a member of this committee for four
years and uh glad to be home and some of
my former colleagues Jim McKay who
served with me I'll read my testimonies
so it'll be quick and easy and I sent it
to you online as well um again my name
is Rich deepen tea from Portsmith New
Hampshire former state representative uh
I've had over 30 years of Public Health
experience and I won't list all of it
but most of it was I worked for the
State of New Hampshire division of
Public Health Services was assistant
director of Public Health chief of
communicable disease epidemiology in
Manchester I was deputy director of
Public Health in Manchester and also
chief of Environmental Health in the
city of Manchester so I had a lot of
firsthand experience with lead poisoning
during my career over my more than 30
years of Public Health I've had
extensive involvement in the serious
problem of childhood lead poisoning
unfortunately despite years of effort to
Institute Common Sense primary
prevention of lead poisoning we are
still waiting for children to become
poisoned and even having their brains
permanently harmed before we took action
the most devastating consequential event
in my public health career was leading
the investigation of a death of a
2-year-old child in
Manchester as a result of lead poisoning
in
2000 this child having arrived as a
refugee was placed in a home in
Manchester with serious lived hazards
within two months she suffered aute lead
poisoning as a result of ingesting lead
paint with a lead content of 35% by
weight her blood lead level was
391 micrograms per deciliter I'm still
haunted by that
investigation yet even with the death of
almost almost 25 years ago we are still
refusing to properly prevent and manage
this ongoing crisis in fact a recent
state report as you saw that uh 1142
children have been reported with
elevated blood levels the highest number
ever reported and probably a very
under reported number because of the
lack of testing of all children age 1
and two it is long pass time for New
Hampshire to start treating lead
poisoning like every other disease we
need to put prevention first a number of
years ago when the New Hampshire notice
loons dying of lead poisoning for
ingesting lead fishing tackle as a
result the legislature acted very
swiftly to ban the use of lead in
freshwater fishing tank this was the
right thing to do if we can do this for
loons why can't we take aggressive
action to prevent lead poisoning amongst
our precious
children not only are human costs of
lead Point enormous so are the economic
costs the medical expenses special
education costs criminal justice costs
are huge a 1991 CDC report concluded
that the US pre-1950 this is pre-1950
housing for which 80% contend lead paint
were baited the cost savings over the
cost of the bait over 20 years would be
$28
billion at any rate the money saved by
governments individuals and communities
would be vastly more than the cost of
abatement we've been kicking this can
down the road for over 50 years while
children continue to become poison as
Einstein said continuing to do the same
thing over and over again and expecting
different results is a definition of
insanity although the symptoms of lead
poisoning are silent responsible leaders
and child Advocates cannot continue to
remain silent about what needs to be
done to end this epidemic New Hampshire
could make history by putting in place a
primary prevention system to finally end
the scourge of child poisoning while we
cannot undo the harm caused by our past
neglect we can celebrate commitment to
the future generation of children thank
you thank you be happy to answer any
questions thank you does the committee
have any
questions yes yes representative Sebert
yeah um I just well I was kind of a
statement I just wanted to say thank you
for coming to justify and I know what
you're talking about I actually saw that
on an episode of Forensic Files um yeah
so do you believe that our um our
citizens deserve to be you know very for
for when they move into a property let's
say whether they're renting it or buying
it they deserve to have a clear like
have it on the RFP may have it made
clear to them that whether the house has
Le or not well uh thank you for the
question I think uh right now there is a
requirement that if you sell a house if
you have led you have to you have to
disclose that uh to the prospective
buyers that includes people who buy
rental properties when they buy a rental
property whether it has two five or 10
units they know before they buy that
property whether it has lead hazards in
it so they are buying a property with a
knowledge that if they don't do anything
to those units that have lead
that they are going to be renting it to
people so they know it ahead of time so
once a child becomes lead poison they
shouldn't be surprised by the fact that
a child became lead poison they should
have known it ahead of time when they
bought the property and maybe could have
negotiated a lower price for that
property because of the existing lead
Hazard thank you representative
Lucas thank you and thanks for
testifying today um how long has that
been in effect um that the disclosure of
fled in property oh I'm not sure exactly
but at least at least 20 years at least
I'm not sure the exact date but thank
you thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you ma'am
thank
Ellis we ask that you keep your
testimony to three minutes
um to The Honorable chair and members of
the health human services and elderly
Affairs committee my name is Molly Ellis
I'm a resident of
keen and I'm here today to ask you to
vote in support of House Bill 724 and I
apologize that I did not see the
amendment before I wrote my testimony so
that threw me off a tiny bit but um a
few years ago I received news that my
son's lead level was elevated so I went
on a mission to learn all that I could
about lead poisoning and I learned that
the level considered to be safe has been
lowered repeatedly over the years
because doctors have learned that even
very low levels can cause harm and in
fact there's no safe level of lead and
the blood and I realized that the
amendment to this bill does um scratch
that requirement for lowering the
maximum level permitted in the blood
before Public Health gets involved but I
think that speaks to the importance of
the second part of the bill now the only
part of the bill um the importance of of
contractors um using proper lead safe
techniques when when doing renovations
our home is a fixer
uper um and we had done lots of projects
on it and any disturbance to materials
containing lead such as sawing scraping
sanding creates increased exposure to
lead and that's probably what caused our
Suns lead poisoning um as homes are the
the primary the primary um reason
contributing to Children's lead
poisoning
um the most effective way to prevent red
lead poisoning is to be aware of the
presence of lead and to use lead safe
for mediation techniques when when doing
renovation so please vote in favor of
House Bill 724 and thank you for your
time and
consideration thank you are you taking
questions yes does the committee have
any yes representative Drew thanks for
taking my
question going back I I I may have
missed it are you renting did you buy we
own our home you own your home yes
follow up were you notified that you had
a lead hazard in your home when you
purchased it uh we knew that because it
was built in 1850 it contained
lead okay so I mean I I'm sure it was on
some of those pages of that we that we
signed but we were aware we just but we
did not we were not aware uh we just
assumed oh you just paint over it you
know we we were not aware um that that
painting over it doesn't solve it we
were not aware that that there are
really specific legally defined
techniques for safely remediating
lead thank you any further
questions seeing none appreciate
please good afternoon um my name is
Katie Hatcher this is Kim Bernard we
work at the NASA division of Public
Health and Community Services I'm a
public health nurse I'm also the lead
coordinator for the program and Kim is
nurse good afternoon we wholeheartedly
support and recommend the changes to
section three that states when a child
living in a rental unit is identified as
being poisoned that all other units in
the dwelling should be inspected
regardless if there are pregnant women
or children under the age of six living
in these units in my six years working
in lead poisoning prevention I can tell
you that if there is lead paint in one
unit there is likely lead paint in other
units with this change in lead
inspection laws we have the opportunity
for primary
prevention which is preventing lead
poisoning before it happens New
Hampshire does not focus on primary
prevention for lead poisoning and that
narrative has to change n just received
a $7.7 million Grant um for lead
remediation that distributes $30,000 per
unit for lead Hazard reduction um
listening to the other testimony here as
a parent and a nurse it hurts my soul to
hear that our children's Futures are not
worth the cost um I'd also like to point
out that we are really disappointed and
discouraged to hear about the amendment
to drop the language of lowering the
Action level from 5 micrograms per
deciliter to 3.5 which is in line with
the CDC if we don't do it now then we
need to do it soon research shows that
even very lowlevel exposures cause
irreversible lifelong cognitive and
behavioral deficits I've been working in
the lead poisoning prevention program in
New Hampshire for many years when the
Action level was 10 micrograms per
deciliter I was there for the transition
from 10 to 7.5 and then 7.5 to 5 we can
transition from 5 to
3.5 DHHS estimates that 280 children
fall between the par parameters of 3.5
and 5 micrograms per deciliter that is
280 children in New Hampshire that we
have the opportunity to approve improve
the Outlook of their Futures and help
them reach their full
potential we're happy to take
questions the committee have any
questions yes representative L montine
thank you and thank you for taking my
question we received some email
suggesting that uh we're focusing too
much on on
exposures in the home and not enough on
nutrition and other causes but isn't it
true that um better nutrition might
mitigate some of the damage from L
exposure but the primary cause is is the
exposure itself that's an excellent
question um and thank you for asking it
and giving us the opportunity to answer
so primarily um in New Hampshire lead
paint is the primary source of exposure
we do do see other exposure sources
through imported products um food
sources and other things um as far as
nutrition yes children that have lead
exposures typically um if they have a
nutritional deficit they will hold on to
lead in their body a lot longer than
children that don't so we do use
nutrition as a counseling um tool to
help families with that that being said
um it is not the only tool that we have
and a lot of children that have lead
poisoning do um subsequently become
anemic so certainly we we monitor the
nutrition but it is not a fail
safe thank you any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you very
Bardo you have three minutes please
thank
you thank
you I also just read
make it
quicker good afternoon committee members
my name is pristine Fardo and I'm here
in my capacity as a member of
Manchester's Board of Mayor and Alderman
proudly representing W four thank you
for your time today and for your service
to our state um thank you to
representative hacken Phillips and the
other sponsors for bringing this
important bill forward I'm here today to
speak in Urgent support of the proposed
legislation over the last couple of
years I've worked I've been closely
involved involved with the formation of
the city's lead exposure prevention
commission I worked for over a year with
retired State Rep Mary Heath and former
Alderman Mary Heath Senator and Alderman
Pat long as well as our uh City's health
department our deputy director Phil
alexos alongside several other concerned
members of the public and advocacy
groups to see that this commission was
formed the commission has 12 members and
consists of landlords property managers
lead risk inspectors
members of our City's planning and
Community Development Department Aldrin
like myself and importantly we also have
members with lived experience this is a
broad Coalition of Highly concerned and
motivated stakeholders and it enjoys
widespread support across our city prior
to my work on the commission I knew that
lead exposure was of course a problem I
had very little idea to the extent of
the problem and more so the prevalence
of the problem especially in
Manchester this particular detail has
always stood out in my mind as I think
it is the most essential thing it's
already been stated but I think it Bears
repeating this a direct quote from
deputy director alexos when making a
presentation to the board of alderman in
2023 lead is a toxic substance there is
no safe level of lead and I cannot say
that enough the body has absolutely no
use for lead and it interferes with both
calcium and iron absorption which are
directly involved in the development of
tissues and the nervous system and the
skeletal system it can have not only
acute effects but it can result in death
about as it's been pointed out we are
seeing a rise in exposure and and
poisonings that cannot be exclusively
exclusively attributed to increased
testing so I won't go into the details
of that uh but something that stands out
to me as a potential cause and we know
there's no single or straightforward
answer as to why we're seeing this
increase but uh what I wanted to speak
today about is uh the increased focus on
alleviating the how housing shortages
across our state as more and more
buildings are renovated rehabbed and
repurposed for housing so too will rise
the risk of lead exposure and
poisoning we should fully expect that
the number of children poisoned will go
up
to put a much finer point on it more
housing equals more lead poisoning and
I'll wrap up um I'll leave you with this
final data point and I think it's also
been spoken about the idea of the cost
in dollars and cents we know that
everyone pays the price including
landlords and other housing providers
but it's estimated that for every dollar
spent to reduce lead poisoning there is
a social return on investment between
$17 and $21
this should not be seen as an expense
but rather as a smart investment it
should not be seen as a p punishment to
housing providers but rather a public
health requirement that our state
supports primary prevention is good math
it's good for everyone and it's
essential for our children thank you
thank you any
wers I believe from the Department of
Services if the committee wouldn't mind
I would like to bring Beverly drwan up
with me as well she works with the
you thank you members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Mich rers
I'm the bureau chief for public health
protection within the division of Public
Health Services um at the Department of
Health and Human Services and with me
today is Beverly drwan and she's the
administrator of the healthy homes and
environment section within the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services um although the uh if the
actually let me before I start my
testimony if the committee agrees um the
department will focus its testimony on
the amendment um as opposed to the
original bill is that
okay with the committee sure okay so
although the department is not taking a
position on the bill as amended um we
would like to thank the bill sponsor for
supporting efforts to reduce childhood
uh Le poisoning and we are happy to be a
resource to the committee and our
available to answer questions that you
may have and with that I'll turn it over
to Beverly to continue thank you so the
department recently published our 2023
lead poisoning in the Hampshire data
brief which I believe you all have in
the data brief the 20 23 data shows that
1,142 New Hampshire children had
elevated blood leads high enough to
impair their ability to think learn and
concentrate the data in the brief also
indicates that lead safe Housing
Initiative support primary prevention
efforts since the bill Bill's been
amended to remove the provisions to
lower the blood Le Action level from
five uh micrograms of deciliter of whole
blood to 3.5 micrograms per deciliter
the fiscal impact to the department
should this amended Bill be enacted have
significantly changed from the original
estimate in the Department's fiscal note
worksheet the department originally
estimated the need for additional
funding to support activities associated
with increase in lead poisoning cases
that that would need environmental and
nurse case management as a result of
lowering the blood Le Action level to
the cdc's blood Le reference value of
3.5 since this provision has been
removed from the bill the department
does not anticipate significant fiscal
impacts associated with the remaining
Provisions specifically the department
is not anticipating significant
increases in expenditures as a result of
the proposed amendment to RSA 13A
semicolon 6 to require the department to
conduct inspections for the purposes of
identifying the present of lead-based
substances in all the other dwelling
units within a multi unit building that
have been identified as having a child
with an elevated blood Le level residing
in that
building since the department will
already be on site on site to conduct an
inspection in a dwelling unit of the
impacted child the inspector could also
in conduct inspections of the additional
dwelling units within the building at
the same time any additional work
related to this provision can be
addressed with existing program
resources this provision supports
prevention efforts by addressing lead
hazards in the building before a child
is
poisoned the department is also not
anticipating an increasing expenditures
as a result of the proposed addition of
the rebuttable presumption that all
dwelling and dwelling units including
residential rental units erected prior
to January 1st 1978 are presumed to
contain lead based substances unless a
licensed lead inspector has determined
that the dwell dwelling or the dwelling
units do not contain lead-based
substances in addition the bill proposes
a new section RSA 13A semicolon 4A that
requires all building permit
applications submitted in the state of
New Hampshire to include the US EPA
renovation and repair the RRP license
number the department would like to
point out to the committee that we don't
have the authority over the issuance of
building permits thank you for the
opportunity to provide this information
Michelle and I are both happy to answer
any questions that you might have okay
thank you any
Drew thank you for taking my question if
a dhss inspector has cleared a
particular unit or a particular building
if a lead Hazard is then found in that
building does that transfer the
liability to the
state so in the state of New Hampshire
if I understand you correctly a licens l
uh licensed risk assessor is the only
person who can clear a unit they're the
people who go into the unit to determine
there's no more lead hazards so if a
unit has been
cleared and another child has a blood
elevation then that unit uh we would go
back and we would conduct an
investigation to find out what failed in
that abatement or if there's new hazards
that have sprung up or arrived since the
building was cleared does that answer
your
question okay
follow not entirely no the issue I'm I'm
specifically concerned about is legal
liability in other words what it seems
like and I realize this is a much
broader question I'm just it when when
the state is doing this inspection the
state is saying
that this building does not have lead
hazards and if it's then later found
that that building does have lead lead
hazards does that liability simply fall
on the landlord again or does it
transfer to the state because the state
was the one who said that the building
was clear does that make sense um can
you speak to that yeah I think I can so
lead hazards are a moment in time so
I'll give you an example so if I paint
my staircase and it's all painted and
it's pristine and there's no hazards
there's no chipping or painting but then
my husband moves a couch or Bureau up
the staircase and bangs it and there's
chips 10 minutes later there's hazards
so when the department goes on site to
do an investigation an inspection to
determine if a child that had an
elevation they are if there's lead
hazards in the building and we find that
there are no lead hazards no chipping no
friction no impact no chewable it's that
moment in time and then maybe a day
later 10 days later a month later
there's a child with a blood Le
elevation there could be new hazards
there that we didn't see and that
landlord is there anything you want to
add so potentially a landlord could be
put in the lead abatement process more
than once
you representative Kofa thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so just as a point of
clarification so if I'm a housing
provider and I want to get a lead safe
certificate um am am I calling upon a
state inspector or am I calling upon a
licensed risk assessor who is an
independent party you are correct you
are calling on an independent New
Hampshire license risk assessor to give
other
questions representative
McGrath so um this is thank you Mr chair
thank you for take my question so this
is important work but I've heard people
mention things like applesauce and other
sources of lead how do how do we assess
that um maybe the child has been exposed
some to some other source like where how
does that
those cases get discovered so our data
tells us that of the children who have
blood Le elevations 70% of those
children have been exposed to hazards
from the built environment the house 15%
are from consumer products and 15% of
those are from drinking water so when we
go do an
investigation um Katie Hatcher is one of
the people who spoke earlier who does
investigations on behalf of the state
she's a nurse a contracted nurse to the
state she'll go out and interview with
the family to find
out that Child's Play Habits eating
habits where they go and where they act
so we can identify where the source of
questions seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Sarah Holland
Realtors good afternoon thank you Mr
chair thank you committee um my name is
Sarah Holland I am a real estate broker
in central New Hampshire and I am the
current chair of public policy for the
New Hampshire Association Realtors the
Realtors have concerns um about this
legislation regarding the timing and
adding to the already um escalated
housing crisis that we have and this is
a very narrow objection on this
legislation um so with this legislation
if there's a concern with one unit then
there's going to be a concern to
mitigate all units in a particular
building and as Mr Norman had noted
there's an added cost for that and
that's going to be coming through either
grant program or it's going to be coming
out of the pocket of that particular
landlord and that creates additional
Financial strain and that Financial
strain creates a lot of uncertainty for
those tenants number one in in the
mitigation process those tenants are
going to need to vacate that property
and currently there's nowhere to go so
if there's one unit that needs to be
vacated in a building that's difficult
enough in this current environment but
if there are 10 or more units that need
to be vacated that's that's exponential
that's really difficult to manage um
additionally when landlords struggle
with this they're going to need to come
if they choose to put their property
back online for rent and allow those
tenants to move back in there might be
an an additional cost to rent for those
tenants or for future tenants so they
can make up these costs so these are all
concerns the money has to come from from
somewhere and I know that there is a
mitigation fund um and we're happy to to
have conversations kind of outside of
this Committee hearing regarding how
much money is still in that fund how
much we anticipate coming into that fund
going forward so we can come up with
some sort of um solution last year we
passed legislation um that any new
residential conversions to rental so
existing homes that are now turning into
residential rentals needed to be
certified LED safe um prior to that
occupancy and that process is incredibly
slow and it is incredibly cumbersome and
cost uh costly to folks that are looking
to do that and I know in my practice
folks who were looking to purchase those
properties and turn them into rentals
with this new legislation they've kind
of shied away from that so those
properties are not coming online as we
were hoping that they would in a safe
manner to help with this um with this
crisis um and most recently um I spoke
with a a colleague who had a client that
owns their own home and their child
tested um High Le levels and they are
working through the process to get grant
funding to be able to mitigate that in
their own primary home however there's
no place for them to go in the meantime
and now they have this knowledge that
this house is poisoning their child
so these are concerns that need to be um
that need to be thought through when
weighing this particular legislation we
do not have enough homes out there for
folks to be able to move to during this
mitigation process C we don't have
enough homes period so we need new safe
homes out there for folks happy to take
any question actually hold on um
something was mentioned earlier uh lead
disclosures those lead disclosures need
to go out prior to the um in the sale
process everyone is going to be um
provided a lead disclosure for any
property that is pre1 1978 and also in
the Rental process any P prospective
tenant also needs to be Prov provided a
um a lead disclosure for properties that
are older than 1978 as
well happy to take any questions thank
you any
questions yes representative cber yeah I
just have a question I feel it to be
pretty reasonable in regards to like you
know we do we do know that there are a
lot of some people call them renovation
evictions but whatever they are when
when they do you know displace folks and
they're going to do a renovation on that
property whether it's slapping on a pain
of coat coat of paint sorry paint of
coat a coat of paint or whatever it is
um upgrading a few things why would we
not do we require that to be Abad within
that process I mean I understand it's
cumbersome and that type of a thing but
Al still is the law um we you know what
would be a solution for that for you
versus let's just keep leaving the
situation
the way it is um if I could ask for a
clarification on your question are you
asking about folks that are um having
tenants vacate so then they can do
Renovations on their property that are
not relative to lead paint yeah why
would you not address that at the same
time that's it I that's up to the
landlord I I can't answer that it does
seem it does seem reasonable unless
there is a cost aspect of that is
just cost prohibitive for them to do so
yeah all
right other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you okay no one else has signed up to
testify on HB 724 FN does anyone else
wish
to
ma'am oh oh okay uh you put down 756
that's the next bill did you want to
testify this one El okay could you fill
please well you also want to testify on
this one too right no oh you don't okay
okay I'll just change this one
[Music]
then thank you chair members of the
committee so my name is uh Joan O'Brien
and I'm the president of the New
Hampshire animal rights league and we
were formed in
1977 so we've been around for almost 50
years years and we are our mission is to
protect animals from Human induced forms
of harm so I wanted to speak to this
bill today because I wanted to discuss a
a large a largely
undiscussed um
potential exposure to lead which is lead
in hunted meat and I attend the monthly
New Hampshire fishing Game Commission
meetings and a few years ago the vendor
dor Scott Mason was discussing a a
ballistics demonstration that he had
attended where they showed that a lead
bullet is shedding lead all the way
through its path you know when if you
shoot an animal and he said and then
you've got lead in your meat so I
thought interesting and then later I
learned about there we have something
called The Hunt For The Hungry program
and that is a program where you can
donate venison to the food bank and I
thought gosh I wonder if you know those
people are at risk that's a you know a
vulnerable population of people getting
food from the food bank maybe they're
getting meat with lead and so I did some
research into it and in fact you know if
you shoot a lead bullet into an animal
the fragments lead fragments into a lot
of little pieces they can be 18 in from
the site where the bullet hit and
Hunters are accustomed to like field
dressing their animal and they would cut
around you know the the place where the
bullet hit but they might not get all of
the the rest of the fragments and um so
I did call the food bank and the
director there had never this had never
come up um and she said we have the meat
processed by approved butchers um but
the butcher didn't call me back but I
read a study where they took 30 deer in
another state took 30 deer to 30
different butchers and and tested the
ground meat and they found lead in 24 of
the samples so 24 out of 30
butchers um so it's I think it's just a
largely
undiscussed exposure and I know that
Medicaid recipients are all over the
state including in rural areas where
hunting is popular and um poaching is
also something that happens all over the
state and recently they fishing game
donated 350 lbs of poached meat to
I'm not sure where actually but you can
imagine somebody poaching an animal
might have shot it with a lead bullet
not probably not caring too much so I
did write an article about this which
was published in the New Hampshire
bulletin and
um yeah and we we to raise awareness we
tabled about this in 2022 at the N
Hampshire fishing game um discover wild
New Hampshire day and we had a petition
yeah I'm almost done we had a petition
we got 250 signatures asking the
department to take some action like a
buyback program an ammo buyback program
or something like that so nothing's
happened yet but I just couldn't resist
this opportunity to raise this and on
your website it doesn't mention hunted
meat as an exposure shooting Rangers are
mentioned but not hunted animals so
thank you thank you any represent
palazov thank you Mr chair and thank you
for sharing this concern with us uh so
obviously exposure is possible but do
you know of any case somebody was
poisoned uh by New Hampshire and needed
medical help because he or she were
eating venison or some other haunted
meat I don't know of any you know data
about that because I think it it's
largely undetected and people don't
think about it should be you know where
from other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
thank
you okay I have no one else signed up to
testify does anybody else wish to
testify on HB 724
FN seeing no I am going to close the
public hearing on HB 724 FN uh the next
bill is scheduled to be heard at 2:30
which is 756 FM so we will be in recess
you
e
like to reconvene and we have one bill
left to be heard today and it's HB 756
FN uh the prime sponsor is
representative Heath Howard and he is at
the W uh witness table and ready to go
welcome back representative Howard thank
you honorable Mr chair and uh committee
members uh my name is representative
Heath Howard I represent the towns of
straford and barington in straford
District 4 uh today I'm introducing HB
756 uh which is uh lead blood testing
levels uh so lead poisoning among
children is rising dramatically across
our state uh the proposed legislation
mandates blood level uh blood Le level
testing for children aged six or upon
entry into a public school or Child Care
Agency uh which is critical Timely uh
and is actually a response to the
alarming data uh revealing a 43% surge
in lead poisoning cases in 2023 with
1,142 children suffering harmful blood
lead levels and lowincome Medicaid uh
insured children twice as likely to be
poison this legislation is a moral and
practical imperative to prot protect the
vulnerable youth lead poisoning causes
irreversible cognitive damage uh
impairing learning concentration and
lifelong potential the recent Spike saw
342 more children poisoned in 2023 than
the previous year signals a systemic
failure while increased testing post
pandemic explains some of the rise
experts have warned the true tool is
likely higher this legislation closes
that Gap by requiring Universal testing
ensuring no child slips through these
cracks as you have heard in the previous
Bill low-income families bear the front
of this crisis as older rental housing
often uh disrepair uh is Laden with lead
paint uh disproportionately houses
Medicaid insured children mandatory
testing ensures early detection for all
regardless of income and empowers
parents with state provided educational
resources to mitigate risks lead
poisoning costs taxpayers millions in
healthcare special education and loss
productivity earlier detection is far
cheaper than treating lifelong
disabilities and this legislation's
testing mandate uh paired with
exemptions for religious exceptions
balances Public Health needs with
individual rights while reducing
long-term economic burdens New Hampshire
cannot ignore a crisis poisoning its
future generations with lead levels at
historic highs and vulnerable children
at the most risk this legislation is
necessary evidence-based intervention it
priorites uh prevention and
accountability safeguarding Children's
Health while addressing the root causes
of exposure passing this bill is not
just policy but it is a moral duty to
protect New Hampshire's children and
build a healthier Fair future for all
thank you so much and I'm open to any
questions thank you representative
Woods thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um just um was
there a particular reason that you
limited it to Public
Schools um I believe believe so this is
a resubmission of uh legislation that
was proposed last year uh and I mean I
do think that the public schools is the
best and easiest way to implement this
without necessarily uh trying to get
involved with uh private
entities follow up um but just in view
of fairness wouldn't it be applicable to
all schools I think that it could be
well again follow comment perhaps to
clarify um say a child does go to a
private school and finds out he has
difficulty because of lead
poisoning currently they don't have the
ability to take a child with
IEPs and it's a cons that falls back to
the public schools so in that sense the
private schools then would reap the
benefit of that service uh without any
responsibility and so therefore I would
say uh I would encourage you to consider
having it all schools yeah I may be uh
also incorrect about this uh but I
believe it also would allow any children
uh aged
six to potentially be able to be
eligible for that again I'm sorry I'm I
don't have uh full text in front of me
10 yes yeah yes I understand what you're
saying that would be for someone who had
been domiciled from birth if someone is
say coming from some other venue uh into
the state and it wants to enter directly
into the school system at that time they
would not have been included yeah oh I I
understand what you're trying to say
that would be a good amendment to to add
in to make sure that all students would
be eligible for
questions I'm seeing none okay thank you
also signed up to speak is
do uh good afternoon members of the
committee I'm representative Alice weed
uh representing do W 2 and straford
district 15 and I'm one of the
co-sponsors on this
bill so um the really the core part of
the spill it gets at is having data on
lead poisoning the the importance of
that in terms of abatement cannot be
understated knowing whether or not a
child has had
exposure is just the very start of the
process um and it can help not only
improve that child's health it can
prevent them from being exposed in the
future if you catch it early um but it
can also Trends um in the area and can
prent prevent additional exposure to
many more
people let's say if one child tests
positive you can test their home and
maybe you find contaminants um on the
window sill or on the door frames from
when it rubs you can treat that um if
you don't find contaminants the
investigators can go through further
processes to identify um exposure
through food products like was mentioned
during the last hearing and that can
help um identify those issues and then
prevent thousands more children from
being exposed to that
contamination you know it can it can
help that child it can help any child
that moves into that house in the future
um if another child if their friend
visits their house it can prevent them
from exposure maybe it's in the soil and
it can help their neighbors too
you know the same goes for things like
daycares um and those Trends can only be
identified when you have sufficient data
you know lead back in the 1900s was
everywhere um in our paint and our
gasoline and we did a lot of great work
to prevent that but a lot of those older
buildings as is the case here in New
Hampshire still have a lot of lead paint
in them Flakes and
all of that and this problem doesn't go
away on its own lead doesn't degrade on
its own um without actively working to
address
it you know just this week it's been
mentioned nhpr released um the the
headline with the report about how lead
poisoning is the highest they've ever
been since we started
testing and that's likely a significant
undercount because testing is not
currently
Universal that exposure has drastic
effects on the health of children it
impedes their brain development and
causes a number of additional health
issues you know there have been a lot of
studies that correlate lead exposure to
higher rates of crime lower IQ uh other
health defects like damage to their
brain their nervous system you know
challenges with with hearing and
speaking processing and many learning
disorders um you know and treating this
lead exposure has a high return on
investment yielding at least $17 for
every $1 you spend on
it and that's why this bill is in
everyone's best interest since you can
only treat lead if you know it's a
problem in the first place and I
strongly urge you to vote on to pass on
this bill uh thank you and I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is
representative Nancy Murphy from hills
is good afternoon Mr chair and honorable
members of the committee I'm Nancy
Murphy uh representing Hillsboro 12 the
town of
March um I'm here um as a co-sponsor and
to expr my support for HB
756 um HB 766 756 is both a public
health and Child Protection bill it's
important to remember that there is no
safe level for lead in a child's body
lead is a neurotoxin which causes
neurodevelopmental disabilities in
children resulting in learning and
behavioral challenges that can be
lifelong increased cost for special
education services result in higher
property tax for New Hampshire citizens
though the analysis notes that this bill
establishes a blood testing requirement
for children entering daycare in public
schools we should be clear that the
requirement is not actually for the
testing itself as that is already in
current RSA following a study Commission
on lead poisoning that led to SB 147
being passed into law in
2018 HB 756 does not add any new
requirements for physical examination
nor lab testing for lead rather the
requirement referenced in the bill
analysis pertains to a notation on the
school daycare Health form of a single
Le testing result which would not be
necessary If the child is Exempted
should the child's health form be
missing that single blood level testing
result that New Hampshire statute
already requires the school or daycare
will a remind the parent guardian of the
lead testing requirement and B provide
them New Hampshire DHHS supplied
educational
materials uh relative to lead poisoning
and the importance of lead testing it's
hope that HB 756 will lead to increased
compliance with lead level testing so
that parents of children found to have
elevated lead levels can have a better
understanding of risks relative to lead
toxicity and the options for
treatment this will afford parents the
opportunity to intervene quickly and
protect the health and well-being of
their children thank you for your time
and attention I asked uh that you
recommend OTP on HB 756 thank you thank
you any
questions say no questions thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Katie
Hatcher from I believe it's ntional
Services as is someone with you also um
she she is speaking separately okay good
afternoon again my name is Katie Hatcher
um at the NASA division of Public Health
I have been a registered nurse for 15
years and I have been working as a
public health nurse doing lead poisoning
prevention directly with families for
six years thank you for allowing me to
speak um all New Hampshire children
deserve the freedom to reach their full
potential and lead poisoning robs our
children of that freedom lead is a
neurot talk
and children under the age of 6 years
old do not have a fully formed bloodb
brain barrier to protect themselves from
that poison there is no safe level of
lead in a child's body the human body
does not know what to do with lead when
it enters the body so your body actually
think it's calcium lead follows the path
that calcium takes throughout the body
so it goes directly to the brain your
blood soft tissues and your
bones the research shows that even very
low levels of lead causes irreversible
cognitive deficits developmental delays
lower IQ speech delays the need for
special education services in school and
there is even correlation that childhood
lead poisoning can cause incarceration
as adults because lead can affect the
impulse decision-making part of your
brain we have to stop the cycle of
generational lead poisoning which
perpetuates the cycle of poverty when a
child is poisoned 95% of the lead burden
goes directly to their bones and it
stays there for decades upon decades
even if that child is removed from all
environmental lead hazards their own
bones become the exposure Source I'm
going to repeat that because I think
it's really important when a child is
poisoned 95% of the lead burden goes
directly to their bones and it stays
there for decades upon decades even if
the the child is removed from all
environmental lead hazards their bones
will become the exposure source for
example a female child who is lead
poisoned reaches childbearing age she
becomes pregnant during the second
trimester of her pregnancy her fetus
tries to pull calcium from her mother's
bones to make bones for the fetus when
there is lead in the bones lead gets
pulled instead of calcium so that fetus
becomes lead
poisoned another another example is when
a child is lead poisoned the lead stays
in their bones they become elderly if
they develop
osteoporosis that lead is leeched back
into their blood and they're lead
poisoned again when they're when they're
age childhood lead poisoning is 100 100%
preventable it is irreversible it causes
lifelong def deficits for the child the
family the community and and our economy
we have the power today right now to
make a difference for the children of
New Hampshire and I ask you to please
support this Bill thank you prect
questions see no questions thank you for
you also signed up to speak is Molly
good afternoon to the chair and the
committee again and thank you that was
that was wonderful and said a lot of
what I was going to say so I'll be very
very brief my name is Molly Ellis I'm a
resident of keen New
Hampshire um I'm here again to ask you
to support House Bill
756 uh when I discovered that my son's
blood lead level was elevated a few
years ago I really really
panicked um because doctors have
discovered that there is no safe blood
level in the blood um it is especially
crucial to test very young children
because as we as we just heard um they
have no blood brain barrier and the lead
is absorbed into their brains which
um which causes so many so many terrible
problems um It's associated with um
behavioral problems uh cognitive
impairment um stunted growth hearing
problems even
incarceration um because we learned
about my son's elevated lead level his
his Outlook is very good and uh this
bill can help keep other children's
future safe as well so please vote in
favor of of House Bill 756 thank you for
your time and consideration and I will
take any questions if anybody has any
thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Jackie
Hampshire is it Jackie or is it Jack
clay or Jackie well it's Jack Jacqueline
oh okay when I was in trouble with my
parents but I'm Jackie okay um how do
you do chairman McDonald and members of
the committee my name is Jackie Cowell I
am the executive director of early
learning New Hampshire we are a
Statewide nonprofit and our mission is
to ensure that all New Hampshire
children have the opportunity to reach
their full potential um we do that
through supporting Child Care programs
as well as the families they serve and
so we are actually um coming in
opposition to this build not because of
its intent but simply because of its
solution we feel there is a more logical
and efficient solution than what is
proposed in this bill um knowing again
that there is a requirement to have
blood Le level testing um we do not
oppose at all having a an extra line on
the health form that goes to the public
schools or for child care
agencies um but having the burden and
the duty of it not being completed going
back to the child care provider and then
alerting the parent and trying to give
the parent documents why it seems so
much more efficient that the healthc
care provider fill it out it or if they
don't have the information they have the
capacity to do that testing there it
does not make sense to us adding this
extra paperwork and documentation for
something that could we believe be much
better fulfilled if it was the health
care provider who was required to fill
that out
thank
you thank you any
questions seeing no
lonte hi thank you
um though I think the point of the bill
is to be able to identify
children uh that enroll in a daycare
that perhaps never um were tested it's
just just a feel safe right I do
understand that but the first order of
what's going to happen is a healthcare
provider will fill out the
form there has that has to happen before
they enter that they have that Health
form filled out so if there's a new line
there that the provide that the child
care provider would be reading so would
the health care provider and if there's
it's blank and there's no testing it
seems more logical to us that the
healthc care provider then take action
okay does that make
sense
yeah representative kofalt and then
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so current statute does require
Leed testing for children between one
and two I believe if I understand
correctly and so um it seems to me that
this bill would cover two scenarios one
is children who were exposed at some
point after they were initially tested
by a physician and the other would be
children who moved to New Hampshire you
know whose families moved to New
Hampshire from out of state um it seems
to me that that sort of uh gives us a a
much smaller subset not I mean obviously
every child is important we want those
children to be safe and and healthy but
um can you comment on sort of what do
you think the impact is in terms of sort
of the procedural concerns that you
brought up and the fact that we are
already requiring lead testing for
children um before the age of two yeah
and again I I applaud the intent of of
the sponsors of this bill and I um feel
that it's a good idea to have that new
part on the form that's not there now
saying what the blood Le level to is and
again because the first contact with
that form is not the childcare provider
it's the health care provider that if
that is not
there um that's where it's best caught
and and resolved when they when they're
filling that form out whether they're
going to a childcare program or a public
school representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
think I have two questions the first is
what happens to that form ah yeah so it
is filed and uh data is kept on
immunizations um there is an annual
report that is required by childcare
programs um this again part of what I'm
thinking about is if this form comes
incomplete um then this bill then asks
the child care provider rather than
asking the form to be complete ask the
childcare provider to notice that
document you know U go back to the
parent tell them give them forms you
know tell them that they have to have it
completed Etc that seems a lot less
efficient and may not result in a quick
solution
um this really more of a second question
a follow up and I apologize if you're
not the right person to answer this but
all the form requires is that at some
point between the age of one and six
you've had a blood test which by law has
to be between one and two which means
there's a big gap between two and six
right and I'm I'm not the best person to
answer that all I know is that this bill
talks about it being that if it's blank
that the childcare or the public school
then connects to the parent and does
some documentation of disseminating
information Etc yeah thanks
representative Woods uh thank you Mr
chair and you again may or may may or
may not be able to answer the question
uh we we talked about all kids by law
have to be tested from up to Age Two uh
but um what is the actual compliance
with that uh sitting on a commission
couple years ago we found the compliance
was really poor so when we read this do
we know what the current compliance is
for I don't know yeah that's that's not
my expertise again um it's that whether
they fill it in whether they have if the
healthc care provider has the blood Le
level
I'm seeing none okay thank you sure
thank
you also signed up to speak is Kim
Bernard from Nash Department of Public
Health
again okay so my name is Kim Bernard um
I've been a registered nurse for 30 plus
years I currently am the chief public
health nurse at the nashwa division of
Public Health and Community
Services children have that have led
poisoning typically look happy and
healthy as the cognitive and behavioral
deficits often times do not show
themselves until school age the only way
to know if a child is Led poisoned is to
test them Universal testing has been a
great start to increasing testing rates
in New Hampshire however according to
recently published 2023 data brief 24%
of one-year-olds are not being tested
and 31% of 2-year-olds are not being
tested that's a lot of children in New
Hampshire that are slipping through the
cracks we know that lead poisoning
disproportionately affects lowincome
populations New Hampshire children on
Medicaid as was discussed during the
last bill are twice as likely to have
lead poisoning research shows that many
children who have lead poisoning
required special education services to
access their
educations there are new studies that
have just been published correlating
childhood lead poisoning with mental
health um with mental illness as
adults part of the job that we do in
public health is provide nurse case
management to children who are LED
poisoned as well as their families we go
into their homes we work with these
families over months sometimes
years because it takes a very long time
to get lead out of a child's body even
when the lead hazards are
removed we connect with these families
we connect these families with Community
Resources such as early supports which
includes early intervention for one to
threey olds with things such as OT
occupational therapy speech therapy
physical therapy because we know these
children are at high resk risk for de
developmental and behavioral
deficits we also connect these families
to Wick because Healthy nutrition as my
colleague had mentioned is one of the
tools that we use to help um with lead
poisoning because often times it can
cause
anemia these families feel like their
lives have been turned upside down that
their home is not safe that their child
may not be able to have the future they
envisioned for them we have seen
children as not as young as 9 months
test positive for lead from home
renovations we are seeing an increas in
of five and sixy olds having lead
poisoning due to lead in food such as
wabana apples saces that were recalled
cinnamon and other imported spices from
India and Southeast
Asia childhood lead poison is 100%
preventable it causes lifelong deficits
for the child the family the community
and our
economy we have the power today right
now to make a difference for children of
New Hampshire I ask you to please
support this bill thank you thank you
any
you also signed up to speak I'm Michelle
Roberge and Beverly drwan from the
Services thank you member MERS of the
committee for the record my name is
Michelle robers I'm the bureau chief for
public health protection within the
division of Public Health Services at
the Department of Health and Human
Services and with me today is Beverly
drwan and she's the healthy homes and
environment section administrator with
the Department of Health and Human
Services we wanted to come up and be a
resource to the committee and try to
provide some information that we heard
from some questions I think it was
specifically uh representative Wood's
question related to testing rates for
one and 2 year olds there is a
requirement in RSA
13A colon
a-5a uh which uh New Hampshire is a
universal testing uh State and there's a
requirement for all one and two year
olds uh to be tested for lead um and we
have that data available there is an
exception in the law as well um there we
do have that data and you all should re
have received a copy of the 2023 Le data
brief and so on the first page um you'll
see um at the bottom of the first page
there's a graph and maybe Beverly you
can speak to it a little bit more but
there's a graph that shows the testing
rates for all one and two year olds in
New Hampshire so in New Hampshire right
now
sorry in New Hampshire right now if you
look at the bottom uh graph here it
shows at 2023 that 76% of our one-year
olds were tested for blood Le levels and
69% of our 2-year olds the universal
testing law in the state of New
Hampshire that was implemented in 2018
requires our one-year-olds to be tested
and again our two-year-olds so it's two
tests a one-year-old and a 2-year-old
and if a a child for whatever reason
misses their Well wellcheck Visit and
misses that one or twoyear old test and
they go back to the doctor at their 3
four 5year old if they're under 6 years
old we recommend that they have their
blood Le levels tested so test at one
test it two and if you miss one of those
tests you they they call it catch-up
or5 so I just wanted to make sure the
committee understood New Hampshire's
Universal testing law okay any questions
representative
Nel thanks Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I'm just always curious when
we have laws like that what are the
ramifications for parents if they don't
do
it so there is an exception in law and
assuming no exception assum what is the
ramification if a parent chooses not to
test child just doesn't do it is non
compliant doesn't do it I I would think
the ramifications might be that you
would get your child into into school
and the school district might not have a
flag that this child had a bloodle
elevation which is a a brain injury and
they might not be looking for they might
not get him enrolled in an IEP they
might not be able to start those
Services soon enough yeah the reason I'm
asking the question is laws are only as
good as they are enforceable and if
there's no enforce ability behind this
that's going to affect our ability to do
this I I think it you know it's the it's
the relationship with the between the
pro medical provider and and the parent
and that the recommendation that come
through for that and this law allow you
know just provides that guidance back to
clinicians to to do that t that early on
testing the recommended
guidance representative Woods did you
have your hand up a moment
ago are you one more question I mean I
was looking up the cdc's guidelines and
they actually recommend testing at six
years too are we ever looking at doing
that as well so right now our test in
laws 72 months and younger which is the
month that a child turns six so uh we
educate our providers and the the
Hampshire Academy of Pediatrics in their
Bright Futures guidelines recommends
old representative Woods yeah thank you
I just uh I need need to help me through
your data yeah uh on the
one-year-olds um uh we'll just say for
% uh and then on the same year
that so those are okay I think I
understand that in other words when the
one-year-olds were tested when when
they're two-year-olds they wouldn't be
tested because they were tested when
they're oneyear old no let me help
clarify a little bit Yeah so on the
graph on the bottom of the first page
the blue line is the testing rates for
our one-year olds so if you look at 2022
you can see that 77% of our one-year
olds were tested and it went down
slightly in 23 only 76% of our
one-year-olds were tested but we had
some huge gains with our 2-year-olds so
if you look at 2022 the Orange Line you
can see in 2022 57% of our 2-year olds
were tested and it improved to 69% in
2023 so the law requires a one-year-old
get tested and then because that's when
they start they're mobile right we want
to test them early and then we test them
again at their second birthday two tests
okay that's why I wanted to clarify it's
two tests two test it's not just age
correct no it's two tests and that
citation is in RSA
130-a colon 5A so that's the y That's
the universal testing law requirement
thank you representative
delus thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I hear
request ired
suggested
uh is there is it is it required is it
is it a a bylaw required of parents and
if they do miss having their children
tested are they legally liable to be
fined or taken to court or is there any
te teeth to that so I'm looking at RSA
130a semicolon 5A which is our Universal
section of the blood of the state Le law
and it says all health care providers
who provide Primary Medical Care shall
conduct blood Le testing of all one and
twoyear old patients to determine their
blood Le level a health care provider
shall not be liable for not performing a
test for blood Le level when a parent or
a guardian has been informed of the
blood Le testing requirement has refused
to consent or fail to follow through in
response to a referral for a test
nothing in the section shall prevent a
healthc care provider from RE
recommending blood Le testing for
children younger than one or older than
two should circumstance including
potential lead exposure hazards warrant
such
testing
that representative
mcgrail is
the percentage of untested do you
believe the barrier is those are
uninsured
I don't know that I can speak to that I
don't have that data I I think we know
that some families don't have a medical
home um I think we have a little bit of
ways to go with educating our health
care providers that it's two
tests right so I think it's a
factors other
questions not seeing any thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Melissa
Clement from the Department of Health
unit thank you members of the committee
for the record my name is Melissa
Clement and I'm the chief of the
childcare licensing unit in the
Department of Health and Human Services
I'm just here to answer any questions
may have regarding um the section that
speaks to the health forms in child care
programs um because we would be the one
enforcing that action so if you have any
questions I'm happy to answer them are
there any questions representative Nagel
thanks Mr chair thanks for taking my
question I I if I remember last year
there was a lot of opposition on the
basis of time elements and things like
that it seems to me this is just a
simple check mark that then gets um
transferred ref to somebody else to
review is that accurate sure um let me
um thank you for the question um the
what the process that would happen is a
childcare program would receive the form
they would be reviewing to see if the
lead level was there if the lead level
isn't there according to the bill um the
program would then be required to go
back to the parent and provide resources
or determine if they have refused the
test so what we would be doing when we
go into the program we take a sample of
children's record where we we already
have a health form um it does have a
spot for a blood level test but we would
now
spe excuse me specifically be looking to
see that that section was completed and
then if it wasn't we would have
follow-up questions for the provider to
for them to show us what documentation
they had regarding um what they provided
to the parent so that would be the
process and then if they didn't have
that information they would be cited for
non-compliance because it was not there
and they didn't or they did not provide
the information to the parents as
required other
questions seeing none okay thank you
you no one else has signed up to testify
on this bill does anyone else wish to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on HB 756 FN that is
the last bill we had scheduled for
hearings today so um you know the
hearing portion of our day's work is
completed uh we are going to be going
into executive session shortly to
consider some other bills but we'll be
in uh I don't know does the committee
wish a recess or shall we go directly to
the uh executive session five minutes
okay how about make we'll make it 10
minutes
e
okay I'd like to call the executive
session to
order uh we have uh hoping we're hoping
to get through four bills this afternoon
the first one will be HB 51
representative plaz off I believe you
have a motion uh thank you Mr chair uh I
move or to pass on House Bill 51
relative to hem derived cannabinoids and
the definition of cannabis and
therapeutic cannabis uh so uh this bill
will help let's get a second first
representative mlan I believe I'll
second okay now go ahead representative
Paz off uh thank you uh I I think uh
this bill will help uh uh patients and
provide uh greater variety
of
therapeutic uh
products and it improves the definitions
uh uh in in the law and um there are
some concerns
around uh intoxicating effects uh of uh
uh medical uh marijuana but this bill
actually may help patients to transition
from high Del 9 THC products to blend
that are less
intoxicating so I see this bill is
winwin so please support
it okay thank you um anyone else wish to
speak to this motion or to this
bill seeing no one I'll ask the clerk to
call the role motion is out to pass on
representative merer
yes representative mlan
yes representative
damus representative kofalt yes
representative
Nagel representative poov yes clerk
votes
yes representative marel yes
representative McGrath yes
representative um
sorry emphatic yes represent McKay
yes representative
Woods representative Palmer
yes representative tez yes
representative L montine yes
representative
hartnet representative
Lucas Tim haret representative Harnet
was
double to say I just realized he wasn't
here
today
okay vot is 16 to zero motion
passes um do I get to vote or oh
sorry Reverend McDonald that every clct
does it uh
yes I should put you at the bottom of
the page 17 to Z that that was we were
trying to figure out who sat next to you
representative McGrath ex representative
hartnet that sits there right it's been
though I no in between after that first
bill this morning I missed a lot of
things um so anyway um okay so the bill
the motion passes 17 to zero and
representative palaza you'll get me a a
report within the next couple of days
okay great thank you consent for that uh
uh yeah there's no objection we'll put
that on consent any objection from
anyone representative lontine any
objection next up is HB 53
representative um kofalt perhaps this is
the amendment oh I'm sorry I apologize
representative mlan yes uh thank you Mr
chair um I uh handed out
uh pardon me uh I I uh move Amendment
02 72h to HB
53 okay and uh I will second that
motion and would you like to speak to
your motion representative thank you Mr
chair yes um I was not here for the
public hearing but um it was noted that
there was a a drafting error in the
legislation where the uh implementation
date on page 4 line 27 is no later than
December 1st
2024 which has since come and gone so
the amendment um makes that uh December
1st
2025 okay is
yes any other questions or comments
about this
amendment well depending to lean a
little it on this one so this this is
just on the amendment representative not
the bill
itself just the date change yeah i'mot
on that okay okay so the motion is ought
to pass on um again the amendment number
is 0272 H any other
discussion if not I'll ask the clerk to
call a roll rep merer yes rep mlan yes
rep damus
yes rep kofalt yes rep
Nagel rep poov yes Burk votes yes R
marel yes rep McGrath yes rep
Sebert yes
sorry I don't think they heard you
across the street r r m yes rep Woods
yeah rep
Palmer uh rep Tes yes rep lamantin yes
rep hartnet is not here rep Lucas
yes R McDonald
yes vote is 17 to zero motion
passes okay now the motion before us is
um ought to pass as amended on HB
53 representative cofal are you up for
this one or uh yes I I move ought to
pass with Amendment um um on House Bill
53 okay and representative mlan well
representative
leontine okay representative Lamonte in
seconds um representative kofalt do you
wish to speak to your motion yes I think
uh this bill address addresses three
issues one is access uh there are people
who live uh pretty far away from an ATC
or dispensary and uh it it's a burden
for them to uh to drive long distances
to to get medical
cannabis um I also see a uh potential
cost issue um a lot of these folks um
are operating on a very uh thin budget
prices are high at atc's in New
Hampshire and uh allowing them to
cultivate their own cannabis is uh is
going to save them money and there's
also a safety issue which is that um you
know I have heard that there are medical
cannabis patients who who uh for for
cost and access reasons um
may buy Black Market cannabis off the
street which could bring with it some
potential U safety issues so uh for all
of those reasons I I support House Bill
53 thank you representative
delus so can you put your speak on your
mic thanks for taking the question so
the question is how who is checking on
all this growth stuff I've asked that
was the question I had asked before and
I just I
I don't know if there are enough checks
and balances to this system as far as
being
homegrown so um the same person who
checks all of our homes for illegal
cannabis which is no one unless there's
some reason for them to be in the home
so I you know I I I guess I see this as
saying there is uh permission is granted
and you will not be without outside the
bounds of the law if you cultivate a
certain amount of cannabis for your own
use or if a caregiver does so
um that does not call for or require
inspections in my mind it's simply
saying um this this certain Behavior
will not be deemed illegal under these
circumstances so I don't think it calls
kind representative woods and then
representative Nel um thank you uh in a
general concept I'm I'm in in favor of
the bill however for some of the reasons
that were just stated I have some
concerns um the um atcs have
extraordinarily tight strict regular
oversight about exactly not just growing
it but how much what kind uh Etc
extraordinarily tight
oversight um putting this in an
individual's
home uh um I think with no oversights
that I can
see um other than someone's quotes
suspicion um raises some
concerns uh and I say that from
some background my neighbor a year a few
years ago uh was a federal Ag and dealt
with this issue and at that time uh one
of the major problems uh was growing in
individual
homes uh in rural areas and and people
were coming to New Hampshire for that
purpose because rural areas have very
poor police
coverage and therefore they thought that
we'll buy a house and we'll just grow as
much as we can here and the basement and
everything else is just full of of drugs
of all kinds um so
I with virtually no oversight I think it
does big to say well now I can really I
can can go dark or someone's coming into
your knocking on that individual's door
and say oh you're growing your own look
um I can make this very profitable for
you I'll help you do this if we can use
your basement
concerns other questions other comments
representative Nel thanks Mr chairman um
in the in the um interest of consistency
this is the fourth time I've been able
to vote on this bill twice at the
therapetic hodus medical oversight Bill
and this will be the second time in this
committee and I voted against it every
time um I really appreciate everything
that representative kofalt said because
I agree with everything said um I think
there's probably better ways to address
that one of the things we did was this
morning the um the uh Greenhouse
cultivation which will be a big one for
increasing access to other strains that
we don't have access to now and another
build that we're proposing to increase
the number of ATC dispensary sites which
can solve those problems I think
relatively safely having toward um um
cultivation site and seeing the amount
of science that goes into developing a
reproducible product it's become quite
apparent to me that it's virtually
impossible for a typical lay person to
do that on their own and get a product
that is actually a reproducible thing
there and I could go on that in detail
if you want is to all the factors that
involved in getting something like that
but I just don't think your typical
person can do that and then then when I
asked you know the folks um you know at
the dispensaries and and people
knowledgeable about this we don't think
many people are going to do this anyway
so I said there go well you can't create
a reproducible product it's really not a
pharmaceutical product this is really
not a therapeutic thing um I don't think
we're going to support people growing
opium in their own homes to do the same
thing for opioid related products which
probably have much more medical value
than than cannabis does um I just think
based on all that I just don't think I
can support this bill ever um with that
said I've been very happy to be a 20 19
to1 vote on this three times and I won't
be opposed to being it again in a fourth
but that's be won't be 19 to1 there's
only 17 only 17 of us here so
representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman I was chairman of the committee
to legalize marijuana for five
years uh I I've never had an
experience like that before in the
legislature that the intensity of
feelings on both sides for and against
legalization is still
powerful uh I support this legislation
because it heads in the direction of
distinguishing
between uh the use of marijana for
personal reasons versus the professional
reasons
and that we heard from Jerry and I can't
remember he has a tricky last
name right uh that committee recommends
this
legislation that's what influenced me
those are the doctors who are looking at
this
medication of
marijuana are are finding very
specific uh uses for serious illness
including mental
illness and because of that I see this
as not a major solution but a step in
the right direction therefore I will
support
this anyone else any other comments
discussion representative Mark yes thank
you Mr chairman a couple of things come
up in my mind is when I heard the
original testimony on this bill it was
represented that this was going to
appeal to a very small
Market um the indications were initially
that approximately 15,000 people have
medical marijuana cards in this state
however they made no representations
whatsoever as to what the size then they
indicated there was a necessity or
transport issue um dealing with the
necessity um they never made a showing
as to what number of people or even a
rough estimate as to um what number of
people would actually be growing this
this particular material that's number
one number two is is that I'm concerned
about the addition I think as
representative Nagel points out uh and
as was also pointed out
um what's to prevent these what's to
prevent people in this situation if they
have that kind of financial need or
they're that remote from growing it and
then turning around and selling it and
uh I realize that distribution of
marijuana in the state is illegal but
that doesn't stop people and I'm
wondering if this AIDS and abets it uh
number three the people who were the
proponents of this bill were asked about
the rep about the lead about the statute
uh that exist the statutes that exist as
to growing in surrounding
jurisdictions and uh they weren't able
to discuss it in any way shape or form
other than it exists so I had to take
that upon myself and real and look up
the statutes myself uh they're they're
somewhat different they're also
distinguishable on the grounds that um
our surrounding jurisdictions here also
allow uh personal possession for
non-medicinal use on that basis I
distinguish it so I've looked at this
and I'm not sure that this is really
good public policy beyond that I'd like
to go a little bit further and say as
follows uh number one was I asked about
transport uh and I did make a reference
to whether if you can deliver it almost
like a pizza I think it developed a
little humorous response or or maybe
even less than that and then we're
looking at a companion bill which allows
alternate grow
sites um which allows which is going to
permit alternate grow sites for these
distribution centers and yet that they
were talking about being able to
transport it from their grow centers to
their distribution centers under tight
controls now if the case is one of two
things and the third the additional
thing is is that they want to convert
from nonprofit to uh be able to
incorporate to some degree I'm assuming
that's either going to be either an es
if they're going to file their taxes As
an X Corp or a C Corp on this I don't
know that you could that's for somebody
else to decide if you're growing
marijuana but the point being that um if
they're going to regulate and tightly
control transport
um why can't we have legislation that
tightly controls delivery uh to to
people to individual users and the other
representation that was made was that
cost was a factor and so somehow you can
grow your own and mitigate the cost well
if they're that concerned about their
people number one and they want to
convert to a corporation which they said
would give them a little more financial
flexibility why not be able to use that
incorporation Authority to be able to
have a financial need-based program to
give the people a break on their current
product that way we would be uh
addressing those needs and at the same
time I think engaging in prudent public
policy by keeping uh quite frankly
keeping marijuana out of the hands of
people who shouldn't be getting it while
it's still federally illegal and my and
Beyond Beyond being an attorney who
deals in federal and criminal defense as
well as state criminal defense um that's
a whole different matter but for those
reasons I don't really think I can
support this
bill um representative lamon and then
representative
Nal yeah I I don't think that this bill
has that much to do with um the
nonprofit or for-profit status of some
of these companies I see this as a
person who has has a medical U marijuana
card for their condition wanting to grow
their
own uh marijuana at home for their needs
and anyone can do this without a card
but these are individuals who want to
use this product for their pain or
whatever
reason um and they're not I I would
think they're probably less likely to um
grow the marijuana to sell or to give to
anyone else they're trying to meet their
own needs and stay within the law and I
don't really have a problem with it any
more than you know someone that is
manufacturing their own beer you know
it's it's for um their own personal
use representative Nel I I feel
obligated to throw this in since this is
a public hearing but I think I was one
of the first doctors ever certify a
patient for cannabis in this state I've
certified a lot of patients for cannabis
in this state um I believe that it has
value um more as an adjunct than as a
primary um medication but at the same
point I don't have a single patient that
smokes it I don't have a single patient
that inhales it I don't have a single
patient that Vapes it even the the
dispensaries we try really hard to not
use that mode of delivery as a method of
of taking this stuff and it's same with
opioids too injection is really a bad
way to do it pills are a lot better and
so um when you're doing it at home doing
it this way the odds are you probably
are going to be smoking it which we just
don't think medically is a good way to
do it um but I just feel obligated to
say that thank you other discussion
representative McKay thank you Mr
chairman if I didn't uh mention this
before Jerry caner who was the chairman
of that
committee uh was a professional
doctors uh said that they voted to
legislation other discussion
representative mlan yeah I mean I'll
just be brief I think I you know I I I
respect representative Nagel's point
about you know the complexity um with
respect to the atc's and and what they
do and the likely inability to replicate
that at home you know that being said
one of the things you will be able to do
at home is not know that you're you're
making a product that's laced with
fentanyl right and so I think that
that's so while you're not getting that
same caliber of product there there
there is still the the safety concern
for me and I really think this just
allows people to to live within the law
if if you're looking to go and make a
huge amount of marijuana you know for
for sale to to third parties um you're
probably going to be doing that with or
without this so I don't think it really
moves a needle in that direction so I
will be supporting the Bill thank you Mr
chair all right um I think that pretty
well addresses it so the motion is ought
to pass as amended on HB 53 I'll ask
damus R kofalt yes RIP
Nagel rip poov yes clerk votes yes r
marel
no Brett McGrath
no rep
Sebert won't yell into it um yes rep
McKay yes rep Woods yes rep Palmer yes
rep TZ yes rep lontine
yes vot is 13 to4 motion
passes 13 to
four um that prevents us from calendar
correig right PR yeah we can't I don't
believe we can have more than two um
against um will there be I assume
probably not a minority report or will
there be huh we don't need one
no and it sounds like it would be a
republican Republicans writing it
probably if it if it were one and
I okay that's usually found
on we don't need one so no there's no
minority no Minority Report but regular
calendar because it's so
no it's on right right and majority
reports can be rep coal
uh yeah representative Kofa you're
writing the majority
report okay I had a feeling you were
going to say that he's very
quick what happens
to it'll it'll go to a Voice vote unless
somebody wants to
speak
right right no it's the speaker will
bring it up uh and and he'll call for
vote and nobody signed up to speak for
it
then and and there's no need to he'll
just the'll I mean I will have to give
names just in case somebody you know it
happens but
what all right moving on
hb26 um representative McGrath I believe
you have a motion on oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry well you do have a motion but it's
on the amendment
right yes I'd like to move the amendment
to House Bill
84h is there a second uh representative
delus I believe you have seconding okay
I would you like to speak to your motion
representative McGrath sure the
amendment basically just moves the onus
for the bill from the pharmacist filling
it to the Doctor Who's prescribing
it
okay any other discussion on this
amendment any other comments AC
questions saying none uh I will call ask
the clerk if he's ready to call the
rooll motion is ought to pass on
0184 rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
damus rep kofalt yes rep Nagel yes rep
poov yes
clerk votes yes rep marel
yes rep McGrath yes rep
Sebert
yes R McKay
yes rep Woods yes R Palmer yes rep tez
yes rep lontine
yes rep
Lucas rep McDonald yes
one 17 to zero motion passes okay thank
you uh next up uh representative McGrath
I believe you now have another motion uh
yes a motion to move Bill
126 uh to pass uh to pass is amended and
and um who seconded oh okay
representative delish who seconded okay
uh do you wish to speak brother to your
motion yeah it's just a common sense
bill that after a year of monthly
prescriptions a patient can get three
months at a
time okay any other discussion
representative Nal thanks Mr chairman I
just love this solution for a really
complicated problem um we he and I have
been talking the sponsor and I have been
talking about this for quite a while and
it's the exact same solution we came up
with people on long-term opioid
therapies that after a while it's
functionally not helpful to make
somebody have to go in every month to
get something or every week to get
something when they've shown that
they're a good patient so I thought this
was rewarding people for good behavior
and I thought it was a good
solution okay any other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
Clark to call all the motion is ought to
pass as amended on hp1
126 rep Meer yes rep mlan yes rep damus
rep kofalt yes rep
Nagel rep poov yes Burk votes yes rep
marel yes rep McGrath
yes rep
Sebert yes rep McKay
yes rep Woods yes rep Palmer yes rep TZ
yes rep lontine yes rep Lucas yes re
consent hearing known will that'll go on
consent okay and the final bill of the
day and I know there was some concern
over this and representative TZ you and
I spoke about it I repres I'm Miss um
not sure what her title I think she's a
director director Rogers and I um spoke
she's from the Department uh about 576
FN and they understand that U it's an
early Bill we want to move ahead with it
and uh they didn't seem too concerned
about what you know I I told them what
the likely outcome would be so um this
point representative um D I believe G to
this we 26 but okay no I H you down for
576 unless you want someone else to do
it sure um
um we were doing it yeah I I moved that
uh we itl on HB
576 and wases Ma I believe you were
seconding that yes do representative V
do you wish to speak to your
motion or buy
guy um just real brief this is way too
expensive for what it's doing it's a
handful of people um I I don't see any
point to it uh that I can also talk a
little bit about why it's so expensive
um tracking this data because they
specifically mentioned that they were
using Salesforce to track this data and
so what that requires is going into
Salesforce and setting up a a data flow
for that specific data which is why it's
so expensive
so anyone else have any comments or
questions concerns thoughts
representative Tes um I had understood
that we asked a lot of questions and
wanted more information about potential
alternative databases cuz uh The Way It
Was Written they costed it out in a
certain way and we had a lot of
conversation about exploring
Alternatives so that's why I had hoped
we could not execute
today um you know representative TZ and
I was speaking earlier about this and uh
you know in the four years or going on
five years I've been here especially as
the three that I've been doing this as
chairman I've always admired the fact
that when we ask for information anybody
we ask is very prompt about getting back
to us because they recognize we're on
timetables and and they never know when
the bill might get exact uh and plus
this is an early bill and we at this
point we're looking at having hearings
even during school vacation week for
this committee because we do have so
many bills so um I think it's important
that we move ahead with this but U
obviously the committee is I mean I'm
I'm I want to listen so representative
Nagel with that with that said I think
this it brings up important issues that
they did not address in a cost effective
manner I know there's better ways to do
this is this a bill that we could retain
and think about
later I'm sorry for not bringing that up
earlier but I never thought about it
till right now well right now the motion
on on the floor is itl so that would
have to be withdrawn but I'm not sure if
this I guess that again um during
discussion on itl we can discuss if
that's the the direction the committee
wants to go in or if we want to um you
know obviously it's got to pass this
committee as to what the ultimate action
is if itl fails then we could certainly
discuss retain but right now we have
another motion on the floor was there
any
sorry that's kind of what I figured but
I just thought I needed to ask it I I
mean I I there's nothing wrong with
letting this bill go home letting people
sit down think about it work it out a
lot better in a multi-stakeholder manner
come back and with a solution that's
much more more cost effective than this
and there's other people in the country
that are doing this there's no reason we
have to be the ones and there's no
so representative
lonte yeah I I would like to vote
against the itl I I believe that the
fiscal
note uh was not realistic at all
compared to what other states um have
been able to implement Reg states that
have much larger population than we do
and I think it is a um there aren't that
many cases but it's a very serious
disease and we don't know what causes it
and we have no cure and um by having a
registry it's the first step to allow um
you know both the individuals Medical
Care they can gather a lot of
information but for epidemiologists to
start
tracking uh where the cases are and it's
really
important representative McLean thank
you Mr CH you know La last year we um
held over 15 to 20 bills and I know that
we only had subcommittees really to look
at two of them so we retained all this
stuff to look at and because this is not
going into an interim study if this is
retained we're just going to be dealing
with this again uh in January of next
year and I think um your comment that
you know we had asked the department for
additional information and they're just
in really seem to be a lot of fire there
um I just don't know that we're really
going to be doing a lot with retention
and we're going to be back here again
next year so I would I would favor just
going forward um and it Ling the bill
representative
Palmer so I apologize because I missed
the hearing and and
um my recollection from the last time
around was that most of the cases are
followed by
Dartmouth um
and and I guess what I'm thinking and
that one of the thoughts was that they
would provide the data and I guess they
decided not to do that and so I'm just
wondering what the value would be if
there relatively few cases and
dartmouth's already following the cases
that there are are we getting it not
into our hands maybe but into the hands
of people who are looking into the
causes of ALS are we already getting
about as much as we'll ever get in the
state of New Hampshire since it's such a
small state with so few cases I don't
know uh representative Nel my
understanding is
actually the cases that are followed
within the state that they're the ones
that follow the most but there's a
substantial number when you're talking
26 cases I don't I don't know what
substantial number means that are
actually fought in Massachusetts not
here and that was what they wanted to do
was capture that data too that was the
whole benefit for it but um with that
said
um this is a two committee Bill correct
so we it is yes so it's going to finance
and with that number it's never making
it out of there so no matter what we do
it's not going anywhere so we might want
to just save them the pain and suffering
I guess representative kland
representative T is um so I want to to
Echo some comments that have been made I
also want to acknowledge that um you
know one of our colleagues uh The
Honorable Mark algro um passed away from
this uh two years ago now uh and it was
devastating to watch that um so I think
many of us would very much like to do
something to help people who are
afflicted with this at the same time
though I I don't see that this
accomplishes that I I think that given
the the very small number of cases and
the likelihood that the the Right
medical professionals already have high
visibility to those cases I just don't
see it even if the fiscal note were
substantially smaller than it is um you
know retaining this bill I also agree is
just going to we're going to circle back
and probably come to the exact same
result
um so I I I just think it is probably
best for us to just make the decision to
itl it at this point representative
Tes thank you um
I have learned in the functioning of
this committee that we make the policy
decisions and we let the fiscal
committee do their part um so I would
urge us to consider like everyone has
said it's a very devastating disease
there is no registry or place where the
data is being collected and I didn't
know about the cyano bacterium
Association and I think it should get
studied and the fact that rates in New
Hampshire seem to be higher than other
places so um I would urge us
to and and I I think what happened is it
wasn't explicitly clear that we were
expecting them to come back with more
information like that that was clear in
my head but I don't I've talked to other
people I don't think everyone thought
that was clear and so they would um you
know uh with a little more time I think
they would like to explore but again we
don't know what that price would come
down to I think we all agree it should
be a lot less um so I would urge us to
do the right thing from a health
perspective thank you representative
Maser while I appreciate the intent of
this bill um I did make a note from the
hearing that could this be handled by
the oversight committee there was a
mention of that in the hearing so taking
this outside of where they recommended
it go now um so that was you know that
it could this could possibly this stats
tracking could be handled elsewhere and
without the fiscal note that they
brought to us so that's I'm going to go
itl just because I think there's there's
other ways of doing this and this is not
the way I will say that I sit on the
oversight committee along with um with
representative Weber and um
representative Woods you're going to be
on that too AR you and um I know
representative Murphy has been on there
in the past a former member of this
committee I'm the vice chairman of the
committee uh chairman Mark Pearson um
who's also under children and family law
he's the chairman of that committee we
do hear updates every month uh we meet
the last Friday of every month we we
hear about updates on um new system
design we hear updates on uh Medicaid uh
Dental the med Medicaid dental program
and numerous other things
uh so this is is something that could
possibly be addressed in that manner uh
I don't set the agenda for that
committee the chairman does obviously
but it C we do certainly handle other
regular updates representative Nagel and
if you do it that way you don't need a
statute to do it it's a departmental
thing and that that it solves the
problem with if we were to ask the
commissioner or any or Henry Litman or
whoever the Henry liman is State
Medicaid director or
whoever uh you know they they've been
very accommodating and and again that's
the purpose of the oversight committee
representative Woods yeah um I'm just
going to than um um Bill know what you
just said uh in terms of having
oversight committee um I forgotten two
four years ago or something like that
there was a big push um I think um
representative Edwards was pending that
uh movement to completely redo just this
issue the data systems and their
interaction because they were so
desparate and they couldn't talk to one
another and and I forgotten the details
uh but uh there was a committee
established just to look at databases
and not just the database but security
and making sure they wouldn't be hacked
uh like some of the other things we hear
about um and so I I think to ask that
question at the oversight committee
would be uh would be that way I would
think we should go with this um the um
the study itself um uh is not providing
a treatment um and at the moment we
really can't provide any prevention
because we don't have the data uh so the
data uh but this I just it was I made a
note to myself uh fiscal Noe is totally
out of
whack um I just didn't quite to uh
admittedly the data has to be fairly
robust be because the data uh we don't
know where people came from people come
to New Hampshire to retire did they get
their exposure in
Texas um so it does have to be fairly
robust in the sense of very
detailed um so I can see where it's it's
not just a matter of oh you have ALS
fine check the box thank you very much
not that we're all done uh it's it is
more robust than that but still I this
was way out of out of whack but it would
also seem that interfacing with Dr
stumble um uh when I I I actually had a
bill five years ago uh which I pulled
just because of secondary issues uh and
uh to coordinate with Dr
stumble um and almost be a
repository for his data uh rather than
generating any new data and I think
that's something else that the oversight
committee would have the flexibility to
look at so I'm I'm going to vote itl
with the hope that um our vice chair of
oversight committee can get it on the
agenda I will definitely talk to the
chairman about
that representative Nel I'm sorry for
throwing one more thing and but the
other big problem that I had with this
bill was that it's being referred to as
a critical health problem and I don't
think we ever fully really defined what
a critical health problem means and
something that affects 66 people in the
state I think it's a big step to refer
to it in that particular statute and one
more thing Dr STL and I work on we're on
the rare disease commission together
and there's not definitely a clear
association with cyanobacteria it's a
theory of his he believes that
environmental exposure is a signifant
play may play a significant role he's
very interested in veterans there's a
lot of veterans data on exposure to the
things that they get exposed to so he's
trying to prove a theory it's not that
the theory is tied in stone yet so
that's why they want the data so that
they can prove
Association other qu uh representative
lante well um to representative Nagel's
point though I think the
only only by having a registry where you
can um first make sure it's not the same
patient being counted in Vermont and
Massachusetts it's not just about
collecting the numbers and it's being
able to go back because yes maybe you
would disprove that it's cob bacteria
but you might find something else only
by uh having the
registry I can't believe that anyone who
is diagnosed with ALS would object to
participating in the research to look at
perhaps where where they were exposed
and what the cause might be and I don't
I don't really understand how the
oversight committee could possibly
registry yeah it's not it's not a
replacement but how is it solving the
yeah anyway representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh I was the one the other day
that made the fuss about the fact that
it should have gone before the oversight
committee so I'm trying to figure out
how to vote
uh and so I take it that if we Vote
IPL that somebody on the oversight
committee will ask
for that to come before them and I will
do that I and again I can't I don't know
I mean there there's a very specific
statute that addresses the the mission
you're allowed to do that I am yes I I
can't promise anything but I will
explore that and I will say if it's
within our jurisdiction and and I can
bring it up to the Medicaid director
that I see him monthly at those
meetings whatever appropriate personnel
I anyone
else representative
Woods I just I think going with the uh
and it may be a dead end but I think
it's definitely the next uh Avenues to
to go through the oversight committee uh
because they have much more flexibility
in terms of what we can or can't do and
I think would
circumvent um this this big you know
Financial thing which I out of way um um
and anyway
enough other questions discussion
thoughts represent P did you have a hand
up a moment ago
or no I was thinking of it but now I'm
I'm convinced by representative McKay
and representative wood so okay all
right all right all right if there's no
one else I'll ask the clerk to call the
role the motion is it on HB 576
FM rep merer yes rep mlan yes rep
delanis rep kofalt yes rep
Nagel rep poov
yes Burk votes yes R marel yes R McGrath
yes rep
Sebert
yes rep McKay yes rep
Woods rep Palmer yes rep TZ
No rep lontine
no rep Lucas yes rep McDonald
yes vote is 15-2 motion
passes um this consent appropriate
yes consent no objection to
consent all right those are are the only
bills that we had planned to exec today
so that concludes our business anything
else any other questions before we
adjourn till next
Wednesday hearing none We Stand
majority